GOOD MORNING I AM CALLING THIS
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER
WILL SAYS THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. O'DONNELL HERE. KILEY
THERE BENNETT HERE DALLY PLEASE
YEAH MCCARTY. QUIKSILVER HERE.
THAT'S FIVE WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE TWELVE
BILLS ON FILE THERE ARE THREE
MEASURES ON CONSENT THE THREE
BILLS ON CONSENT ARE AS FOLLOWS
AB FORTY SIX AB NINE SEVEN SIX
AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR THOSE OF
THE BILLS ON CONSENT. TWO
MEASURES HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM
CONSENT THOSE MEASURES ARE AB
THREE ZERO NINE. AB EIGHT EIGHT
THREE THOSE TWO HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM CONSENT. PLEASE
NOTE THAT WE WILL BE HEARING
THE BILL'S IN FILE ORDER WITH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESENTING
LAST IF A MEMBER IS NOT PRESENT
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THEY
WILL PRESENT AT THE END. OF THE
HEARING. IN ORDER TO MOVE
THROUGH OUR AGENDA EFFICIENTLY
WE WILL ATTEMPT TO. SPEND NO
MORE THAN TWENTY MINUTES ON
EACH BILL. WHICH HAS BEEN OUR
PRACTICE. ARE ATTEMPTED
PRACTICE. OF THIS YEAR. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE IN THE ROOM
WILL HEAR UP TO TEN MINUTES OF
TELEPHONE TESTAMENT ANY AND UP
TO TEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
AND CAPITOL PARK. LIMITATIONS
ON TESTIMONY WERE NOTICED IN
THE DAILY FILE AND I PERMITTED
BY OUR COMMITTEE RULES. AND
THIS IS BEEN R. PRATT ARE
CONSISTENT PRACTICE WITH BILLS
ALL THIS YEAR. OTHER COMMITTEES
HAVE A MUCH STRICTER
LIMITATIONS ON TIME ALLOTMENTS.
AND HOW MANY SPEAKERS CAN SPEAK
CENTER TO OF ALL. OURS ARE A
LOT MORE EXPENSIVE THAN SOME
OTHER COMMITTEES BUT STILL.
THEY ARE LIMITED- ANOTHER
COMMITTEE IS USING THIS ROOM IN
THE AFTERNOON AND WILL NEED TO
PROVIDE TIME FOR CLEANING
BETWEEN HEARINGS. IF YOU ARE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH ON THE
PHONE YOUR WELCOME TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THIS WILL BECOME PART
OF THE FITIAL RECORD OF THE
BILL AGAIN IF YOU ARE. UNABLE
TO GET IN. FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY AND IT WILL
BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD. AND YOU CAN SEND THAT
TO THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OFFICE BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR AGENDA. I HAVE A
STATEMENT TO READ REGARDING OUR
PROCESS TODAY. WE CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM SO
WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE. WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE INSIDE THIS
HEARING ROOM. AS WE HAVE ALL
YEAR. WE ARE ALSO REQUIRING.
THAT MASS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BE MADE BY ALL MEMBERS
OF THE TO. IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A
MASK WE WILL PROVIDE ONE FOR
YOU. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON A BILL YOU MAY
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE WHEN WE
INVITE COMMENT. FROM PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM IN THE ROOM. WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
TESTIMONY. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS AS FOLLOWS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION WEBSITE
IS ON THE SCREEN. AND THE- IT
AGAIN AND IT IS A AGAIN IS ON
THE SCREEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN. PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR PRESENTATION. AGAIN IF
YOU ARE CALLING AND PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. HE AUTHORED PRESENTING
THE BILL. BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
THERE YOU WE WISH TO TESTIFIED
IS BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE TO AVOID
GETTING- IN LINE ON ANOTHER
BILL THE BILL YOU MAY NOT WISH
TO WEIGH IN ON. PLEASE FOLLOW
THE MODERATORS INSTRUCTIONS SO
THAT YOU WILL TESTIFY ON THE
CORRECT BILL. PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR IVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES IS IMPORTANT. YOU NEED
ELIMINATE THAT BACKGROUND NOISE
BECAUSE WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS. AS
YOU'RE CALLED ON WE WILL BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BECAUSE OF
THE BACKGROUND NOISE SO THAT'S
IMPORTANT. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE NUMBER AT. NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT SEVEN. THERE IS ALSO A
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION HERE
IN CAPITOL PARK ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF THIS CAPITAL OF THE
CAPITAL. AS I NOTED EARLIER WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEES
WEBSITES ON THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION. COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
AGAIN THESE ARE THE SAME
PROTOCOLS IN THE SAME PROCESS
WE HAVE FOLLOWED ALL YEAR FOR
ALL BILLS AND ALL COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. FINALLY I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS DISRUPTIONS THAT ARE
HEARING PROCESS. THE ASSEMBLY
IS EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMEDIAN FOR
PROCEEDINGS ON A LAST YEAR.
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPT THE
SERVICE OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE HEARING
IS ABSOLUTELY PROHIBITED SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE REMOVING A
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE SPEAKING
LONGER. THAN THE TIME ALLOTTED
EXTENDED DISCUSSION ON MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF
THE HEARING AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONTACT I WILL TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS TODAY. EVEN
INDIVIDUALS TO DISRUPT HER
HEARING PROCESS I WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT THE CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS
MAY RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND THE
NATURE OF DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT.
IF THE CONTRACT DOES NOT STOP I
REQUEST THE ASSISTANCE OF THE
SERGEANTS AND ESCORTING THAT
INDIVIDUAL. OUT OF THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COOPERATION TODAY AND I REALIZE
WE'RE- OPERATING UNDER VERY
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES. WITH
THAT LET'S MOVE ON OUR FIRST
AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
WHICH IS HERE- HE HAS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE OH NINE.
MR CABLE YOU MAY PROCEED ONE
READY. WITH AB THREE OH NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PLEASE
TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
TODAY AND YOUR HELP AND
ASSISTANCE FROM THE COMMITTEE
ON THIS BILL AND I AM PLEASED
2% AB THREE OH NINE THE BILL
THAT REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A MODEL
REFERRAL PROTOCOL TO ADDRESS
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
THIS COMMITTEE IS NO DOUBT
AWARE OF THE STATE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS WE FACED IN
CALIFORNIA ONE THAT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY EXACERBATED BY
COVERT NINETEEN. TEACHERS ARE
OFTEN THE FIRST TO NOTICE
CHANGES IN STUDENT BEHAVIOR
THAT CAN SIGNAL MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES YEAH EDUCATORS REPORT A
LACK OF PREPAREDNESS AND
ADDRESSING MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. AB THREE OH NINE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONSULT WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
EDUCATION EXPERTS. TO DESIGN A
MENTAL HEALTH REFERRAL PROTOCOL
FOR VOLUNTARY USE BY SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT. THEIR EMPLOYEES
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND TRAINING
TO A BETTER ADDRESSING MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY- DELORES DURAN FLORES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND LYDIA BORN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU AND
REQUEST WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB THREE OH NINE. GREAT
THANK YOU- MR GABRIEL. BOB LET
WHITE LET'S GO TO OUR YOUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DOROTHY FOR S. NINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER A
QUARTER OF A MILLION CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES STATEWIDE. I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE OH
NINE THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION COULD
DEVELOP MODEL FOR ALL PROTOCOLS
HELP STUDENTS OFFERING FROM
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SH AB
THREE OH NINE INCLUDES
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROTOCOL CAN
INSURANCE THAT THEY ARE DRAFTED
WITH SCHOOL STAFF AND MINE. OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF BECAUSE THEY
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WORK WITH
EVERY DAY THEY CARE ABOUT THEM
AND THEY WANT TO DO WHAT THEY
CAN TO HELP THEM. THE PANDEMIC
HAS HEIGHTENED THE NEED FOR
EIGHTY THREE ALONG THE
CHALLENGING TIME FOR ALL OF US.
CARS DIDN'T. THEN MAKE A CHANGE
LIVES THEY CAN'T IRAQ WITH THE-
FRIEND BUT IF. MATE THE WAY
THEY GET TO. THEY CAN'T PLAY
THE FOUR THEY LOVE THEM
GRADUATION DIFFERENT. AND MANY
OF THEIR HAVE THEIR- OR
STRUGGLING KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEAD AND ON THE TABLE. IN
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME BELA
WITH THE- THAT ARE STOCKS ROM
THE- AND OTHER MENTAL HEALTH AT.
AB THREE ON IRAQI. THE THAT.
STAFF NO THIS IS ARE THE NEXT
HELP. FIVE THOUGHT THAT WOULD
GUIDE. ON HOW TO HELP AND GET
THE HELP IT'S BEEN SUFFERING
FROM. HEALTH ISSUES. HOW TO
CALL SAVE IT'S BEEN FIVE YEAH I
THOUGHT. THEY YOU TO NEXT
WITNESS- LYDIA BORN OF THE
SCHOOL NURSE ORGANISE. LET ME
SEE IF I FEAR ONE MOMENT MISTER.
THE BILL. IT LOOKS LIKE LYDIA
DROPS SHOULD NO LONGER ON THE
CALL. OKAY SO WHAT WE'LL DO IS
SEE OF LYDIA COMES BACK ON WE
WILL CURE IN FORT FOR COMMENT.
OUR PRESENTATION. WHY DON'T WE
GO TO- ARE THERE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES THAT WISH TO TESTIFY.
I DON'T BELIEVE THERE ARE ANY
WHAT WE OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WHY DON'T WE GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
RIGHT NOW AND THEN OF LYDIA
COMES ON WILL HAVE HER- WEIGH
IN ON THE BILL- I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL MR
GABRIEL THIS IS- THIS VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC. TODAY BUT BY
THE WAY. FOR A LONG TIME IT'S
BEEN BUT AN IMPORTANT TOPIC.
AND THIS- I KNOW I. HAD THIS
BILL A FEW YEARS AGO UNDER
PREVIOUS GOVERNOR THAT VETO
THIS- AND THIS BILL TYPICALLY
BILL COME FROM A SPONSOR
SOMEONE BRINGS YOU A PROBLEM
SOMEONE BRINGS YOU AN IDEA
SOMEONE FROM THE PUBLIC.
SOMEONE FROM AN INDUSTRY FROM
I'M FROM THE SCHOOL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. THIS BILL
ACTUALLY. CAME ALREADY
ORIGINALLY FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM
WHERE AND I. AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER HAD A STUDENT. THAT I
NOTICED WAS HAVING ISSUES AND I
WENT TO THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR.
AND I BASICALLY HANDED THE
ISSUE OFF TO HER. AND I JUST
DIDN'T FEEL THAT EVEN ACCOUNTS
OR KNEW WHERE TO GO. EXACTLY
NOW THAT MAY HAVE CHANGED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS I HOPE I
HAS BEEN. I DON'T KNOW THAT IT
HAS BUT I THINK WHAT THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO IS REALLY BILLS
PROTOCOL SOME POLICY AT THE
SCHOOL SITE LEVEL. THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT AT THE SCHOOL SITE
LEVEL SO THAT WHEN A TEACHER NO
STUDENTS HAVING STRUGGLES-
ESPECIALLY BE THEY MENTAL- THAT
THERE IS A PLACE FOR THAT
TEACHER TO GO. AND THE ISSUE OF
BECAUSE THE TEACHER SHOULD BE
DIAGNOSED SHOULDN'T BE TREATING
TO THE TEACHER MAYBE. QUITE OFF
BASE IT MAY JUST BE A BAD DAY
FOR THAT STUDENT- BUT THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME PROTOCOLS AND
POLICIES SOME NEXT STEPS. SO
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY AND SOME
FINALITY. TO THE ISSUE. AT A
SCHOOL SITE IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. AND OFTEN. POLICIES
GET BUILT UP AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL NO RELIEF USE DOWN TO THE
LOCAL LEVEL THIS AND IT TO DO
IT SCHOOL SITE LEVEL-
PERFECTLY. BUT THIS IS ONE THAT
WE REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE HELP STUDENTS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING MENTALLY HOW DO WE
IDENTIFY THEM. HAVE WHO DOES A
TEACHER GO TO AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS SO I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS GIVEN MY OWN EXPERIENCE
IN THE CLASSROOM MORE THAN ONCE
HAVING THIS ISSUE. AS A TEACHER
NOT EVEN KNOWING DO I GO TO
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST. DO I GO TO
SCHOOL COUNSELOR. SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST ISN'T ALWAYS
THERE- I'D G. MAYBE I KNOW I
GOT ACCOUNTS OR DO I GO TO- YOU
KNOW ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL WHO
WHAT ARE THOSE THE SCHOOL SITE.
PARKS AND BY AND LARGE THEY'RE
NOT ESTABLISHED ACROSS OUR
STATE THEY'RE NOT CONSISTENT
ACROSS OUR STATE AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS. BILL SEEKS TO DO NOT
TO MICROMANAGE BUT TO GIVE
SCHOOL SITES A PATH. TO HELP
STUDENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING AND
IDENTIFY THEM. AND GET THEM
SERVICES SO I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS BILL. I THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING IT TODAY ARE THERE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THAT WISH TO COMMENT
ON THIS BILL. OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SAT. OKAY UGH. UGH
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE- LYDIA
BORN ONLINE YET YOU KNOW. SHE
IS NOT ON AS OF NOW OKAY K.
LYDIA WASN'T SUPPORT YEARS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION. SO THERE AGAIN
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST COUNSELOR
EVEN A SCHOOL NURSE ONE OF THE
SCHOOLERS OF THERE THAT DAY
SOUTH OF THAT. HOW DOES ALL IT
WORKED OUT I THINK THAT'S THE
INTENT OF YOUR BILL SO THAT'S A
GOOD THING SO WHY DON'T WE GO
TO THE PHONE NOW WILL GO FOR UP
TO TEN MINUTES OF PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. TO THE
PHONES THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORDS.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE NINE
ZERO IF YOU'RE INTO PORT FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB. THREE OH
NINE. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF. ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF ONE TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN DO YOU
HAVE A TIME YOU. TONY TOOK
THEIR- CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANKS TO BOTH THE LINE OF
ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS COMITATO ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WITH THE
SUPPORT OF AMANDA CONVENTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF THE TWO OH SEVEN. ERICA
HOPPING ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF TWO
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LINE IS ALREADY OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOANNE DOT BEN
HOME FULLER OPPOSE. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF THE TWO
OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH
NATALIE ELLIS EDUCATOR FROM
PASADENA STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE YOUNG OF THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND GAGGLE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE OF A TWO TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS KISHA
ACTION. ORANGE SEIJO PATTERN
AND AYE OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU AND MEXICO SO LINE OF TWO
OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU ALL NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHEN ONE PARENT IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL WANTING TO MOVE
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
BOTTOM LINE OF TWO TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ASSEMBLY
ROSENBERGER YEAH YOU IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH. BUT HELLO I HAVE
ONE MORE. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DISABILITIES
ONE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES ARE KALIDASA
WITHOUT PROBABLY GOING HOME. WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THREE OH NINE THE END OF THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AMONG ALL SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. RESTRICTIONS ON
MOVEMENT FAMILY SEPARATION
DEPRESSION AND THE INABILITY TO
INTERACT WITH FRIENDS HAVE
TAKEN A TOLL ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH OF VALUE. CHILDREN ARE
REACTING TO THESE ISSUES BY
VISITING SLEEP ISSUES. OVER
EATING AND BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS
WHILE MANYOF OUR STUDENTS OUR
DISTANCE LEARNING EFFECTS OF
THE CHANGES IN THEIR
ENVIRONMENT STILL VIABLE.
SCHOONERS SPEND OVER 30% OF
THEIR TIME PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND WE AS THE
PRIMARY HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
THE SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN THE FIRST
TO A FAST. AN ADULT A FATHER
FINDS OF MENTAL OR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES. WHICH AFFECT THE
ACHIEVEMENT ATTENDANCE AND
CHRYSANTHOS SCHOOLS. EARLY
DETECTION A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND ACCESS TO THE
TREATMENT HAS PROVEN EFFECTIVE
IN LESSENING THE ASSOCIATED
FONG. DEVELOPMENT OF A
PROCESSES NECESSARY FOR
ASSISTING IN IDENTIFYING
PROBLEMS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
HAVING REFORM PRO THE CURRENT.
PROTOCOLS FOR STAFF WILL LIKELY
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF THE
STUDENTS THAT WE CAN SERVICES
TO ADDRESS. MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE ARE A STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB
THREE ZERO NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY AND NEXT. NEXT
NEXT OVER THE LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ARE YOU READY OF BORN
REPRESENTING AMERICAN GAMAY
PEDIATRICS WE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE ZERO NINE THANK YOU.
EXEGGUTOR LINE OF IT TWO THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY
TWO THIRTY A LINE IS OPEN-
SORRY I'M I ACTUALLY WAS
CALLING BIRD EIGHTY THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. OKAY WE'RE ON AB THREE
OH NINE. OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN WE ARE AB
THREE OH NINE AND WE'RE GOING
TO LINE AT TWO TWENTY ONE. THEY
LEFT Q. AS WELL WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK USE
ANY SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. SENIOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM WITH
COACH IS THERE ANY- WE'RE
OPPOSITION OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN CAPITOL
PARK. IN THIS AGAIN THIS FOR AB.
THREE ZERO NINE. I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS ANY SO WHY
DON'T WE BRING BACK I WAS OUR
MOTION YEAH THAT'S BEEN MOVED
AND SECONDED WAS OUR SECOND KID
TO MOVED AND SECONDED- DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE MISTER DONNA
COULD I JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT
FOR BECAUSE OF HIGH SCHOOL MAP
OF THE HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELOR
FOR SEVEN YEARS SO I. J. DISP
APPRECIATED MOVING. THANK YOU-
IT'S BEEN MOTIONS THAT HE MAY
CLOSE DOWN THANK YOU MISTER
CHARGES TWENTY WHY SIGNIFICAN
I'M NOT SURE THAT ALL THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THE CALLED
IN WITH WITH FOR MY BILL I MUCH
OF THE DAY I'M IF I PICKED UP A
BUNCH OF SUPPORT OPPOSITION
LAST TWENTY MINUTES BUT- WHAT
IF WE JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR TEAM FOR THE FOR THE
WORK ON THIS AND I THINK YOUR
LIVED EXPERIENCE HERE ON THIS
ISSUE- IS BECAUSE AS THE
ANALYSIS NOTES BACKED UP BY A
LOT OF DATA ON A LOT OF
RESEARCH ABOUT THIS PROBLEM OUR
TEACHERS ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES. HOW MANY OF THEM
EXPRESSED THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WE HAD A SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN THE
STATE PRIOR TO COVERED THAT IS
BEEN DEEPLY EXACERBATED ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD
WITH PARENTS WITH EDUCATORS
WITH ADMINISTRATORS AND MY
DISTRICT POINTS TO THE FACT
THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS
AROUND STUDENTS AND COMING BACK
TO SCHOOL ARE VERY PROFOUND SO
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR A LONG TIME AND I
THINK THIS IS HERE TO GET IT
DONE AND. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
IN ABOUT. GREAT THANK. YOU- THE-
IS TO APPROPRIATE- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
SO DONALD HI KILEY KILEY I'D
BENNETT BENNETT I. DALLY B. HI
LEE I MCCARTY CORK SILVA HI
QUICK SILVA HI. THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES GREAT THANK YOU YOUR
PROJECT- AND WE'RE NEXT WE'RE
GONNA MOVED- AB NINETY TWO BY
MISS- REYES A. B. NINETY TWO-
AND JUST TO NOTE FOR THE FOLKS
ON THE PHONE WE'RE NOW AN
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY TWO- IT
SPEAKS TO A CHILD CARE- AND-
IT'S NOT THE CHARTER SCHOOL OF
THE OCEAN AWAY ON ON THAT
THAT'S- AB ONE THREE ONE SIX AB
ONE THREE ONE SIX YOU WANT YOU
ON THE PHONE. WHEN- THAT BILL
COMES UP- W. AGAIN WEREN'T A
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY TWO BY
MISS REYES RIGHT NOW IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AND MR S. YOU
MAY PROCEED ALREADY. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY
PRESENTS YOU AB NINETY TWO
WHICH WILL CREATE AN EQUITABLE
SLIDING SCALE FOR FAMILY
FEASIBLE ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN
ON WORKING FAMILIES. STRUGGLING
TO PAY FOR CHILD CARE.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE STATES FOR PARENTS
WHO NEED CHILD CARE SERVICES.
WELL THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
STATE AND FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAMS THAT HELP. FAMILIES
PAY FOR CHILD CARE FAMILIES WHO
NEED CARE MUST STILL PAY WHAT
IS CALLED FAMILY FEES. THESE
FEES GROW AS INCOME RISES AND
CAN BE UP TO SIX HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE DOLLARS. PER MONTH. WHICH
IS UNAFFORDABLE FOR MANY
WORKING FAMILIES THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
HEIGHTENED THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE.
ESPECIALLY FOR WORKING MOTHERS
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO
ARE SIGNIFICANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL
WORKFORCE. IN LIGHT OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
ECONOMIC RECESSION PARENTS NEED
AFFORDABLE CHILD CARE NOW MORE
THAN EVER IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING FOR THEIR FAMILIES.
AB NINETY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES BY CONVENING A WORK
GROUP OF PARENTS. PROVIDERS AND
CHILD CARE STAKEHOLDERS TO
DEVELOP AN EQUITABLE SLIDING
SCALE FOR FAMILY FEES IT
REFLECTS FAMILIES BUDGETS. THIS
BILL WILL PROTECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BY ENSURING THEY DO
NOT ABSORB THE COST OF A
REDUCTION IN FAMILY FEES AND
THAT THE NUMBER OF. CHILD CARE
SPACES IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
REDUCED. FINALLY AB NINETY TWO
WILL UTILIZE FEDERAL FUNDING TO
TEMPORARILY WAIVE FAMILY FEES
FOR ALL FAMILIES UNTIL OCTOBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TO REDUCE
THE HARDSHIPS OF COVERT
NINETEEN ON CALIFORNIANS AND AS
PERMITTED UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
HERE TO TESTIFYING ARE MAKAYLA
MELISSA A PARENTS PAYING HIGH
FAMILY FEES FOR HER CHILD CARE
AND LORI FURSTENFELD WITH THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER. HELLO MY
NAME IS NICK A LOT MORE I'M A
MOTHER TO A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
AND TWO YEAR OLD CHILD I AM
CURRENTLY UP FOUR POINT OH GRAD
STUDENT PURSUING TWO MASTER'S
AT THE MARRIAGE FAMILY
THERAPIST AND BILINGUAL SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST. I'M AN ESSENTIAL
WORK FOR WORKING WITH STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND MEET
ACADEMIC SUPPORT AND I'M A
MEMBER APPARENTLY. I WILL NOT
SHOP HERE. ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR OVER A YEAR THERE WERE ONE
THOUSAND CHILDREN AHEAD OF MY
TIME. WAITING FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE IN MY COMMUNITY ALONE
WHICH IS RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS WAITING
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I KNOW SO
MANY NIGHTS NOT BEING ABLE TO
PUT MY BABY TO SLEEP BECAUSE I
WAS WORKING NIGHTS AS AN- EACH
DRIVER ON TOP OF THE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER AND YET.
THANKS CARE ACT AND THE ACTION
TAKEN BY OUR STATE I WAS ABLE
TO GET IN A CENTRAL WORKER
CHILD CARE VOUCHER. QUIT MY
SECOND JOB FOCUS ON SCHOOL AND
GET THE NIGHT BACK. SO MY BABY
CAN FALL ASLEEP IN MY ARMS
DURING THIS CRAZY YEAR I NEEDED
HIS SUPPORT AS MUCH AS HE
NEEDED NINE. EXPRESSLY IN MAY
OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WHEN MY
THEN ONE YEAR OLD BECAME
EXTREMELY ILL DUE. TO
CONTRACTING HOLDEN NINETEEN.
AND ALTHOUGH I'M NOT I GRATEFUL
FOR THE- I DIDN'T KNOW THAT I
HAVE TO PAY FAMILY. FOR THE
SUBSEA. IT THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MY- SOMEONE MIGHT
THINK THAT THREE HUNDRED OF
THEM A LOT TO PAY FOR CHILD
CARE BUT WE ARE LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK. I'D MAXED OUT ON
THE STUDENT LOAN AND CREDIT
CARD. MY HUSBAND IS ANOTHER
ESSENTIAL WORKER. HAVE A LONG
COMMUTE. SO A LOT OF THESE
MONIES GOING TO GAS. SHOULD
CHECK THINGS ARE RIGHT. I BONTA
PAYMENT PLAN WITH PG&E IN ORDER
TO PAY MY CHILD CARE FAMILY
THE- AMERICAN HAVING TO READ. A
LECTURE THIRTY IN ORDER TO PAY
FOR CHILD CARE. NOW IT BEING
FOR A LIMITED. NEWS THAT WE
HEARD DOLLARS IMMEDIATELY TO
CATCH UP PAIN ALL OF MY BILLS.
AND MAKES ME FEEL EMBARRASSED
TO BE FELL BEHIND PAYING MY
BILLS IS CONNECTED TO HOW I SEE
MYSELF AND THE LEVEL OF
MATURITY AND BEING RESPONSIBLE.
MY FAMILY ALSO TRYING TO FANS
THAT SHE'S MY FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDER HE WAS LIKE FAMILY.
TAX IT REVIEWS OF HERBS. AND
EXPECT MY FAMILY TO MAKE UP THE
DEATH. SHE SPENT OUR CLEANING
CANNOT CLASS YOU CAN EVEN
AFFORD. I FEEL MORE TO IF I
DON'T THEN I CAN THINKS I THINK
MONEY OUT OF SAN OF PACK. AND
OUT AND THE LOSING MY CHILD
ASSISTANT. THANK YOU CAN DO THE
PART THE FED GOVERNMENT HAS
GIVE US WHICH WINDOW TO TAKE A
ACTION TO TAKE ACTION. TO FOR
ALL. WE DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK
TO WAY THINGS WORK WE AN OP. TO
ADDRESS OUR CHILD CARE UP.
CRISIS AND BRING EQUITY OUR
CHAO CARE THE- AND AGAIN BUT AB
NINETY. IS ABOUT TO. CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILIES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK AND I DON'T KNOW
THERE ARE NONE WITNESS GOING TO
TEST DURING A TOP CLASS NOTES
HERE. LAURIE YES THE BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU EVERY CHILD. TO GROW
UP IN A LOVING HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY CAN
BRIBE. AND EVRY PARENT HAS THE
RIGHT TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. AND LORI FURSTENFELD
DIRECTOR OF LEGAL AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY FROM THE
CHILD CARE LAWCENTER. AB NINETY
TWO IS A PANDEMIC RELIEF BILL
THAT IMMEDIATELY PUTS MONEY
BACK INTO THE POCKETS OF FAMILY
AND CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR. AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
CALIFORNIA TEMPORARILY WAIVED
FAMILY FEES FOR ALL FAMILIES
WITH THE PUBLICLY FUNDED CHILD
CARE SUBSIDY THROUGH AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY. FIFTH SOLUTION
ALLOWED PARENTS WHO WERE EAST
CENTRAL WORKERS TO KEEP WORKING
AND ENSURE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
COULD STAY OPEN BY PAYING THEM
IN FULL. FROM SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY UNTIL JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FAMILY FEES
ARE WAIVED ONLY FOR FAMILIES
WHO ARE NOT SENDING THEIR
CHILDREN TO CHILD CARE DO TO
COPE AND- UNDER THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDING LAWS.
WE NOW HAVE A NARROW WINDOW
DISEASES OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE
ALL FAMILIES REALLY FROM FAMILY
FEES NOW FIRST DISTILLED
TEMPORARILY WAY FAMILY FEES FOR
ALL FAMILIES UNTIL OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
TO REDUCE THE HARDSHIPS. OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SECOND
THE FACT CHILD INTO THE BLOCK
GRANT ACT THE MAIN SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. MANDATES THAT THE
REQUIRED THING MY FEES MUST BE
AFFORDABLE AND NOT A BARRIER TO
FAMILIES RECEIVING CHILD CARE
ASSSTANCE. IN CALIFORNIA THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN AFFORDABLE FOR
YEARS AND THE PANDEMIC HAS
GREATLY ELEVATED HELEN
PORTABLE. FAMILY FEES IMPACT
LATINO BLACK AND OTHER FAMILIES
OF COLOR. THEREFORE EIGHTY
NINETY TO CONVENE THE WORKGROUP
OF PARENT CHILD CARE PROVIDER
STATE AGENCY STAFF AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE AN
EQUITABLE FIGHTING SCALE FOR
FAMILY FEES. ONCE THE REQUIRED
FAMILY FEES GO BACK INTO A
FACT. AB NINETY TWO IS MODELED
AFTER THE FEDERAL CHILD CARE
FOR WORKING FAMILIES ACT THE
BILL INTRODUCED IN THE
CONGRESS. IMPORTANTLY EIGHTY
NINETY TO PROTECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDER ENSURING THEY DO NOT.
THREE IN FAMILY FEES AND THAT
THE NUMBER OF CHILD CARE SPACES
ARE NOT REACHES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES I DON'T SEE ANY. NO
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- WHY DON'T
WE GO TO ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU
AT I JUST WANT TO THANK SOMEONE
EVER RASTRICK FOR PUSHING THIS
ISSUE- NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT
LAST YEAR IS WHAT WE ADDRESS
THIS DURING THE BUDGET SO. IN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC THIS WAS
THE FACT THAT A BIG ISSUE AND
WE DID ADDRESS THIS DURING OUR
PUBLIC RESPONSE AND THIS IS
PART OF A LARGER THAN YOU SEE
PACKAGE THAT WE'RE PUSHING IN
THE ASSEMBLY. THIS IS ALSO
MEMORIALIZED IN OUR BUDGET-
PROPOSAL WHICH ACTUALLY AS WE
SPEAK OUR BUDGET SHARES GOING
OVER THE LARGER PIECES WHICH
WILL HAVE A- SIGNIFICANT ECP
COMPONENTS INCLUDING THIS ISSUE
AND THE BIG PICTURE IS THAT.
THESE FAMILY FEES- DON'T MAKE
OR BREAK FAST PAYING FOR
SUBSIDIZED BECAME CHILD CARE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THEY DO MAKE OR
BREAK PEOPLE FAMILIES PAYING
FOR IT THEMSELVES IN OTHER
WORDS LIKE WE DON'T NEED THIS
TO KEEP THE PLANT TO KEEP THESE
PROGRAMS RUNNING. BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT THIS IS A BURDEN ON
PEOPLE WITH LIMITED MEANS AND
SO IT'S JUST- FURTHER EXCLUDES
ELIGIBILITY AND IT'S AND IT'S
NOT NECESSARY SO- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND OUT
OF THE BILL. PHIL'S BEEN MOVED
SAT BY BETTER- WITHOUT ANY
FURTHER COMMITTEE KHANNA MISTER
BENNETT. I WOULD I WAS PLEASED
TO HEAR OF THIS MORNING ON THE
NEWS THAT- PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
TRYING TO COME UP WITH SOME
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR- FOR
THIS THE SERVICE SO HOPEFULLY
THE TWO WILL THAT DOVETAIL
NICELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE SINGLE FOR THE COMMON
FROM THE COMMITTEE- WE WILL
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THAT WISHES
TO COMMENT ON THIS BILL. AGAIN
WE'RE AB NINETY TWO RIGHT NOW
EIGHTY NINETY TWO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE COMMENTING ON ANYONE IN
THE ROOM. NOBODY IN THE ROOM
THAT I SEE. I WILL NOT GO TO
THE PHONES ON AB NINETY TWO
THIS ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY TWO-
TO THE PHONES FOR TEN MINUTES
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB. NINETY TWO.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR A. B. NINETY TWO. AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MESSAGE FOR A NUMBER OF
COLD WAR DOMAIN ON BEHALF OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY AND THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
ONE EIGHTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KATHY VAN
OSTERN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA
YEAH- A CO SPONSOR VERY PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO
TO LINE OF EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT MORE BURKE
BACKING DOLLAR **** THAT THEOF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE OF TWO FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS DONNA CALLING
REFERENCE COUNTY FIRST TRY
AMERICA READY NATION FIGHT
CRIME IN KIDS AND READY INCLUDE.
THANK YOU. AN EXTROVERT LINE OF
TWO EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JASON SOMEONE ON FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CURRENT PAYMENT
PROGRAM. AND WHAT KIND OF SPORT
EIGHTY NINETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO VOTE SO LINE OF THE
TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MICHELLE SO APARTMENTS
HE WITH KIDDING GO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IN MEXICO IT'S A LINE
OF TWO EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING IT'S A FAIR NUMBER
OF BROADBAND CURVATURE ELLIOT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION CONSORTIUM
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF THE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING CALLING PACKED ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
GO TO ONE OF TWO NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS MONICA MURPHY ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE CHARTER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATE NETWORKS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO A LINE OF
THREE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER ON
BEHALF OF FIFTEEN PM AT THE ARE
YOU NEEDING TO BE A
COLLABORATION INCOME SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE
OF TO- TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF TWO SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
POLICY MANUALS FROM INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS RICK
RICHARDSON REPRESENTING CHILD
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATES IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE OF TWO SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JANABI
HAVE THE SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
JUST ADVOCATE FOR BETTER
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF THREE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS RUNNING
FOR THE MARKETS WITH UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO TIMELINE OF US THREE OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JAMIE
DONOVAN PARENT OF FOUR CHILDREN
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF TWO
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
GOOD MORNING ABILITY WITH EVERY
CHILD CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO A
LINE OF AT THREE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA POLITICS CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE RESOURCE REFERRAL
NOT ONLY BECAUSE BONTA AN
INSTRUCTOR FOR. THANK YOU AND
NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF THREE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE THREE TWENTY NINE. OKAY
LEFT Q. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU ARE
MOVING FROM THE PHONES WE'RE
GOING WE'RE GOING TO GO TO-
REMOTE ROOM THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN CAPITOL
PARK IS THERE ANY TESTIMONY
FROM THE REMOTE STATION ON A.
B. NINETY TWO. SEE NO REMOTE
TESTIMONY FROM CAPITOL PARK
WILL BRING IT BACK- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND YES- YOU
MAY CLOSE PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE
AB NINETY TWO WILL MAKE CHILD
CARE MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES WILL BENEFIT
THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY. OF THE
STATE BY HELPING PARENTS REMAIN
IN THE WORKFORCE AND ACHIEVE
ECONOMIC STABILITY I DO WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU TO MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATE AFTER I
FOR YOUR IPHONE. I'M SORRY. BOB
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI BUT ALL AYE KILEY
AYE. KILEY I'D BEEN IT. SENATE
I DOLLY PLEASE RIGHT PLEASE HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY FIVE PORK SILVA
QUICK SILVA HI AS SIX BOTH.
GREAT THANK YOU SOME BILLS OUT-
THANK YOU WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO AB FIVE SIX EIGHT BY
MISTER RIVAS WERE NOW ON
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX EIGHT
AND THAT'S BY MISTER RIVAS. AND
SPEAKS EARLY LEARNING- SO YOU
MAY PROCEED ONE READY MISTER
RIVAS THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES- AND
BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE TO THE
I WILL BE THE COULD A MAN TO
REALLY WANT THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THIS BILL
AND THE ANALYSIS IN THIS
LEGISLATION PROPOSES TO
ESTABLISH A NEW DASHBOARD- THAT
WOULD CENTRALIZE- SOME DATA ON
OUR STATE'S EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE PROGRAMS- AND IT WOULD.
CREATE AN ANTI BIAS EDUCATION
GRANT PROGRAM FOR PROVIDERS AND
STAFF IN- AND CURRENTLY EARLY
LEARNING AND CAN CARE- THE
PROGRAM DATA IS SPREAD THROUGH
THROUGH THE DOZENS OF STATE
COUNTY PRIVATELY OWNED SYSTEMS-
AND VERY LITTLE OF THIS DATA IS
EASILY AVAILABLE TO POLICY
MAKERS IN ORDER TO THE PUBLIC-
AND THE LITTLE DATA WE HAVE ON
THESE PROGRAMS POINTS TO A
TROUBLING FACT THAT BLACK AND
LATINO- THE CHILDREN ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIKELY TO BE
EXCLUDED FROM EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE PROGRAMS. THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND RELEVANT
AGENCIES COOLEY NEED MORE DATA
WE NEED RELIABLE DATA TO TARGET
AND ADDRESS THE RACIAL AND
EQUITY GAPS THAT OUR YOUNGEST
STUDENTS FACE. IF WE BRING ALL
THE DATA WE HAVE ON EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS INTO A
CENTRALIZED DASHBOARD IT WILL
CERTAINLY GO A LONG WAY TO HELP
ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL
ADDITIONALLY BY INVESTING IN
ANTI BIAS AND PROFESSIONAL-
SOME DEVELOPMENT TRAINING WE
WILL BE BETTER EQUIPPED TO
RESPOND TO EIGHT TO IT TO
RACIAL INEQUITIES IN EARLY-
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION FOR THESE
REASONS MISTER CHAIR IN
COLLEGES BUT BASS WHEN I VOTE
WITH ME- HERE TO- PROVIDE A- IN
TESTING. IS OUR HADIZA ALARM
JOB HE'D GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
DIRECTOR FOR THE BEST A PROJECT
CALIFORNIA AND RAIN NOT THE
MINGUS MANAGER OF EARLY HEAD
START FOR THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THANK YOU MR JEFF GREAT THANK
YOU I HAVE RENTED A MAGAZINE
FIRST BUT IF HE IF HE'S NOT
FIRST REMOVED THE SECOND WITH
HIS FIRST SO TO THE TO THE
WITNESS TESTIMONY MODERATOR
PLEASE. R. O. GOING PRETTY GOOD-
GOOD MORNING THE TO TURN
MEMBERS COULD BE JOB THE DEATH
PROJECT CALIFORNIA WHERE AN
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY IN OUR
STATE I WANT TO START OFF BY
DEVELOPING AN EXCELLENT BILL
ANALYSIS BY COMMITTEE STAFF AT
LEFT NOTHING TO IMAGINATION AS
TO WHY THIS BILL IS NEEDED
THANK YOU. I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
ADD TO WHAT THE ANNOUNCES
FORWARD COLLECTION OF DATA IS
ONLY USEFUL WITH THAT TELLS A
STORY PAINTS A PICTURE HEALTH
REFORM DECISION MAKING IF IT
DOES NONE OF THE ABOVE THE DATA.
IS JUST NUMBER. AND IS WHAT WE
ARE TO CALL WITH THE BILL. YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO THIS OF BUT
I BLACK IN BROWN CHAU. AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE FACING.
WHETHER IT'S AN EXACT. OF THE
PROGRAM IN CERTAIN AREAS.
WHETHER IT'S BLACK ACCESS TO
FILL. THE TYPE OF CARE
PARTICULARS. OF CHILDREN
RECEIVE OR DO KNOWLEDGE. WHERE
CHILDREN RECEIVE CARE OF
WHETHER THAT STATUS MEETING THE
NEEDS OF FAMILIES. ALL OF THE
ABOVE DATA THE COLLECTED A
COMPREHENSIVE MORE ACCEPTABLE
WAY. IT WOULD POINT TO AN
EQUITABLE ACCESS PROGRAMS FOR
BLACK AND BROWN CHILDREN ACROSS
THE STATE. THIS BILL WILL MAKE
IT A MORE TRANSPARENT.
COMPREHENSIVE ACCEPTABLE. AND
IT WILL PAINT A FULL PICTURE
FOR YOU AS POLICYMAKERS TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO
MAKE SMARTER AND EQUITABLE
INVESTMENT IN EARLY CARE
EDUCATION. NOW TO THE SECOND
ISSUE THE BILL ADDRESSES
SYSTEMATICALLY TO.
SYSTEMATICALLY IS MUCH OF THE
PANDEMIC AS IT'S CALLED THE
NIGHT. AND IT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WITH THE SAME TYPE OF PREGNANCY.
THIS BILL TELL. TWO ONE
ELEMENTARY ADDRESS RACIAL. AND
OFFER. EVIDENCE BASED ANTI
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITY. TO ALL LEARN EARLY
ON CARE AND EDUCATE PER.
BECAUSE DIVERSE THAT. WE ENTER.
THAT TRAIN. ROOTED IN THE-
EQUITY INCLUSION AND BELONGING.
THE RESULT IN OF THE BEING. TO
CRACK. FOR INSTANCE HOW TO HELP
IMPROVE CHILD'S BEHAVIOR AND IT
SAID A FEW TO SPEND. EXPLOSION
AND OTHER PEOPLE AMERICA'S THE-
MEASURES. THANK YOU AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR- THANK WILL NEXT TO
THE OTHER WITNESS WHICH IS
APPEARS IT'S RAINY DOMINGOS. ON
A. B. FIVE SIX EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING MY IS JAMIE NOT LOW GET
ABOUT OF THE HELPED FOR AT THE
TIME TO CRACK OFFICE THAT YOU.
I WORKED IN EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE OVER THREE YEARS.
DEMOCRATS OFFICE IF CLOUT THE
CLOSE BOND EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH WITH SOME SIX
FIFTEEN THE DATA IN A WAY THAT
WILL HAVE STATE AND LOCAL
POLICY MAY. IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THIS. TO DISCONNECT
THAT HAPPENED BLACK BE NOT. AND
PROCEED. ACCESS TO SERVICES. WE
MOST RESURGENT X. THAT- EARLY
LEARNING SAID CHILDREN FOR THE-
AND AFTER. GRADUATION APPLYING.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ACTS TO STATE.
AND PANEL PROGRAM IF NOT EQUAL
ACROSS THREE. AND ETHNICITIES.
AB SIXTY EIGHT TWO HIGH THIS.
TO START ADDRESSING THE PERFECT
AND IF REASONS SIXTEEN. THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE DATA TO
BE. IN THE ARTICLE CARE CASH
FOR PUBLIC EXPENSE. IT'S NOT
CURRENTLY FOR VERIZON A WAY
THAT LEAD TO. LIKE YOU OR LOCAL
ADMINISTRATORS ARE MYSELF. MAKE
DECISIONS INSERTED YOU CAN NEXT
ADDRESS THE SEMICONDUCTOR. AB
SIXTY EIGHT THE CENTRAL TO HELP
AND- WE COVER THE CHILD LOS
SIX. DURING THE PANDEMIC. AT
THE WE INVEST- EARLY LEARNING
CHILDCARE AB SIXTY EIGHT WHAT
HELP WITH A- BY WHAT THE-
NUMBER OF. SLOTS FOR. WHAT ARE
SOME. PROVIDERS AND HELP TO
HELP. MOST OF BY THE CONTENT. A
TRANSFER. AND ACCEPTABLE CAN.
WILL BE ABLE TO ASK LEAST. INTO
EARLY LEARN. AND CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS AND ADDRESS EQUITY
GAPS. WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
OUR CHILDREN BY VOTERS YES I.
EIGHTY FIVE SIX EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HAVE THERE ARE
NO OPPOSITE WERE TO THE BILL-
SINGLE- WHEN IS- WILL GO TO THE
CAN MEMBERS QUEST ARE COMMON
READY TO COME MEMBERS. ON THIS
BUT BILL. IT'S BEEN MOVED I SAY-
THE BILL- ANY SINA COM OVER THE
COMMITTEE WHAT WE GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC OF UP TO TEN
MINUTES IN THE IN THE ROOM AS
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WISHES
TO TESTIFY ON THIS BILL. K. NOW
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING
TO THE PHONE LINE AND WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION ONLY ONLY. TO AB
FIVE SIX EIGHT BY MISTER RIVAS
AB FIVE SIX EIGHT- PLEASE
MODERATOR GO TO THE PHONES ON
AB FIVE SIX EIGHT. IF YOU IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. OF AB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR A.
B. FIVE SIX EIGHT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING BUT THAT
GONZALEZ AS OF SOCIAL WORKER
CAL CHAP IN. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF THIRTY THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE
THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON.
OKAY WILL CALL ONE AND AGAIN
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF A. B. FIVE SIX EIGHT. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF IT TWO
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MICHELLE SO
APARTMENTS HE WITH KIDDING- IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF THREE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS STACY PHELPS MY NAME IS
STACY FOLLOWED I'M A LIFELONG.
SACRAMENTO AND I ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED AB. FIVE SIX EIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
THREE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE THREE SIX EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HEARING YES GO
AHEAD PLEASE BALMAIN'S COULD
DIVERT ATTENTION FROM RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD LIKE TO
LET YOU GUYS KNOW I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. AND NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF THE THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
JACQUELYN MISTREAT- IN
NEWCASTLE CALIFORNIA AND I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF THREE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. EIGHT NINE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE
HAVE NO FIRST SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME GREAT THANK YOU- IS THERE
ANY REMOTE TESTIMONY FROM
CAPITOL PARK ON THIS BILL AB
FIVE SIX EIGHT. SEEING A REMOTE
TESTIMONY- THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED CORRECT
CORRECT- YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER
CHAIR REALLY AREN'T
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL VIRGINIA
VIRGINIA THAT- AND THEM AND YOU
I'D LEAVE IT STATE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING AT THE
BEGINNING OF YOUR PRESENTATION
THAT YOU DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MOMENTS THE MOTION IS
A TO PASS AS AMENDED TO A
PREPARATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR
DONALD HI HI KILEY. HI AYE
SORRY FOR DONALD BY KILEY AYE.
BENNETT BENNETT BY. DELHI LEE
FACT LEE I. QUICK SILVA. THE
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES BILL'S
WORLD TOURISM THANK YOU NOW
WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED TO-
ISSUES HERE- AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY MISS RUBIO SO RIGHT NOW
WE'RE ON BILL AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE NOT THIRTEEN SIXTEEN AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE- IN THAT IS
GOING BE RESENTED BY MISS RUBIO.
AND YOU MAY PERCEIVE IN REDDING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THREE SIX ONE AND
PROVIDING OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE RECOMMENDED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTED ON
PAGE EIGHTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. I AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE HAS THREE MAJOR COMPONENTS
IT EACH OF WHICH WILL
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE OUR STATE. FIRST
THE BILL WOULD GREATLY LIMIT
THE SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION OF
PRESCHOOL AGE STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM NASH NATIONAL
DATA HAS INDICATED TO.
INDICATED TO VERY CONCERNING
TRENDS AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION NOT ONLY ARE
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS MORE
COMMON IN THE PRESCHOOL SETTING
THAN K. TWELVE THE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
CHILDREN OF COLOR. RESEARCH HAS
ALSO INDICATED THAT SCHOOL
EXPULSION AND SUSPENSION
PRACTICES ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
NEGATIVITY CATION- AND LYFT
OUTCOMES. IN ADDITION TO
HARMING A YOUNG CHILD'S
ACADEMIC PROSPECTS RESEARCH HAS
ALSO FOUND THAT SUSPENSIONS AND%
EXPULSIONS DO NOTHING TO IMPACT
THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGE. OF CHALLENGING
BEHAVIOR. WELL THIS FIRST MAJOR
COMPONENT IDENTIFIES THE KEY
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA'S
PRESCHOOL SYSTEM AND MOVES TO
IMMEDIATELY AND HARMFUL- I'M
SORRY TO IMMEDIATELY END
HARMFUL PRACTICES THE NEXT
COMPONENT OF THE BILL IS
DESIGNED TO CREATE A PART OF A
PROACTIVE SOLUTION. AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING. SORRY AND WE ARE
DOING THIS THROUGH THE USE OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATIONS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS EASY M. C.
H. M. H. C. ECM H. C. SERVICES
ARE PUT A PROVEN MODEL WAY
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WILL
ENSURE THE PRESCHOOL SETTING
AND PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THE
STUDENT. THE STAFF AND TO
FAMILIES THESE SERVICES CREATE
A MEANS OF PROVIDING ADEQUATE
SUPPORTS TWO TEACHERS CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES TO PROMOTE
POSITIVE MENTAL HEALTH BUT FOR
THE EFFECTS OF TOXIC STRESS AND
TRAUMA AND BRING OUT THE MOST
OPTIMAL DEVELOPMENT AND
LEARNING OF EACH AND EVERY
CHILD. SO WITH THIS BILL WE ARE
NOT SIMPLY TRYING TO HAND OFF
PROVIDERS BY LIMITING. I'M
SORRY TYING THE HANDS OF
PROVIDERS BY LIMITING
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS WERE
ALSO PROVIDING THEM WITH A NEW
TOOL TO HELP ADDRESS
CHALLENGING BEHAVIOR IN MORE
HOLISTIC AND PROACTIVE MANNER.
THE FINAL COMPONENT OF THIS
BILL WILL BE FOR THE STATE TO
BEGIN COLLECTING DATA ON THE
USE OF SUSPENSION AND A- SO
THAT PAUL MAKERS HERE CAN
BECOME. UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
OUR IS WORKING. THIS
LEGISLATION HAS HAD INPUT FROM
POLICY EXPERTS THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION AND ENJOY A LARGE AMOUNT
OF SUPPORT. THE BILL HAS A WIDE
COALITION OF SUPPORT AND IS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE MASTER
PLAN RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR. ON THE PHONE WITH US
TODAY WE HAVE SOME OF OUR CO
SPONSORS FROM CONVICTED ANGLE
AND BLACK MEN FOR EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE PRESENTATION WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THE FIRST WITNESS I
HAVE IS- IS WITNESS MORTON. IT
I BELIEVE THAT AS THE FIRST
WITNESS TODAY. THEN THE MAN YOU
MAY YES JUST FIVE ALREADY.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
TERMINAL DOWN ON NUMBERS ASAP
MY NAME IS CAIN MORTON ON
BEHALF OF BLACK MENTOR
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY PROUD
SPONSOR OF THE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. BLACK
MENTOR EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
ORGANIZATIONAL BLACKMAN THE
PARENTS UNCLES BROTHERS AND
SONS IN THE ENTIRETY OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE WAKE OF
GORGEOUSLY BLACKMAN'S
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY CAME
TOGETHER ONE MILLION THE PEOPLE
EXPRESSED THE ESIRE TO BUILD
MORE EQUITABLE EDUCATION
SYSTEMS TO INCLUDE EARLY
LEARNING CARE SYSTEMS. WE'VE
SEEN AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL BUT
CONVENTION BEEN EXPULSIONS AND
FOUND TO BE A DIRECT PATHWAY
INTO THE JUVENILE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS BUT THE REALITY
AT THE BEGINNING FOR CHILDREN
AS YOUNG AS EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
FIVE. ELEVATED LEVELS OF
EXCLUSION DICTIONARY. ACTIVE
NATIVE AMERICAN AND LATINO
CHILDREN YET NO OTHER STUDENT
WHO'VE EXPERIENCED LEVELS OF
DISPROPORTIONATE DISCIPLINE
GREATER THAN A BLACK MALE
CHILDREN. WHILE MORE DATA IS
NEEDED FOR A STATE A GROWING
BODY OF EVIDENCE IN A REPORT BY
NEEDS OF PROFESSORS UCLA AND
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY. ON
THE BLOCK WITH A FIVE POINT SIX
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE
SUSPENDED THAN PAID AVERAGE FOR
THE MORE REPORT LEVEL BEGINNING
IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN COMMENT
MANY PRESCHOOL TEACHERS. LOOK
FOR DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR OFTEN
HAVING TO KEEP FOCUS ON
CHILDREN OF COLOR MORE THAN ANY
OTHER GROUP IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE TO WORK
TO LIMON A BENCH. OF YOUNG
CHILDREN ATTENDING CHILDREN
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
INVOLVES. CRITICS OF. IN HE
TOWARD SCHOOL BY. IN A ROW.
RELATIONS FOR THAT. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE IS THE- TO. THE
VALUABLE. AND PROVIDER. AND THE
FAMILY DATE. THE RATHER STATE.
IT'LL TURN IT INTO SPENT
TWELFTH. AND BEHAVIOR CONSIDER
INTO THE- SUPPORT SUCH A GREAT
INVOLVEMENT WITH FAMILY. IN THE
BILL BE AND EVEN. AND OTHER IN.
AT THAT YOU OF EARLY TWO.
MENTAL HEALTH COUNCIL. WHICH
WERE BROUGHT REYES PROVIDE
AWARE ABOUT THE ISSUE. AND
BUILDER. FOR THEM TO COME. LL
STRATEGIES. TO SUPPORT CHILDREN
J. THE BILL HAS. CONTINUING IN
A- IS TO KEEP OUR KIDS LEARNING
AND KAREMIRE. NOT ISOLATE MOVE
THEM FROM THE- THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT OUTCOME PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL AND REACH. AND TOOLS
TO PROVIDERS. THANK YOU IN THE
**** FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON
EIGHTY. SIX ONE. THANK YOU TO
OUR WITH NEXT WITH SINCE THE OF
THEIR SO ONE. HELLO NINETEEN AS
LONG LIFE AND HE AND BY
PRESIDENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION
AFTER DANGAL A LARGISH CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDER IN
THE BAY AREA. MICHAEL THREE A
OF EIGHT FOR TIME. SERVING OVER
ONE HUNDRED CLASSROOMS.
TEACHERS AND CAL PROVIDER ARE
HER GROWING FIGURE AND THEY'RE
IN ON YOUNG CHILDREN AS
PROFOUND TEACHERS DESERVE AND
REQUIRE ADEQUATE SUPPORT CAN BE
EFFECTIVE. ABOUT ON FULL TOLL
OTHER AND- ENCOURAGED PER
CHALLENGES THAT HAVE PLAGUED
ECP PROGRAM ACROSS CALIFORNIA
YEAR AFTER YEAR WHICH CULMINATE
INTO THE EXCLUSION OF BABIES
AND YOUNG CHILDREN. EXPANSION
AND EXPULSION AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE PROVIDES EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION.
HIGH QUALITY EARLY LEARNING.
THERE IS A FORMULA YOU LOOK
EARLY CHILDHOOD HEALTH CONSERVE.
IT ADDED BASED MENTAL HEALTH.
THE ONGOING COLLAB PARTNER AND
ECSTATIC BETWEEN. EDUCATORS AND
PAM. AND THAT'S IT CREATES AND
THE- THAT. THE GATE IN. AND
GENERATE TAILORED STRATEGY. TO
WATER BECAUSE ISSUES. LET
FORMULA BE. FROM THE SPECIAL
ACT FOR. AND UNIQUE SKILL SET
OF THE COULD WORK. FOR AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE OUT THAT THE
FIFTH MASTER LEVEL AT.
PROFESSIONALS FOR AND TO
REQUIRED THAT UNDER CONSULTS
ABOUT NOW AND TRIED TO TRY ME
AND IT ON T. CHILDREN OF
CONCERN AND NORMATIVELY UPON
ALL CHILL IN THE STUDY. WITH IT
BECAUSE OF APPROACH AND
SPECIALIZED EXPERT. EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH COMPANY
WELL AND GAVE THE EASE EASY. TO
MORE FOR ACHIEVE THE IMPACT IT
PROMISES. WILL DO IS GO TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS- WAS QUICK SILVA YEAH
YES I REMEMBER- NORMALLY IF
SUPPORTERS THAT IS GOING TO
OCCUR ON THE BILL AND- AS A-
CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS. TEACHING
ELEMENTARY WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN THERE NEEDS TO
BE DISCIPLINE WHEN THERE NEEDS
TO BE- INTERVENTION WITH
PARENTS WITH TEACHERS AND
COMPLETE- STAFF APPROACH BUT
LOOKING AT EXPELLING YOUNG
CHILDREN- I THINK THAT WHEN WE
BRING THE BEST MINDS TOGETHER.
AND THE BEST PRACTICES TOGETHER
THAT WE KNOW WE HAVE AT OUR
FINGERTIPS THOSE ARE GOING TO
PRODUCE THE BEST RESULTS AND
SO- I KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY
WAYS TO WORK WITH CHILDREN THAT
CAN. DE ESCALATE SITUATIONS
THAT CAN PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
THEY NEED THE PER SUPPORT THE
PARENTS NEED AND THE STAFF
THAT'S WORKING WITH THEM SO I
THINK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
AND I THINK AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH CHILDREN. WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT ALL THE WAYS THAT WE
CAN TO NURTURE THEM AT THE
YOUNGEST AGES. BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THOSE EARLY INTERVENTIONS
ON THOSE EARLY EXPERIENCES LAY
THE GROUNDWORK FOR MANY-
FUTURE- SCENARIOS AND IF A
CHILD HAS A LOT OF TRAUMA AT A
LOT VERY YOUNG AGE THAT CAN
STAY WITH THEM REALLY FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIFE SO
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO. AS A
PUBLIC- EDUCATION AND WITHIN
SCHOOLS TO CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S NURTURING
AND THAT TIME SPEAKS TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT SOME OF THESE
CHILDREN FACE IS WHAT WE NEED
TO DO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU- MISTER COLORFUL. I
FULLY AGREE WITH THOSE COMMENTS
AND I AGREE WITH TE PREMISE OF
THIS BILL THAT- YOU KNOW A
CHILD- PRESCHOOLER I SHOULDN'T
BE EXPELLED SUSPENDED- YOU KNOW
AN EXCEPTION TO THE MOST
EXTRAORDINARY OF CIRCUMSTANCES
MY RESERVATION IS WHETHER YOU
KNOW WE IS A STATEWIDE POLICY
MAKING BODY ARE BEST POSITIONED
TO DEFINE WITH SPECIFICITY WHAT
THOSE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DEFINITION
OF SUSPENSION IT'S ANY REMOVAL
OF A CHILD. FROM ALL OR PART OF
THE PROGRAM DAY SO YOU KNOW
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
PUNITIVE HAVING A CHILD MISS
PART OF A OF ONE DAY OF SCHOOL
AND YOU KNOW GIVEN THE SORT OF
INFINITE VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CAN DEVELOP-
YOU KNOW AT A SCHOOL IN ANY
PART OF THE STATE- I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT THAT DEFINITION
IS NOT GOING TO ALLOW SCHOOL
LEADERS TO. ADEQUATELY MEET
THAT THE NEEDS OF THEIR OF ALL
THEIR STUDENTS SO I YOU DON'T
RESPOND YOU DON'T WANT TO IF
YOU ARE NOT A DEALER- I TAUGHT
KINDERGARTEN FOR THREE YEARS
FIRST GRADE FOR FIVE AND EIGHT
YEARS IN FOURTH GRADE SO I CAN
TELL YOU- SPECIFICALLY THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AND YOU
KNOW I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING SOMETIMES WE TIE THE
HANDS OF ADMINISTRATORS BUT
THE- BUT I THINK FOR ME BUT THE
MOST IMPACT IMPACT FULL TIME OF
MY TEACHING WITH KINDERGARTEN
WHEN. IF WE EXPEL THE TILED
WHAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
REALLY REINFORCING THAT THEIR
BAD BEHAVIOR IS GOOD BECAUSE IF
YOU ARE STARTING PRESCHOOL OR
KINDERGARTEN THAT MOST KIDS
DON'T HAVEN'T HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE OF SCHOOL SO THEY
DON'T REALLY WANT TO GO AND SO
IF THE ACT OUT AND WE SUSPEND
THE KIDS THEN THEY GO HOME.
WE'RE REINFORCING THAT BY BAD
BEHAVIOR BECAUSE GUESS WHAT
THEY WANT TO STAY HOME BECAUSE
ALL THEY'RE GOING TO DO AT HOME
AND PLAY VIDEO GAMES YOU KNOW
TO YOUR BUT IF YOU KNOW THE
FIRST PART OF YOUR YOUR COMMENT
IN YOUR QUESTION THE SECOND
PART IS THAT'S WHY IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WEPROVIDE NOT
ONLY ARE THE MENTAL
CONSULTATION TO THE CHILD RIGHT
WE'RE PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR THE
TEACHER AND FOR THE PARENTS.
BECAUSE AS. A CLASSROOM TEACHER
WE ARE EXPECTED TO BE.
EVERYTHING TO A EVERYBODY. I
WITH A GRANDMA MOM DAD I WAS
YOU KNOW PSYCHOLOGIST
PSYCHIATRIST- NUTRITIONIST. AND
WE'RE QUITE FRANKLY OUR
EDUCATION TO BECOME TEACHERS
DOESN'T PROVIDE THE SUPPORT.
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THESE ISSUES ARE BACK
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL INCLUDES
THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATIONS. TO ASSIST THE
TEACHER AS WELL NOT JUST THE
STUDENT OR THE FAMILY. AND OF
COURSE IF THERE'S REALLY
EGREGIOUS- BEHAVIOR THEN THAT
TEAM CAN COME TOGETHER AND
FIGURE OUT IF WHAT WE'R DOING
IS NOT WORKING BUT I THINK FOR
ME IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT. TO THE
STUDENT FIRST INFORMAL STRAIGHT
THE FAMILY BUT THE TEACHERS SO
THAT. TEACHERS ARE EQUIPPED
WITH THE TOOLS ARE THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
INTERVENE IN THESE CASES AND-
YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY B. THESE
KIDS ARE THREE AND FOUR. AND SO
AGAIN IF WE SUSPEND THEM. IF
I'M THREE OR FOUR I WANT TO GO
HOME AND PLAY. RIGHT AND SO
WE'RE ONLY- ENCOURAGING BAD
BEHAVIOR BY BY SUSPENDING THEM
SO I THINK THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT AND AGAIN. PROVIDING
IS WHAT I THINK FOR ME IS THE
MOSTIMPORTANT. AS ALL THREE
COMPONENTS ARE THEPARENT THE
TEACHER AND THE FAMILY IS
GETTING THAT SUPPORT. YEAH I
THINK THAT THAT IS GREAT AND- I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THIS
BILL TO SUPPORT AND THE SHARING
OF BEST PRACTICES AND I AGREE
WITH YOU THE SUSPENSION CAN BE
SORT OF OVER USED. AS AN
INTERVENTION- AND THAT WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY BE SHARING
BEST PRACTICES OR WE CAN JUST
MIGHT MY OBJECTION IS WITH THE
HARD AND FAST RULE THAT. YOU
KNOW PRECLUDES AN
INDIVIDUALIZED EVALUATION- YOU
KNOW INTO THAT IS THAT THAT IS
SENSITIVE TO. THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF PARTICULAR
CHILD IN A PARTICULAR SCHOOL.
OKAY I ACTUALLY THINK IT DOES
THOUGH IT DOES YEAH I THINK IT
DOES I THINK YOU'RE BOTH RIGHT
I THINK YOUR CONCERN IS IT.
THEN THIS BILL DOESN'T SAY
NEVER RIGHT- BECAUSE AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER MY MIDDLE
SCHOOL A LOT OF YEARS RIGHT-
YOU HAVE TO HAVE TOOLS BEFORE
YOU THAT YOU CAN HELP. RIGHT
SECRETARY HEATHER THIRTY FIVE
OTHER CHILDREN IN THAT
CLASSROOM- THAT YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE ARE SAFE AS WELL. SO
I DON'T GET SAYS NEVER JUST
SAID SAID SOME PROTOCOLS RIGHT
AND I WILL THROUGH PROGRESS AND
HOW I DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE ON THIS I DON'T WANT.
DON'T I DON'T RECALL WHAT IT
SAID BUT THE TEACHERS DO HAVE
TO HAVE THE IMMEDIATE ABILITY
REMOVE A CHILD FROM A CLASSROOM
OFTEN FOR JUST THAT CHILD
SOMETHING. YET OR MAYBE THE
SAFETY OF OTHERS SO THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE MAINTAINED. YEAH I
THINK WE'RE SEEING HERE WHAT
WE'RE ASKING HERE IN CALLING.
FOR HER SOME PROTOCOLS BEFORE
WE DO- SUSPEND. AND RIGHT
INSTEAD OF GOING DIRECTLY TO
THIS RANCH AND ACCORDING TO THE
SAP CENTER AT THE HOSPITAL BUT-
SHALL. NOT THAT THAT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN. GIVEN SOME
EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES SO I
THINK. I THINK WERE. MOSTLY ON
THE SAME PAGE RIGHT AND ACTING
AND THAT'S WHY I APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I THINK WE MADE SOME
AMENDMENTS TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY YOU KNOW WHERE THAT
LOOPHOLES MAY BE. AN OBVIOUSLY
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE PERFECT
FOR EVERYONE BUT I THINK THIS
IS THE BEST APPROACH- YOU KNOW
IT'S PROGRESS HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE KIDS ARE GETTING THAT
THAT- SUPPORT AND THEN IF THAT
DOESN'T WORK THEN THAT'S WHEN
YOU KNOW THE TEAM COMES
TOGETHER AND SAYS. WHAT ELSE
CAN WE DO THIS HASN'T WORKED
BUT I DON'T IT'S ONLY STUDENT
SAFETY RIGHT THAT COULD BE THE
ULTIMATE REASON FOR- EVEN THE
OF REMOVAL PART OF THE SCHOOL
DAY THERE'S NO OTHER. REASON
THAT CAN BE USED WELL I THINK
XIN RIGHT BUT THAT YOU KNOW AND
THE REASON FOR THIS BILL IS
WHEN WE DID THIS THE RESEARCH
ON THE STATISTICS- BUT BUT
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS WERE
BEING SUSPENDED FOR BITING.
WHICH WHICH YOU KNOW IN ITS
FACE RIGHT IS A BITING HOWEVER
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA DEVELOP
DEVELOPMENTAL CHART THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY SO THERE WILL MEANS
OF COMMUNICATIONS BY BITING.
THE WORK WORK WITH THEY WERE
SPENDING THE KIDS FOR DOING
SOMETHING THAT THEIR SUBPOENA
DEVELOPMENTALLY THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T COMMUNICATE SO YES TO
THAT. THE STUDENT SAFETY
HOWEVER- THE POPULATION THAT
WAS BEING- IT SUSPENDED AND
EXPELLED WAS. OVER MORE OF A
BIAS RATHER THAN THE THAN THE
ACT BECAUSE ALL THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS. GO THROUGH THAT'S
THE DEVICE OF BITING. OKAY I
MISS BENNETT. THANK YOU- I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE TO HELP
WITH THE INTENT OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I
PARTICULARLY- THE BIASED ASPECT
AND THE THAT IS INHERENTLY OUT
THERE EVEN IF WELL INTENTIONED
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT THEY
HAVE IT- TO PROTECT THE GOALS
OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO ASK US THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD- IT TO
CAREFULLY CONSIDER THE FACT
THAT WE'RE SUCH A LEGALISTIC
SOCIETY NOW. THAT IF WE START
GETTING LAWSUITS BECAUSE OF THE
TEMPORARY REMOVAL FROM ONE
EDUCATIONAL SETTING YOUR IDEA
THAT YOU KNOW OF THESE KIDS GET
SENT HOME IN THEIR ONLINE THAT
I COMPLETELY AGREE THAT'S A
REINFORCEMENT FOR MISBEHAVIOR
BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE FLEXIBILITY
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THE STUDENT
AROUND AND SCORE MOVING FROM
THIS CLASSROOM INO SOME OTHER
SETTING. SO THAT- SO I JUST
DON'T WANT YOUR DEFINITION TO
BE SO TIGHT THAT WE START
GETTING LAWSUITS OF THAT DEFEAT
THE PURPOSE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND THEN HAVE THE
SCHOOLS PUT ACTUALLY PUSH BACK
ON THIS DEFINITION SO MY ONLY
REQUEST IS THAT AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD YOU COULD YOU TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE FLEXIBILITY
OF THAT DEFINITION OF WHAT IS.
EXPULSION IS OUT OF THE SCHOOL
AND SENT HOME VERSES
TEMPORARILY REMOVAL YOU KNOW
IT'S WEIRD WHEN YOU SAY FOR A
EVEN PART OF THE DAY WHAT PART
ABOUT TEMPORARY MOVE FROM ONE
CLASSROOM TO ANOTHER OR TO THE
OFFICE OR THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
SO- I AM SURE YOU'LL DO A GOOD
JOB THANK YOU I APPRECIATE I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND THE
AND THE DISCUSSION AND I THINK
THAT'S THE INTENT YOU KNOW OUR
INTENT BASICALLY IS TO. TO
ASSIST AND- THE CHILDREN AND
AGAIN AS A FORMER TEACHER I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- I NEEDED AS MUCH
HELP AS I CAN GET WHEN I HAD
THE- THE YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT SOME CHILDREN THAT
I WASN'T- CAPABLE OF HELPING
AND THIS I THINK WILL PROVIDE
THAT SUPPORT FOR THE TEACHERS
SO IT YOUR POINT IS WELL THANK
TAKEN THANK YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU TO MR BENNETT'S. POINT I
THINK WE SEEKING DURING SURE
THAT WE DON'T MAKE A- FROM THE
ROOM- WHICH I YOU AGREE WITH-
AND THEN. EVEN YOU KNOW. THIS
IS NOT THIRTY DAYS JUST. BUT I
JUST WONDER IF IT WOULD BE
BETTER TO HAVE CD DEVELOP SOME
GUIDANCE OR SOME POLICIES.
ALONG THESE LINES AND THEN HAVE
EVERY LOCAL. CHILD CARE CENTER
DOT THEIR OWN POLICY WITH
REGARD TO HOW THE ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. THAT MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT LESS. MICROMANAGING A
LITTLE AND AVOID THE- WELL I
COMPLETELY LAWSUIT BUT EITHER
WAY THAT'S- HOW I DID IT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND YOU KNOW
I'VE GOT SEVEN MORE YEARS-
HOPEFULLY IF I KEEP GETTING
REELECTED AND- IN MY COMMITMENT
IS TO WORK THROUGH. SOME OF
THESE POLICIES TO BE ABLE TO
COME TO THAT SPOT WHERE WHERE.
YOU KNOW WHERE WE'RE BEING FAIR
TO EVERYONE ESPECIALLY THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS WHEN.
YOU KNOW WE'RE MOVING INTO THAT
DIRECTION WHERE WE ARE MICHEL
MANAGING SO I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS APPRECIATE APPRECIATE%
YOUR EFFORTS- WITH THAT- WE
HAVE GONE TO- COMMITTEE MEMBER
QUESTIONS- IS THERE ANY IN THE
ROOM THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
THE BILL. OF TO MR MCCARTY
JEWISH OF YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER THIS IS
PART OF OUR- OUR- EARLY
EDUCATION PRE K. PACKAGE WE
ANNOUNCED A FEW MONTHS AGO THIS
IS A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ONCE AGAIN THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. SO ANYWAY THIS IS IN THE
ROOM OR ANY PUT PERSONS IN THE
ROOM WHICH WOULD COME UP. WHICH
TO. COME UP AND SAY WHETHER
THEY SUPPORT. OR OPPOSE THE
BILL JUST SAY YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE GIVE. A CARLOS
MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT- LET'S NOT
SEE NO OTHER PERSONS IN THE
ROOM WHEN WE GO TO THE PHONE
LINE- NOW TEN MINUTES. OF
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION ON THE
BILL ONLY THE BILL RIGHT NOW IS
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUDY RUBIO AND
SPEAKS TO CHILD CARE PROGRAMS.
TO THE PHONES THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
THAT IS THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE EIGHT THREE MMHM. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU- MISTER
MEMBER KATHY VAN OFTEN AMERICAN
UNIVERSE- SORRY AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK
YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU AMANDA DICKEY WITH
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION PROUD SPONSOR AND
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF FOUR TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS DO MORNING THERESA
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARK
AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF FOUR
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MORNING SURE MEMBERS I AM
NOT SURE OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WITH
SPORTS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PERFECTING GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF
FOUR THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU WORK. ONE FOUR THREE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY HEALTH.
GET I HAD DELETED OPEN.
PROBABLY SHOULD MOVE ON
MODERATOR. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF THAT TWO OH TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. STEPHANIE
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF SILICON
SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE THREE ALL THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN JAMIE DONOVAN HOME
EDUCATOR AND PARENT OF FOUR
CHILDREN STRONGLY OPPOSED AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
AN EXTRA GO TO LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI YOU KNOW TIME IN VIEW
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH REGION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JACQUELYN MONTHS STREET-
AND FORMER HOME EDUCATOR AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE I AGREE IT'S
MICROMANAGING. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING AND WE CAN RUN THROUGH
IT SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO
LINE UP FOR TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FOUR TWO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL GO
TO THE NEXT FINE. AND THAT IS
FOR SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI I AM ACTUALLY HERE FOR
AB TWENTY TWO SO I'M GONNA HANG
UP AND- THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA FOUR SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BRITTANY PICKETT I'M A PARENT
OF FIVE CHILDREN AND I STRONG
INSULT. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF FOUR OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS HEATHER
KELLER A PARENT OF TWO CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU AN
EXTROVERT SO I KNOW FOR FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING THIS IS A THREE ACRE
FROM LINCOLN ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL NOT ALL THREE
TO FOUR YEAR OLDS GO THROUGH
THE STAGES OF LIFE THANK YOU.
BUT ON OUR OWN THANK YOU. THANK
IN MEXICO TO LINE UP FOR TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT
THE SENATE YOUR PRELIMINARY I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME GREAT THANK YOU- IS THERE
ANY TESTIMONY FROM THE REMOTE
STATION CAPITOL PARK IN AB. ONE
THREE SIX ONE. SAYING NO REMOTE
TESTIMONY- THE AUTHOR MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE BELIEVE WE NEED
TO MOVE THE BILL MR MCCARTY
MOVES- MISTERLEE SECONDS- THE
MOTION IS- THE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI FOR DONAL I KILEY.
KILEY KNOW BENNETT. BENNETT
FIVE DALLY. DALLY HI LEE LEE HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY I QUICK SILVA
HI RICK SILVA HI. THE BILL HAS
SIX OF. WILL SIX PHOTO IS OUT.
WITH THAT WILL GO TO- ALREADY
IN THE. VIRGINIA IS A TALL
NUMBER WHICH WE- GET THE STORY
STRAIGHT OKAY. START TRYING TO
FIGURE MY ORDER MISTER LEE IS.
EUROPE IT'S EIGHTY SEVEN SIX
TWO. AB. SEVEN SIX TWO. FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. ARE THEY GIVE US
SHARE MEMBERS THANK YOUAND
ALSO I THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY TEAM
TO ON THE NEW AMENDMENTS WHICH
I ACCEPT THE COULD BE
AMENDMENTS I AB SIX. I'M SORRY
AB SEVEN SIX TWO THIS BILL
SEEKS TO PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
AIR POLLUTION DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS NEAR SCHOOLS REQUIRES
PRIVATE AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
MEET THE SAME SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AS PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WHEN CHOOSING A NEW SCHOOL SITE
IN MY DISTRICT A PRIVATE SCHOOL
CALLED STRATFORD SCHOOL WAS
BUILT RIGHT NEXT TO CONCRETE
FACTORY. RIGHT NEXT TO A
PLAYGROUND THEIR PILES OF
CONCRETE AND OTHER BUILDING
MATERIALS THE PROCESS OF MAKING
CONGREGATE PUT CHEMICALS INTO
THE AIR AND CHILDREN ARE
SPECIAL RISK FOR HEALTH
PROBLEMS I'M THANKFUL FOR THE
SUPPORT AND ADVOCACY OF PARENTS
FOR MY DISTRICT SHALL ONE TO
FONG SHALL AND CRYSTAL DIE
WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE ATTENDED
STRATFORD SCHOOL AND WILL BE
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. AND SADLY THIS ISN'T THE
ONLY EXAMPLE IN SOUTHEAST L. A.
COUNTY THERE ARE PLANS TO BUILD
A CHARTER SCHOOL IN A SITE
CONTAINING LEAD AND ARSENIC
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE PUT
HEIR HEALTH AT RISK BY GOING
TO CLASS AB SEVEN SIXTY WILL
SIMPLY ENSURE THAT POTENTIAL
HAZARDS AND SOURCE OF HE
POLLUTION NEAR PRIVATE AND
CHARTER SCHOOL SITES ARE
IDENTIFIED INVESTIGATED. SO
THAT SCHOOLS CAN BE BUILT
SAFELY I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE SCHOOL
ORGANIZATIONS FOR CALLING THIS
BILL A SENSE FOR HOW HIS BILL A
SENSIBLE REASONABLE AND
PRACTICAL MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I ABOUT.
MY WITNESSES. WILL BE ALLEN ABS
FROM THE- FROM THE BEAR. I
CALLED BEAR AIR CALL MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT AND STEVEN WENK WAS A
FORMER STUDENT OF THE STRAFFORD
SCHOOL VIA PHONE. OKAY TO YOUR
WITNESSES MISTER RIDLEY. SIR
ALAN ABS FIRST HE'S GOING TO BE
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM I
BELIEVE- YES OKAY. GOOD MORNING
CHERO DONALD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM ALLEN ABSOLUTE
SLATE OF OFFICERS WITH BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
WHICH WORKS TO PROVIDE A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT TO NEARLY
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
NINE COUNTY BAY AREA REGION.
THE BAY AREA AT&T IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO
AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEE FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. IN
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT BILL TO
PROTECT CHILDREN'S HEALTH. IN
CURRENT LAW PRIOR TO
CONSTRUCTING A NEW PUBLIC
SCHOOL PUBLICLY FUNDED CHARTER
SCHOOL SCHOOL AUTHORITIES ARE
REQUIRED TO PERFORM SEVERAL
ACTS OF DUE DILIGENCE THE
BETTER ENSURE THE HEALTH OF
THEIR FUTURE STUDENTS AND
SCHOOL STAFF. THEY DETERMINE
THAT THE PROPERTY COULD BE
BUILT UPON IS NOT A CURRENT OR
FORMER HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE OR
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE RELEASE
SITE. THEY CONSULT WITH STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO MAKE A
FINDING THAT THE HEALTH RISKS
OR OTHER POLLUTION SOURCES DO
NOT AND WILL NOT CONSTITUTE. AN
ACTUAL OR POTENTIAL
ENDANGERMENT OF PUBLIC HELP THE
PERSON TO ATTEND TO BE EMPLOYED
AT THE SCHOOL. THIS INCLUDES
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT OR
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
TO IDENTIFY BOTH PERMITTED AND
NON PERMITTED FACILITIES WITHIN
THAT DISTRICTS AUTHORITY.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FREEWAYS AND OTHER BUSY TRAFFIC
CORRIDORS LARGE AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS IN RAIL YARDS WITHIN
ONE FOURTH OF A MILE. THAT
MIGHT REASONABLY BE ANTICIPATED
TO ADMIT HAZARDOUS AIR
EMISSIONS. THIS IS A
REQUIREMENT THAT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY APPLY TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND SOME CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND WHILE WE ARE NOT
CLAIMING THAT A LARGE NUMBER OF
THE SCHOOLS ARE POORLY CITED
INCREASING LAND USE DENSITY AND
RE PURPOSING INFILL SITES
RAISES THE POSSIBILITY THAT
WITHOUT SIMILAR DUE DILIGENCE.
FUTURE SCHOOLS MAY BE
CONSTRUCTED IN THE VICINITY OF
POLLUTION SOURCES THAT
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSE CHILDREN
AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. AND
CREATE AN UNHEALTHY WORK
ENVIRONMENT EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY
TWO REQUIRES THE SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES TO ASSESS THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND AIR
POLLUTION CONDITIONS ON AND IN
THE VICINITY OF THE SCHOOL. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS INFORMATION
AND IF NECESSARY TO USE IT IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
WHEN CONSTRUCTING THEIR SCHOOL
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AGAIN THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
FOR OFFERING THIS BILL. AND I
ASK FOR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO YOUR NEXT. WITNESS
ON THE PHONE I BELIEVE IT IS
STEVEN **** THE MORNING. MY
NAME STEPHEN LANG AND I- A
SCHOOL. THE DALLAS ASSEMBLY
SEVENTY TWO. AND THE IMPACTS
FOR THE GREAT CAL. ALL OF YOU
TO AND WILL BE HOW ARE SELDOM
SHOULD BE TO WITH THIS IN MY-
AND THIS BEGIN WITH ENSURE THAT
THE AND BY. IT CONDITION TO
PARTY GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT.
IF CHILDREN CONSTANTLY SEE IN
BRAVE TOXINS THAT ARE KNOWN TO
HAVE DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON THE
HUMAN BODY. HOW CAN THIS
POSSIBLY BE ACHIEVED. EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE FIRST STEP
IN BRINGING CHILDREN AWAY FROM
THESE TOXIC MATERIALS AND
TOWARD A BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONES I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO-
LET'S GO TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER ANY QUESTIONS MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THAT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED BHUVANA
SCORE SILVA SECOND AYE MR. I
THINK- ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
COMMONS SEEING NO COMMITTEE
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL. WILL GO
TO THE PUBLIC- IS ARE THERE ANY
PERSONS IN THE ROOM THAT WHICH
TO. WEIGH IN ON THIS BILL.
NOBODY IN THE ROOM ON THE PHONE
LINES GO TO THE PHONES NOW
WE'RE ON A. B. SEVEN SIX TWO
MISTER LEVY AB SEVEN SIX TWO IF
YOU WISH TO WEIGH IN ON THIS
BILL I WAS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. ONLY TO THE PHONES.
THANK YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN SIXTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON A. B. SEVEN SIXTY TWO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF. FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS-OPEN. MORNING MR SENTIMENT IN
MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY THING DIEGO OR.
THANK YOU ABOUT THE LINE OF
FIVE ALL FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS BROUGHT
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF ABOUT.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE UP
FIVE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SHANNON
SHAW AND I SUPPORT THE EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO BILL. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE OF FOUR SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CHRIS BECAUSE I AM A PARENT OF
A FOR MORE. STUDENT THE STOCK.
AFTER I STARTED SUPPORT EIGHTY
THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO HELP
PROTECT OUR KIDS HEALTHY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
OF FOUR TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BONTA MESCAL CORNY
TEACHER AYE OPPOSED. SEVEN
SIXTY. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE TO THE MOTO AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. TURNING OVER
MOBILE. THANK YOU AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP FOR SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
BRITTANY PICKETT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINE- FIVE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME OF THE SHOW ONE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. SEVEN
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
THE LINE OF FIVE EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
TERRY CASEY I'M A HOMESCHOOL
PARENT WITH I. LEAD CHARTER
SCHOOL ANNEX STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE SPELL. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU- IS THERE ANY
REMOTE TESTIMONY IN THE CAPITAL
FROM CAPITOL PARK. I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE IS- SO WHAT WE GO
TO THE AUTHOR MAKES THE OTHER
MADE CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. NAY WE HAVE HAD A MOTION
AND A SECOND IS THAT CORRECT
OKAY SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROACH YOU APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THE SECRETARIAL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
O'DONNELL BY DONAL I KILEY.
KILEY KNOW BENNETT BENNETT I
DALY. TALLY NOT VOTING PLEASE
FIVE LEE HI MCCARTY HI MCCARTY
ALRIGHT QUICK SILVA. QUICK
SILVA HI. THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTE. THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTERS
OUT MISTER LEE THANK YOU. ARE
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GO TO AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE BY MR
MCCARTY AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE.
FILE ITEM NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- THIS IS AN ISSUE
RELATED TO ADULT EDUCATION
WHICH I KNOW EVERYBODY IS A FAN
THAT WE HAVE PROGRAMS ALL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA VERY%
CENTRAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES
FOCUSING ON BASIC SKILLS
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
CITIZENSHIP CLASSES AND HELPING
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS GO BACK
AND GET THEIR DIPLOMA HI I KNOW
THIS FIRST HAND. THANKS THIS IS
SOME OF THE BEFORE AND THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THIRTY YEARS
AGO I FLUNKED OUT OF MY LOCAL
HIGH SCHOOL AND HAD TO GO TO MY
LOCAL ADULT ADD TO TURN MY LFE
AROUND AND HERE I AM TODAY AND
I KNOW THAT IT'LL EDUCATION
MATTERS- THIS ADULT THAT TOOK A
BIG HIT DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION- WE HAVE SINCE
RESTORED SOME FUNDING ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. IN OUR STATE BUDGET-
BY TWO OFTEN SOME OF THESE
ADULT EDUCATION CONSORTIUM
MEMBERS TOWARD THEIR MONIES AND
DON'T SPEND IT AND INSTEAD HAVE
CARRYOVER FUNDS YEAR AFTER
YEAR- THIS BUILDING SENSUALLY
SAY THAT IT'S OKAY TO HAVE A
CARRY OVER A YEAR AFTER YEAR
BUT WE SHOULD HAVE A REASONABLE
CAP OF 15% SUMMER CONCERNED
THAT THESE MONIES WOULD GO BACK
TO THE- BY THE GENERAL FUND I
KNOW THESE MONIES WOULD GO BACK
TO FIND ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
THIS IS NECESSARY
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE THAT
MORE OF OUR STATE MONIES GO TO
WHERE THEY ARE ALLOCATED- IN
pPROGRAM THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA-
WITH ME ARE TO- SPEAKERS WHO
THEY ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BELFAST CARE ACT. THANK YOU. I
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE JOINT TURKEY FROM THE
FORMER CHIEF MOUNT DIABLO
UNIFIED BOARD MEMBER. AND
KATHLEEN PORTER THE BOAT WHICH
EVERYONE IS IN THE QUEUE MAY.
PROCEED. OKAY I MIGHT HI MY
NAME IS SAID TO ENTERTAIN AND I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WHY I AM SUPPORTIVE OF
AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE AS A
FORMER TEACHER ADMINISTRATOR
AND SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER FROM
OUT OF A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I HAVE A FRONT ROW
VIEW OF HOW THIS BILL WILL BE
GOOD FOR ADULT LEARNERS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST NEED FOR EDUCATION
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING A MEMBER
OF THE STATE WORKERS JOINTLY
CONVENED A TWENTY THIRTEEN BY
THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE CANCERS
OFFICE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DESIGNING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB EIGHTY SIX
IN A WAY THAT WOULD ENSURE
SERVICES ARE RESOURCES ARE
OPTIMIZED AND MOST EFFECTIVE
DATE ALL THE TRADITIONAL REGION
CONSTRUCTION STRUCTURE CAME
FROM THIS PROCESS WITH AN
EXPECTATION THAT LOCAL PLANS
WOULD BE BASED ON PRIORITIZE
WHO NEEDS A TRUE COORDINATION
COLLABORATIONAMONG K. TWELVE
AND THREE BECAUSE THAT ALL
EDUCATORS. AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
AWARE A LOT OF HARD WORK IS
STARTING TO THE FABRIC OF THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS WITH MANY
POSITIVE OUTCOMES AT THIS STAGE
IN THE PROCESS HOWEVER SOME
PERSISTENT CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND EIGHTY FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE IS DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THEM THAT IS
ENSURING THAT PRECIOUS DOLLARS
NEEDED FOR UNMET NEEDS ARE IN.
FACT BEING UTILIZED IN A TIMELY
MANNER. A MAJORITY OF EDUCATION
CONCERTS MEMBERS DATE OTHER.
PRO IS THERE. SOURCE OF RAW.
RATE TO SERVES TO AND COMMUNITY
SCENE DOLLARS CARRIED OVER YEAR
AFTER YEAR. FLIES IN THE FACE
OF THEIR EFFORTS TO INCREASE
UNNECESSARY TENSION OF
CONSTRUCTION TABLE. LOCAL
CONSTRUCTION NEED YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS INCREASE STATEWIDE
ACCOUNT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
USE OF ALLOCATIONS. SAYING
PRAYER WORKS HARD AND CRAFTING
AND BETTING THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE. SO THAT THE INTEGRITY
OF LOCAL PLANNING CONTROL ARE
INTACT BUT ALSO ENSURES THAT
BINDING ISSUES EACH YEAR AS
INTENDED. I'M AWARE OF THE
CONCERNS ABOUT AB FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE ANOTHER BUT SHARED
AND WANT TO POINT OUT. THAT
THEY JUST CRIED NEGATIVE
IMPACTS SHOULD ONLY COME TO
FRUITION IF LOCAL CONSTRUCTION
AREN'T FULFILLING THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY. I FUNDING
OVERSIGHT AND DECISION MAKING.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO KATHLEEN PORTER.
GOOD MORNING I'M- ORDER
BUILDING CENTER. IN TALLY YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ADULT EDUCATION. I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. CURRENTLY
THE CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM PROVIDES EIGHT THREE
YEARS SPENDING WINDOW FOR
ALLOCATIONS NOT BASED ON
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS. TO
CARRY OVER IS DEFINED AS FUNDS
REMAINING AFTER THAT THREE YEAR
PERIOD. AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE
PROPOSES USING THE MORE COMMON
CONCEPT OF CARRY OVER. THAT
TIME TO ALLOCATED THE ANY GIVEN
YEAR ARE FOR USE IN THAT YEAR.
THIS DISTINCTION IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE WHEN WE CONSIDER
MAKING A DIFFERENCE TO
CALIFORNIANS IN NEED OF ADULT
EDUCATION SERVICES TODAY. WITH
THREE YEAR DEFINITION CARRYOVER
IS REPORTED TO BE BETWEEN FOUR
AND TEN PERCENT. HOWEVER HUSING
THE YEAR OVER YEAR MODEL
PROPOSAL PROPOSED IN AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE CARRYOVER
IS ESTIMATED TO BE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION OR
24% OF THE TOTAL ANNUAL
ALLOCATION. AND THERE ARE MORE
THAN TWENTY AGENCIES CARRYING
OVER MORE THAN A 100% OF THEIR
ANNUAL ALLOCATION QUITE SIMPLY
THIS MEANS THAT FUNDING IS NOT
SERVING STUDENTS IN THOSE AREAS
IN THE FISCAL YEAR. NEFL CLASS
CUTS ROUGHLY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PER YEAR AND SERVICE
TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY STUDENTS
SO ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION EQUATES TO FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED MORE CLASSES. SERVING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS STATEWIDE AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE PROVIDES
LOCAL CONSORTIA THE TOOLS
NEEDED TO MEET THE UNMET NEEDS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES EACH YEAR
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ADULT
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND THE
STUDENTS WE SERVE. I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THE
OPPOSITION. A WITNESSES FOR AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE A FIRST I
HAVE- IT LOOKS LIKE MADELINE
OUR BOTTLE IF I SAID THAT
CORRECTLY AND THIS IS- THAT IS
FOR OPPOSITION I ALSO HAVE A
VALENTINA PURTELL. YEAH COUNTY
NOT PERTINENT HERE GOING. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VALENTINA PATEL AND I
REPRESENTS NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
IT'S ALL FOR MY HONOR TO SERVE
AS PRESIDENT OF NORTH ORANGE
CONTINUING EDUCATION WHICH IS
ONE OF THE THREE INSTITUTIONS
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND THE MAIN -VIDER
OF ADULT EDUCATION IN NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY REGION. FIRST I
WANT TO SAY THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ABOUT THAT PROVIDERS
WORK CLOSELY AND
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
KEISTER TWELVE PARTNERS AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL CONSORTIUM
LEVELS. RELATED TO CALIFORNIA
ADULT EDUCATION PROGRAM. IN
FACT WE HAD MULTIPLE MEETINGS
WITH THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE DISAGREE
ON SEVERAL TECHNICAL ASPECT OF
THIS BILL. WHICH WOULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT ABOUT THAT
CONSORTIUM ESPECIALLY WORKING
IN TWO COLLEGES ARE SERVICE
PROVIDERS. THE PHYSICALLY 15%
CAP IS NOT A REASONABLE
THRESHOLD FOR CARRYOVER GIVEN
THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS PROGRAM
AND A VARIETY OF PROVIDERS.
SECOND ONE YEAR LIMITATION FOR
THE SPENDING CYCLE WILL BE
MISALIGNED WITH YOUR THREE YEAR
PLANNING CYCLE. AND TOGETHER
WITH THE 15% BLEND IT WOULD
LEAD TO CARELESS SPENDING. AND
FINALLY FOUND CONSORTIUM WOULD
BE IN DANGER OF LOSING REGIONAL
FUNDING DUE TO ACCUMULATION OF
CARRYOVER BY INDIVIDUAL
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO OUR CONCERNS.
GREAT THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE
IT'S MATALIN ARE FOLLOW IS
STILL GOING TO TESTIFY. I'M
HERE. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS START HELLO YES
PROCEED. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
INPUT ON THIS BILL AND SUPPORT
OF ADULT EDUCATION MY NAME IS
MADELINE OUR VIOLENT PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION A PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION OF MORE THAN FIFTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION AB FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE. THE THREE ORIGINAL
PLAN THE CONSORTIA CREATE
PROMOTE GOALS TO BE DEVELOPED
OVER LONGER TIME FRAMES THAT
NEED LONGER TIME TO EXPAND BUT
NOT HARD FUNDS WE CAN THEN PLAN
PROGRAMS FOR IMMEDIATE
EMPLOYMENT A COLLEGE TRANSITION
FOR EXAMPLE IF A SCHOOL SIX TO
START ELECTED OFFICIAL NURSES
PROGRAM. UNLESS COUNTY
APPROVALS THAT MAY BE LONG TERM
FOLLOW BY PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
THAT COULD TAKE MORE THAN A
YEAR A MEMBER CONSENT CARRYOVER
FUNDS TO ENSURE THAT THIS
HUGELY IN DEMAND PROGRAM THAT
IS THE CENTRAL AND BOTH A
CRITICAL NEED IS AFFORDED THE
TIME TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT.
SUCCESS OF A PROGRAM CAN ALSO
BE DEPENDENT ON THE TIME LINE
AND FUTURE OUTCOMES MAY BE
SERIOUSLY IMPACTED I UNDERSTAND
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR CONSORTIA
TO KERRY OF WHAT THEY'RE
SPECIFICALLY BY YES HOWEVER THE
METHOD TO BECOME BUDGET PLAYED
A- INTENT IS OPEN FOR NOW OUR
INTERPRETATION AND CONSTRUCTION
MEMBERS FUNDS. MAY BE LEFT
VULNERABLE AND HAVE WE EVER
EVEN STUDIED THE IMPACT ON THE
OUTCOME OF SPENDING AT CERTAIN
LEVELS EACH YEAR FIRST. BENDING
OVER PLAN KIND. I THE GAME MADE
IN THE- VALUED AT THE THAT
PARTNERSHIP. CAN BE LEFT AND
WITH THEM. OF THE CALL. WE
AGREE THERE NEEDS TO BE
ATTENTION PAID TO LESS CARRY
AMOUNT. BUT THIS POLICY IS
SIMPLE TO BRING IN P. IT IS THE-
CHILE. CARRYOVER ABOUT THE TEN
A STRUCTURED NON LEGISLATIVE
TO. AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL. TO A
BURST HOGAN AMOUNTS KERRY OF.
AN APPROACH WITH. IS FEDERAL.
AND WE'RE STILL OPEN TO
SOLUTIONS OUTSIDE OF
LEGISLATIVE FIXES. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF ADULT
EDUCATION. THANK YOU- ANY
QUESTION WHAT QUESTIONS ARE
COMING FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL JUST- JUST MAKE A
QUICK STATEMENT ON THIS IS YOUR
MCCARTY. IF YOU SIT ON MONEY
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS YOU INVITE
A LEGISLATOR TO COME IN. AND
MAKE FOR THEIR LAWN HOW YOU
SPEND YOUR MONEY SO- YOU KNOW
THIS IS A GOOD THING BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO GET THE MONEY OUT
THE DOOR AND TO SERVE PEOPLE.
SERVER DAHLE SOY APPRECIATE-
YOUR MISSION HERE WITH THAT
MISTER BENNETT. I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATED AND THE IDEA OF A
100% FUNDING- SITTING IN
RESERVES OF. HAS TO BE REALLY
FRUSTRATING FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
GET THE EDUCATION OUT BUT I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR. THAT-
AFTER SAID HANDLING BUDGETS A
NUMBER OF TIMES. IF THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN A GOOD FACE
ORGANIZATION SOMETHING HAPPENS
AT THE LAST MINUTE SO MONEY HAS
COME IN OR WHATEVER SO TO THE
EXTENT AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. YOU CAN BUILD WHAT YOU
THINK IS APPROPRIATE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE GOOD FAITH
ORGANIZATION THAT. IS CAUGHT
TEMPORARILY NEEDING TO GO OVER-
IF- I JUST WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT- OUTSIDE OF THAT IS
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH I DON'T THINK THAT- THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO
DO AND LOOK WE'RE GONNA KEEP
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND- MAYBE IT'S NOT 15% MAYBE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS SOME
IDEAS AS WELL BUT HAVING A 100%
OF YOUR MONEY. LEFT LEFT OVER
IS NOT OUR WILL BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY YOU'RE DEPRIVING
THE COMMUNITY WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM THESE. ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM SENSE OF THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE WANT TO DO AND SO- BUT
YEAH THANK YOU WE'LL KEEP
WORKING AND FIND. AN
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION THANKS
THANK. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
COMMENTARY COMMITTEE MEMBER
SAYING UNFERMENTED THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- ANY PERSONS IN
THE ROOM WHICH TO TESTIFY- SURE
THEIR OPINION OF THIS BILL.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE NOW- THE PHONE AND WE ARE
ON AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. BY
MR MCCARTY WHICH SPEAKS TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WELL ADULT
EDUCATION FUNDING- TO THE PHONE
FOR TEN MINUTES SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF áP.
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE- OF SIX TWENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS ACTUALLY WALKER WITH
NOT THE MEN ON BEHALF OF MOUNT
SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF SIX TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CALLING PACKED HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE LAST ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CAN AND WE
WILL GO TIMELINE OF FIVE NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OR SOME
OF THE CLASSICAL FROM SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE IN SANTA MONICA
REGIONAL CONSORTIUM ENDEARMENT
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
VEHEMENT THANK YOU. MEXICO
CAROLINA FOR FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE LETTER THAT
ME YES PLEASE GO AHEAD- YES
GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
STANDARD MARC HAS BEEN I AM A
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS. AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. AGAIN WE'RE
ON AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIVE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS STACY
AFTER TEN AND CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE OF TWO NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE SIX TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
ARMADA SORRY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE BUT WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BILL AT THE TIME WE DO
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT 15%
THRESHOLD WHERE WE ARE LOOKING
FOR DIFFERENT BY THE AUTHOR. I
THANK THE GENTLEMAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO GO TO
LINE OF SIX. FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
BETH DEAN AND I'M A CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENTS I AM A TEACHER I'M
A REGISTERED NURSE AND A PARENT
AND STUDENT IN A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO OTHER
NO FURTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU ONE JUST
QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT WE GOT
FOUR SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS IT'S ME THAT
THE I'M A PARENT OF FIVE. YOU
CAN GET NOW. SO THEN I HAVE
BEING SCHOOL AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN Q. AT THIS TIME
IS THERE ANY TESTIMONY OF ROOM
CAPITOL PARK I DON'T SEE ANY
TESTIMONY FROM CAPITOL PARK ON
THIS BILL COMING UP- WITH THAT.
WILL THE AUTHOR MAY CLOSE. I
ASK THE ARRIVAL THINKING- DO WE
HAVE MOTION ON IT NO WE DID NOT
A MOTION. DO EMOTION BOTH
RECOMMENDED ACTION- IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY MISTER BENNETT. THE
SECOND BY MISS CORK SILVA- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
DONALD BY DONALD I KILEY. KILEY
KNOW BENNETT. HI SENATE HI
SALLY. SALLY I LEAVE. MCCARTY
HI MCCARTY I QUICK SILVA. CORKS
SILVA NOT VOTING THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES GREAT TO THE BILL'S
ALLIES FOR VOTES WERE GONNA
MOVE AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. I'M
GONNA HAND THE GAVEL TO MISTER
MCCARTY I KNOW YOU ARE MISTER
KILEY I APOLOGIZE MISTER KILEY
I KNOW YOU WANTED TO MAKE A
STATEMENT ABOUT. SOME
LIMITATIONS ECCENTRICITY- I
MEAN AYE- AYE AYE I'LL FOLLOW
THE PROTOCOL SET OUT BY THE
CHAIR. BUT I DO WANT TO RENEW
MY OBJECTION TO THE LIMITS ON
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THAT ARE.
HAPPENING THIS COMMITTEE AND
HAVE STARTED HAPPENING IN OTHER
CITIES- AND I ALSO THINK MORE
BROADLY IN THIS IS NOT YOUR
WHAT'S THAT ASSEMBLY DECISION
THAT. IT'S KIND OF TIME TO
START LETTING THE PUBLIC BACK
INTO THE BUILDING IN A MORE
MEANINGFUL WAY. TO THAT WE CAN
HAVE YOU KNOW PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AS AS WE HAVE HAD
AND IS A RIGHT PROTECTED IN THE
CONSTITUTION ESPECIALLY AS WE
HAVE. FOLKS GOING TO KINGS
GAMES DOWN THE STREET SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE. YOU KNOW THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE ASSEMBLY TO
START TO. MOVE US BACK TOWARDS
A MORE MEANINGFUL PROCESS OF
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CARLY I APPRECIATE THAT
THIS SYSTEM THE SITUATION WE
FIND OURSELVES IN IS NOT
PERFECT. I AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT IT'S BEEN FRUSTRATING TO
ME A BIT- BUT I JUST WANT TO
KNOW WE FOLLOW THESE PROTOCOLS
THIS YEAR FOR EVERY BILL. EVERY
HEARING WE HAVEN'T CHANGED HIM
FOR ANY BILL. AND I JUST AS
CHAIR NEED TO REMAIN
CONSISTENT. BUT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOUR FRUSTRATION
INTO TO HELP THAT WE START TO
REOPEN. AS OUR POSITIVITY IN
CASE RATES FALL DRAMATICALLY
THE BEST. STATE THE NATION
RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS- YOU KNOW
NOT HAVING SO MUCH GO WITH
EXETER SO THAT'S A GOOD THING
AND I THINK WE NEED TO RESPOND
TO THAT SO THANK YOU. WITH THAT
THAT THIS IS YOURS. AND G. FIVE
MILLION YEAH. OTHER INMATE. A
LETTER TO WITH HER IN THE HEAD-
FOR. ATTENTION YEAH SO YOU
PROBABLY HAVE TEN. THE END OF
THE ROOM TEN AROUND TEN OKAY
AND THAT'LL KEEP TIME AND I
HAVE A- THING TO SHOW YOU. IS
THAT THE. THIS IS A AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT
ALL. GREAT THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND BEFORE I
START- JUST AS YOU AS I MAKE MY
COMMENTS TODAY. WILL WELL LAY
THEM OUT NO WAY MORAL WERE ALSO
UP AND THIS. WHAT YOU WON'T
HEAR ME SAY WHEN I SAY PROBLEMS
IS. ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
SOLUTION SHUT THEM DOWN. THAT'S
NOT WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT-
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. CREATING
MORE OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
AND EVEN INCREASING SOME AUDITS
TO ENSURE THAT. STUDENTS ARE
SUCCEEDING AND PUBLIC MONEY IS
SPENT WISELY THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT AGAIN- JUST FOR AN
EDITORIAL THINK ONLINE LEARNING
IS NOT GOING AWAY I THINK WE
LEARNED THAT EVEN MORE LAST
YEAR HAS BEEN REAL SUCCESSFUL
QUITE FRANKLY. I THINK WE WERE
ALL OF KNOWLEDGE THAT. BUT FOR
SOME STUDENTS IT MAY BE
SUCCESSFUL AND SO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS KIND OF BRING IT IN TO
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CREATE SOME. SOME GOOD
GOVERNMENT PRACTICES AROUND IT.
AND MOVE FORWARD. SO WITH THAT-
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY SEEKS TO DO THREE THINGS
ENSURE ALL CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS
TO A QUALITY EDUCATION. WHETHER
IT BE A TRADITIONAL BRICK AND
MORTAR SCHOOL OR AN ONLINE
SCHOOL. TO PROTECT PUBLIC MONEY
THROUGH GOOD GOVERNMENT
POLICIES SUCH AS AUDITS
TRANSPARENCY AND STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY PRACTICES FOR
ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOLS. JUST AS
THEY ARE FOR TRADITIONAL SCHOOL
OPERATIONS AND OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES BETTER
STEWARDS OF PUBLIC MONEY. ALSO
TO STOP THE WELL DOCUMENTED
FRAUD AMONG MANY NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION STUDENTS RECEIVE IN
THE SCHOOLS. BY ENSURING THAT
THE MONEY THEY RECEIVE IS FOR
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES. NOT TO
LINE THE POCKETS OF THOSE WHO
WISH TO STEAL. PUBLIC MONEY
WHICH IN SOME CASES WE HAVE
SEEN. I AM A FIRM BELIEVER THAT
AN IN PERSON EDUCATION SETTING
SERVE STUDENTS BEST. BUT FULLY
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME STUDENTS DO
THRIVE IN AN ONLINE SETTING AND
WE WILL OFFER YOU THIS
ALTERNATIVE APPROACH IN
CALIFORNIA. AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO SHUT DOWN ONLINE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL IS NOT FOR
YOU IF YOU WANT TO IMPROVE THEM
THIS BILL IS FOR YOU. I BELIEVE
ONLINE LEARNING IS NOT GOING
AWAY AND I AM NOT TRYING TO
ELIMINATED BUT WE MUST FORTIFY
IT WITH EXPECTATIONS OF QUALITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. AND GET RID
OF THE FRAUD THAT HAS BEEN LONG
ASSOCIATED. WITH THIS TYPE OF
LEARNING. THE FACT IS THAT THE
NINETEEN NINETY TWO CHARTER
SCHOOL LEVEL NEVER COME BLOOD
THE NINETEEN NINETY TWO CHARTER
SCHOOL LAW NEVER CONTEMPLATED
ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOLS. SO
THERE'S RELATIVELY MINIMAL
STATUTORY GUIDANCE AND
OVERSIGHT OF THIS TYPE OF
SCHOOLING JUST AS IN A LOT OF
LAW OUT THERE. PEOPLE OF TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE- IT IS TIME TO
END THE WILD WEST PROVIDE TRUE
OVERSIGHT STOP THE FRAUD AND
ALL OF THE NEGATIVE HYPE AND
SCANDALS ASSOCIATED WITH HIS
THIS APPROACH TO LEARNING. SO
ISSUE NUMBER ONE FRAUD OR THEFT
OF PUBLIC MONEY BY MANIPULATING
OR DOCTORING STUDENT ATTENDANCE
DATA THIS IS HAPPENING HOW DO
WE ADDRESS IT WE FORTIFY THE
STATUTES THAT SPEAK TO SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE. THERE ARE MANY
EXAMPLES OF FRAUD WITHIN SIGHT
THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES OF
FRAUD ACROSS OUR STATE. TODAY
WE WILL SHARE ONE CASE IN
PARTICULAR FROM SAN DIEGO. THIS
EXAMPLE WILL BE SHARED BY THE
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. THIS FRAUD WAS
PROMULGATED BY THE NOW DEFUNCT
EIGHT THREE CHARTER SCHOOL
NETWORK WHICH DEFRAUDED
TAXPAYERS VENTURE OLDER BY
STEALING THE IDENTITIES OF
LITTLE LEAGUE PLAYERS IN ORDER
TO BUILD THE STATE. FOR
EDUCATION THEY NEVER PROVIDED.
THIS CHARTER NETWORK USED EACH
CHILD'S INFORMATION TOOL ROLL
THEM IN THEIR CHARTER SCHOOLS
OVER THE SUMMER. THE CHARTER
SCHOOL NEVER PROVIDED ANY
INSTRUCTION TO THESE CHILDREN.
IN FACT THE PARENTS HAD NO IDEA
THEIR CHILDREN WERE EVER
ENROLLED. IN A CHARTER SCHOOL.
YET THEY COLLECTED ATTENDANCE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE FOR
THOSE CHILDREN AS THOUGH THEY
DID ATTEND THAT SCHOOL. THE A.
THREE CHARTER SCHOOL NETWORK
USED ANOTHER SCHEME TO COLLECT
EVEN MORE FUNDING. THEY MOVE
STUDENTS BETWEEN THEIR SCHOOLS
AND MANIPULATED THEIR CALENDAR
USING MULTI TRACK YEAR ROUND
SCHEDULING. TO DRAW DOWN FAR
MORE. THAN ONCE ONE SCHOOL YEAR
OF ATTENDANCE FUNDING PER
STUDENT. AT ONE POINT THE- SOME
OF THE FOLKS THAT WERE
DEFENDING SOMEBODY INDIVIDUALS
IN A THREE I SAW THIS AND IN
THE MEDIA. AS I RECALL THEY
DEFENDED WHAT THEY DID WAS
LEGAL BECAUSE THERE IS NO LAW
THAT SAID IT WASN'T LEGAL. SO
WE NEED TO CLOSE THIS GAP. WITH
THIS BILL WE WILL CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLES AND THIS TYPE OF
FRAUD THE EIGHTY EIGHTY THREE
TYPE OF FRAUD AND OTHER TYPES
OF FRAUD BY ENDING THE USE OF
MULTI TRACK YEAR ROUND SCHEDULE
FOR BOTH DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS UNLESS THEY TRULY HAVE.
FACILITY CHALLENGES. IMPROVING
CHARTER AUTHORIZER OVERSIGHT OF
CHARTER SCHOOL ATTENDANCE.
ESTABLISHING TRAINING FOR BOTH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOL AUDITORS AND REQUIRING
AUDITORS O LOOK MORE CLOSELY
AT STUDENT ATTENDANCE.
PROHIBITING PRIVATE RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS OR SCHOOLS FROM
SERVING AS VENDORS AT CHARTER
SCHOOLS. REQUIRING A STUDY TO
CONNECT THE CAL PADS SYSTEM TO
THE ATTENDANCE FUNDING SYSTEM.
AND WE WILL HAVE MICHAEL FLYING
HERE FROM THICK MAT WHO SPECIFY
THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE BUT WE
NEED TO SEE WHAT STUDENTS ARE
WHERE SO THEY'RE NOT GETTING
COUNTED INC IN TWO DIFFERENT
PLACES AT ONCE AGAIN FUNDING. A
TWO DIFFERENT SCHOOL SYSTEMS AT
ONCE THIS BILL ALSO CREATES AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE FRAUD AND ABUSE IN
ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT OR CHARTER
SCHOOL OPERATION ACROSS OUR
STATE AND AGAIN THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL WOULD NOT SOLELY FOCUS
ON CHARTER SCHOOLS NOT WOULD BE
FOR ALL. SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIANS NEED. ISSUE
NUMBER TWO. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT ONLINE EDUCATION IS
FOCUSED ON STUDENT SUCCESS. HOW
DO WE ADDRESS IT WOULD BOLSTER
TEACHER AND STUDENT ACCOUNT OF
THE- WE BOLSTER STUDENT
TEACHER. AND STUDENT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS. THE QUALITY AND
OUTCOMES OF INDEPENDENT STUDY
AT NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS
NEEDS TO IMPROVE. STUDIES BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF OREGON
STANFORD AND VANDERBILT ALL
SHOW THAT STUDENTS AN ONLINE
SCHOOL SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERPERFORM ACADEMICALLY
COMPARED TO STUDENTS TAUGHT IN
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOMS. THE
STANFORD STUDY SHOWED THAT
STUDENTS AND NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS MADE SO
LITTLE PROGRESS IN MATH THAT
WAS AS IF THE STUDENTS HAD NOT
ATTENDED SCHOOL FOR AN ENTIRE.
YEAR THE DATA IS CLEAR MANY
STUDENTS THAT ATTEND AN ONLINE
CHARTER SCHOOL PERFORMED POORLY.
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN
THIS THE STATE HAS AN
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE BY BOLSTERING
TEACHER AND STUDENT
ACCOUNTABILITY. CURRENTLY
TEACHERS AN INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAMS HAVE NO MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT FOR HOW OFTEN THEY
INTERACT. WITH THEIR STUDENTS.
THEY COULD SEE THEM AS LITTLE
AS ONCE PER SEMESTER. GIVEN
THAT THE TYPICAL ONLINE SCHOOL
STUDENT IS NOT PERFORMING AT
GRADE LEVEL THIS IS AN
ATROCITY. THIS PRESS STICKS
THIS PRACTICE CANNOT BE
DEFENDED. STUDENTS ARE NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE OFTEN RECEIVING A SUB PAR
EDUCATION. SOME STUDENTS IN
THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVE
INSTRUCTION FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT CREDENTIAL. IT IS POSSIBLE
THEY HAVE NO HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA OR COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THEY OFTEN HAVE NOT EVEN PASSED
A STATE LEVEL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THIS RAISES SERIOUS SKILL SET
AND SAFETY CONCERNS FOR OUR
STUDENTS. AN ONLINE SCHOOL
VENDOR COULD BE TEACHING MATH
WITH NO UNDERSTANDING OF THE
TOPIC NOR HOW TO TEACH IT. AN
ONLINE SCHOOL VENDOR COULD HAVE
A CRIMINAL BACKGROUND BUT WITH
NO BACKGROUND CHECKS. WHO WOULD
KNOW. WITH THIS BILL WE SUIT TO
ADDRESS THE QUALITY OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY PROGRAMS IN
BOTH SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS.
BY ESTABLISHING A MINIMUM
FREQUENCY OF TEACHER AND
STUDENT INTERACTION. REQUIRING
VENDORS TO HAVE A CREDENTIAL.
IF THEY'RE SERVICES COUNT
TOWARD INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES
THIS PROVIDES PARITY WITH ALL
OTHER CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TODAY.
ESTABLISHING A MINIMUM SCHOOL
DAY FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS LIKE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THIS IS PERRY.
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO HAVE AN IN
PERSON OPTION TO SERVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS AND
STRUGGLING STUDENTS WHO NEED
AND PERSON INSTRUCTION AND
SUPPORT. YOU SUCCEED.
ESTABLISHING METRICS FOR ENDING
A STUDENTS INDEPENDENT STUDY
AGREEMENT WHEN THE SCHOOL IS
NOT MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS AGAIN THAT'S FOR
CHARTER AND TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS.
LET ME WALK THROUGH SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS WE HAVE HEARD FROM
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL.
OPPONENTS WILL TELL YOU THAT WE
DID NOT GAUGED ENGAGE THEM AND
WRITING THIS BILL THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY FALSE MY STAFF HAD.
SEVERAL. AND MEETINGS WERE HELD
WITH A VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING ONLINE CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN FACT WE ASK THE
CHARTER COMMUNITY FOR THEIR
IDEAS ON HOW TO STOP THIS FRAUD
THEY CAME UP WITH NEARLY
NOTHING ON HOW TO ADDRESS THE
THEFT OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS NOR
PATH TO ENSURING ATTIC ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. FOR ONLINE. SCHOOL
STUDENTS. THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT OF YEARS OF OBSERVATION
AND DISCUSSION AND RECOGNITION
THAT THE ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOL
ARENA IS RIFE WITH FRAUD. A
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
POOR ACADEMIC OUTCOMES.
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL WILL
ARGUE THAT THE BILL IS REALLY
AN EFFORT TO STOP HER CLOTHES
ONLINE SCHOOLS AND LIMIT
PARENTS CHOICES. THIS BILL WILL
NOT CLOSE A SINGLE CHARTER
SCHOOL. LET ME REPEAT REPEAT
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
THE CLOSURE OF A SINGLE ONLINE
CHARTER SCHOOL. IN FACT THIS
BILL STRENGTHENS PARENT CHOICE
BY MAKING NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS MORE ACCOUNTABLE
TRANSPARENT AND OF HIGHER
QUALITY. THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
INEQUITABLE ALL PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
A PRUDENT TO A CREDENTIALED AND
BACKGROUND CHECK TEACHER.
STUDENTS AND NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS ARE NOT BEING
GIVEN ACCESS TO CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS IN THEIR CORE. AND NON
CORE INSTRUCTION. FURTHER
SHOULDN'T THEY HAVE BACKGROUND
CHECKS TO ENSURE STUDENT SAFETY.
OPPONENTS HAVE ARGUED THAT THIS
BILL MAKES DRACONIAN CUTS. THE
TRUTH IS FOR EARLY BIRD FULLY
VIRTUAL SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
BROOKE AND MORTAR BUILDINGS TO
PAY FOR. NOR DO THEY HAVE OR
NEED THE PERSONAL THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO OPERATE. THOSE
BUILDINGS. THE FUNDING FORMULA
IN THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE LESS
FUNDING TO FULLY VIRTUAL
PROGRAMS AND MORE STATE FUNDING
TO PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE A
HYBRID MODEL SINCE THESE
PROGRAMS COST MORE TO OPERATE
IF YOU HAVE A BUILDING. YOU
HAVE AN OFFICE MANAGER YOU HAVE
A JANITOR. WHOMEVER YOU HAVE
WORKING ON THAT SITE COSTS MORE
MONEY THAN IT WOULD FOR AN
ONLINE SCHOOL THAT DOESN'T HAVE
FACILITIES TO FACILITIES COST
MONEY. OPPONENTS WILL TELL YOU
THAT THIS BILL IS TOO
BURDENSOME TO THE ABSENT TO THE
UPSTANDING CHARTER SCHOOLS DUE
TO A SINGLE BAD ACTOR. THE
FRAUD PERPETUATED BY NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
GOES FAR BEYOND THE A. THREE
CHARTER CASE. FRAUD HAS BEEN
ALLEGED EIGHT THREE VALIANT
INSPIRE KAVA EPIC TRI VALLEY
MAGNOLIA INSULARITY THERE ARE
MORE. OTHER STATES ARE ALSO
SEEING POOR ALKYD OTHER STATES
ARE ALSO SEEN POOR ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES AND FRAUD RELATED TO
NON CLASSROOMBASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND THEY ARE TAKING
ACTION. WE MUST DO THE SAME.
OPPONENTS WILL TELL YOU THAT
THIS BILL BREAKS THE AGREEMENT
ON AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE NOT AT
ALL THE TRUTH IS THAT AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE CREATED A TWO
YEAR MORATORIUM ON THESE TOUGH
ON THESE SCHOOLS PRECISELY SO
THAT WE COULD STUDY THEM AND
BRING FORWARD REFORMS BEFORE
THE MORATORIUM. EXPIRED THE
PLAN WAS ALWAYS TO COME BACK
WITH REFORMS AND THAT IS WHY WE
ARE HERE TODAY. AS WE STUDIED
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND IDENTIFY THE
PROBLEMS WE CREATED SOLUTIONS
TO STOP THE POTENTIAL FRAUD AND
ALL PUBLIC SCHOOL SETTINGS.
THAT IS WHY PARTS OF THIS BILL
APPLY TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS
WELL AS CHARTER SCHOOLS. WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE GOOSE IS GOOD FOR
THE GANDER. OPPONENTS WILL TO
OPPONENTS WILL TELL YOU THAT WE
ONLY NEED TO BEEF UP AUDITING
TO STOP THIS FRAUD NOW WE NEED
TO DO MUCH MORE. ASK ANY
AUDITOR. AS MR FINE WILL BE UP
HERE SHORTLY FROM THE FISCAL
CRISIS AND MANAGEMENT
ASSISTANCE TEAM WHEN HE
TESTIFIES AND HE WILL TELL YOU
THAT AUDIENCE AUDITING ALONE
WILL NOT SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS.
OPPONENTS WILL TELL YOU THAT
THE BILL AND STUDENT
FLEXIBILITY AS TO WHEN THEY CAN
COMPLETE THE WORK. THAT'S FALSE
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE EXISTING CD
REGULATIONS WILL BE REWORKED
AND REWRITTEN STUDENTS IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS WILL HAVE THE
SAME FLEXIBILITY AS INDEPENDENT
STUDENTS IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS I
THINK THAT PROBABLY PERTAINS TO
A PARENT WHO MIGHT HAVE A CHILD
THAT IS IN SPORTS AND MIGHT. BE
PERFORMING THAT SPORT DURING TO
THEIR PRACTICING THAT SPORT AND
THEY MIGHT NEED TO COMPLETE
THEIR INSTRUCTION AND SOME
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS
OVERSTAYING A SERVICE WE SEEK
TO ACCOMMODATE THAT WE SEEK TO
ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE TO.
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL WILL TELL
YOU THAT THEIR STUDENT
PERFORMANCES LOWER BECAUSE THEY
SERVE AT RISK STUDENTS. NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS DO NOT
SERVICE STUDENT BODY THAT IS
REFLECTIVE OF OUR STATE. THEY
SERVE SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER AT
RISK STUDENTS INCLUDING LOW
INCOME. AN ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENTS. AND ACCORDING TO THE
RESEARCH STUDENTS AND ONLINE
SCHOOLS UNDER PERFORMANCE EVERY
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP. COMPARED TO
THEIR PEERS IN CLASSROOM BASED
SCHOOLS. OPPONENTS WILL SAY
THAT SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
NOT PROBLEMATIC AUTHORIZERS.
THE TRUTH IS THESE DISTRICTS
ARE SO SMALL THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENTS ARE BOTH THE
BUS DRIVERS AND THE MATH
TEACHERS IN A FEW DISTRICTS THE
NUMBER OF CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS THEY OVERSEE IS FAR
GREATER THAN THE NUMBER OF
THEIR INDUSTRY AND ROMAN. FOR
EXAMPLE. A SCHOOL DISTRICT WHAT
TWENTY TWO STUDENTS. HAS
AUTHORIZED. IT HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED- FOR A FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED STE 440-500-4440 FIVE
HUNDRED. A STUDENT CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN OTHER WORDS A SCHOOL
DISCUSS TWENTY TWO STUDENTS. IS
OVERSEEING A CHART OF THOSE
FORTY FIVE. HUNDRED STUDENTS
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
OVERSEE FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS IF YOU ONLY HAVE
TWENTY TWO. STUDENTS IN YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT. I DISTRICT
WITH A THOUSAND ADA HAS
AUTHORIZED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED CHARTER SCHOOL
ADA. I THINK OF THE SAN DIEGO A
THREE CASE OF I REMEMBER OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD CORRECTLY.
THEY HAD ONE HUNDRED FORTY
STUDENTS IN THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. YET THEY HAD
AUTHORIZED A CHARTER TO HAVE
TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS THEY
COULDN'T OVERSEE THEM THAT'S
HOW THAT'LL THREE THAT'S- PART
OF THE REASON ONE OF THE
REASONS ONLY.THAT THE WHOLE A
THREE SCENARIO HAPPEN. SO IN
CLOSING. I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. RECEIVE
LETTERS FROM PARENTS SUGGESTING
THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON
AUDITING REFORMS AND REFORMS TO
INDEPENDENT STUDY. WE AGREE.
THIS BILL DOES BOTH. THE
LEGISLATURE MUST CLEAN UP THE
LAWN CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
TO BENEFIT ALL OF OUR CHILDREN.
AND WITH ME TODAY IS ONE OF THE
JOINT AUTHORS OF THE BILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA.
AT THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
THAT FOR WORKING ON THIS. I THE
PUBLIC GOT TO KNOW ME THROUGH
BATH THEN THE CITY OF ALL
FIGHTING CORRUPTION. AND IN MY
NINE YEARS HERE WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF AUDITS IN THAT AREA IN
MY AREA KEEPS BEING THE CORE
THERE ARE CORRUPTION A LOT OF
THE SAME THINGS WE SAW. TEN
YEARS AGO ELEVEN YEARS AGO IN
THE CITY ABOUT HAPPENING IN
NEIGHBORING CITIES BECAUSE AN
AUDIT IS NOT ENOUGH TRANSALTA
NEW SCANDAL AND TEN PEOPLE
GOING TO JAIL WITH ENOUGH
EITHER TO THE TURN OTHER PEOPLE
FROM FOLLOWING THE SAME BAD
PRACTICES OUT THERE. ARE AND SO
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THESE
ISSUES FOR AWHILE AND SAN DIEGO
AND IT BEEN APPALLED BY ABUSE
THAT WE HAVE SEEN BY EIGHT
THIRTY AND OTHERS ARE AND ALSO
BEEN UP ALL OF THE MEMBER
REPRESENTS A LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY OF COLOR. WHERE
STUDENTS ARE NOT YOU SEEN TAX
DOLLARS TO GO TO DISNEYLAND-
AND I HAVE BEEN TO THE HARD
TIME EVEN PAYING FOR BASIC
THINGS LIKE PAPER AND PENCILS-
AND SO FORTH TO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THIS IN EQUITY IT'S
PARTICULARLY HARD FOR ME ONLINE
SCHOOLS ARE HERE THEY'RE HERE
TO STAY WE KNOW THAT- BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC IN THE PANDEMIC
HAS MADE THAT CLEAR. BUT
BECAUSE THEY ARE HERE TO STAY
AND BECAUSE THEY ARE GROWING I
THINK IT'S EVER MORE IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE ACTION NOW TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT'S
EQUITABLE ACCOUNTABLE AND
TRANSPARENT AND FAIR TO ALL THE
TAXPAYERS OUT THERE WHICH IS
WHY I'M HERE SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN. SIXTEEN I HAVE MORE
COMMENTS BUT I WILL NEVER OUR
LEAD UP TO HEAR ME THEY DO A
GOOD JOB OF TALKING ABOUT THE
BILL AND ADDRESSING SOME ISSUES
I WILL BE HERE I TO ENSURE
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ME THAT WE PROTECT THE
PARENTS RIGHT TO HOME SCHOOL
THEIR CHILD OF THAT THEIR-
CHOICE AND THIS BILL STILL
PRESERVES THAT. BUT IT HAS TO
BE IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT
AFFECT OR IS THAT THE GERMAN
OTHER STUDENTS IN OUR STATE
THIS BILL THE SERVICE SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO STUDENTS ARE OF
THE HIGHEST QUALITY ANALYST
QUALITY THAT SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND FASHION BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. OUT THERE WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM THE ONSHORE FROM
THE SENEGAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND MIKE FIND FROM THINK
MATT THAT I HERE TO TESTIFY AND.
ALSO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS I
WAS THE IF WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ARE BELIEVE THE%
FOR WITNESS WE ARE SURE HERE IN
THE- YOU MAY PROCEED ON ANY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE ON
SHORE I'M A DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY AND RUN THE PUBLIC
INTEGRITY DIVISION OF THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. PROSECUTING
INDIVIDUALS WHO STEAL PUBLIC
FUNDS OUR GOAL IS TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CURRENT
GAPS IN THE SYSTEM THAT LED TO
A CASE OF MASSIVE FRAUD TO DATE
WE HAVE RECOVERED OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
EDUCATION DOLLARS. WE WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR OUR OFFICE
SUPPORTS LEGALLY RUN CHARTER
SCHOOLS THEY CAN BE A GREAT
OPTION FOR PARENTS AND STUDENTS
HOWEVER SEEING THE CONTINUED
THREAT TO EDUCATION DOLLARS
BEING DIVERTED FROM KIDS WE
PRESENTED OUR FINDINGS TO THE
CD AND ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WE HIGHLIGHTED.
GLARING PROBLEMS IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THICK MAT SPECIFICALLY
BASED ON OUR OBSERVATIONS IN
THE MASSIVE FRAUD THERE ARE
LARGE GAPS IN THE STATE'S
OVERSIGHT OUR PROSECUTION IS
ONGOING AND FOR THAT REASON WE
CANNOT SPEAK TO MANY OF THE
ASPECTS OF THE CASE
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO STAY IN
OUR LANE OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
SIMPLY POINTING OUT WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT IS VULNERABLE TO
FRAUD THE STATE DOES NOT%
MONITOR THE MONEY THAT GOES FOR
EACH STUDENT'S EDUCATION.
GOVERNMENT REGULATORS RELY ON
AUDITORS TO CONFIRM THE
ACCURACY OF ATTENDANCE AND
EXPENDITURES OF PUBLIC SCHOOL.
AT ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS THE AUDITORS
WORK IN AND HALF WILL CAPACITY
LACK THE TOOLS KNOWLEDGE AND
AUTHORITY TO FIND FRAUD. IF IT
IS A CURRENT. GOVERNMENT
REGULATORS DO NOT MONITOR
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT ATTENDANCE
AT CHARTER SCHOOLS AND ARE
CURRENTLY PAYING OUT MORE THAN
ONE EIGHTY A PER STUDENT IN
MANY CASES WITHOUT KNOWING THAT%
THEY'RE DOING SO. THE CDC HAS
NO AUTHORITY TO INVESTIGATE
POTENTIAL FRAUD AND NEEDS THE
ABILITY TO DO SO ONLY A RARE
DA'S OFFICE HAS THE RESOURCES
TO DO SO. OUR OFFICE ONLY WANTS
TO PROMOTE GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
THAT PREVENTS FRAUD. PROTECTS
TAXPAYERS AND SUPPORTS
EDUCATION OUR EXPERIENCE HAS
TAUGHT US THAT WHEN OVERSIGHT
IS LAX FRAUD WILL FLOURISH WHEN
FRAUD OCCURS IN THE AREA OF
PUBLIC FUNDING OF EDUCATION OUR
SCHOOLS LOSE OUR PARENTS LOSE.
OUR STUDENTS THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WILL NOW GO
TO MISTER FINE MIST CHARACTER
JUST LAST QUESTION OF THE
DISTRIBUTOR- THE IT GIVES QUICK
OTHERWISE WE'VE DORM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASK QUESTIONS DOUBLES
UP THE MIKE THAT'S GREAT. THANK
YOU UP. YOUR EXPERIENCE DO YOU
SENSE OF THE FRAUD GOES BEYOND
A THREE THAT'S THAT'S MY
QUESTION YES. GREAT I'LL KEEP
IT BRIEF THANK YOU. AND NOW
WE'LL HEAR FROM MICHAEL FINE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING TO YOU AYE MICHAEL
FIND CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE STATE'S FISCAL CRISIS AND
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE TEAM I
WAS FACT MAPS PLEASURE TO
SERVICE TECHNICAL ADVISORS TO
THE AUTHORS. IN CONSIDERING
SEVERAL OF THE TOPICS THAT ARE
DRESSED IN- THE BILL BEFORE YOU
AFFECT MAP HAS BEEN CALLED UPON
TO AUDIT. OR OTHERWISE
PARTICIPATE IN INVESTIGATIONS
OF SEVERAL NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SCHOOLS OVER THE YEARS
AS SUCH WE HAVE BUILDING
UNDERSTANDING AND EXPERTISE ON
A VARIETY OF THE TOPICS
ADDRESSED IN THE BILL BEFORE
YOU. I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS- FIRST
THE TOPIC OF AUDIT QUALITY- IN
DEVIATING FROM MY WRITTEN
COMMENTS JUST BRIEFLY GIVEN
THE- THE AUTHOR'S COMMENTS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REMEMBER THAT. IT IS THE
GOVERNING BODY OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL OR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
OR THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THAT IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY-
FOR CONDUCTING THEIR BUSINESS-
IN A LEGAL WAY AND- IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY- IN A WAY THAT.
COMPLIES WITH WITH OUR
REGULATIONS IN THE STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE. IT'S NOT THE
AUDITOR'S JOB TO DO THAT-
AUDITORS ARE FAIRLY LIMITED IN
THE WORK IN THE SCOPE THAT THEY
DO TO PRODUCE AN ANNUAL.
FINANCIAL AUDIT THEIR PRIMARY
PURPOSE IS TO PRODUCE THE
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS RELATED TO
THAT ENTITY WHETHER THAT'S A
SCHOOL DISTRICT OR COUNTY.
SUPERINTENDENT OR- A CHARTER
SCHOOL. SECTIONS OF A ONE TWO
EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN. TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY SIX OF
THE BILL DEAL WITH THE TOPIC-
OF AUDITS AND RECOMMEND
AMENDMENTS TO EXISTING
PROVISIONS. THAT WOULD INCREASE
AUDIT CONSISTENCY AND QUALITY
FOR ALL. OF LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. SECTIONS TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY SIX
SPECIFICALLY DEAL WITH CHANGES
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT BRING
THE AUDIT PROCESS FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN ALIGNMENT WITH. A
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. THE BILL
PROPOSED MAKES COMMONSENSE
CHANGES IT'S NOT AN OVER REACH
BY ANY MEANS- AND AGAIN AT THE
LINES- OUR EXPECTATIONS FOR ALL
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
WHETHER THEY ARE. A GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES SUCH AS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT. OR THEIR
PRIVATE. ENTITIES SUCH AS A
CHARTER SCHOOL. THERE ARE THREE
BASIC TOPICS ADDRESSED IN THE
SECTIONS ON AUDIT FIRST AS
AUDITOR TRAINING- TO. SPECIFIC
TO AUDITORS TO CONDUCT AUDITS
OF- LGAS- WE ADDRESS THIS IN
THE CONTEXT OF EXISTING CPA
LICENSURE- IN CONTINUING AT
REQUIREMENTS WE DON'T GO
OUTSIDE THAT EXISTING
STRUCTURE- AUDIT FIRM PEER
REVIEW LIKEWISE USING THE
EXISTING STRUCTURE THAT'S IN
PLACE. SET BY THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
WE WORK WITHIN THEIR AUTHORIZED
MR FINE SURE DO TIME THANK YOU.
I THINK THAT WAS ASKED ALSO A
TODAY BY COMMITTEE STAFF TO
SPEAK TO- FUNDS THAT ARE GIVEN
BY CHARTER SCHOOLS TO PARENTS.
OF FROM THE FROM THEIR
ALLOCATION THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND WHAT THOSE
ARE USED FOR- LOOKED AT A
VARIETY OF THOSE IN ONE CHARTER
SCHOOLS CASE ONE NETWORKS CASE
THEY HAVE SEVEN THOUSAND
VENDORS THAT THE PARENTS CAN
PICK FROM TO DELIVER SERVICE
SUCH AS INDIVIDUAL MUSIC
LESSONS. HORSEBACK RIDING
CROSSFIT MEMBERSHIP GOLF RESORT
SERVICES ANIMAL CARE MARTIAL
ARTS GYMNASTICS AS AN EXAMPLE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION WILL NOW GO
TO- OPPOSITION WITNESSES. AND
WE HAVE- ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
WE HAVE- CAST JUNE FROM- THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN CAPE FOR BOARD
PRESENT SANTA BARBARA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. GOOD MORNING I
MEAN THE CUSTOMER WHO AND THEN
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION HERE TO REPRESENT
THE CHARTER SCHOOL COMMUNITY
STRENUOUS OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. CCSA HAS A
VERY STRONG RECORD AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE BLEW THE
WHISTLE ON THE CRIMINALS OF THE
A. THREE SCHEME IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND CALLED ON THE CD
IS SUPERINTENDENT TO
INVESTIGATE AND TAKE
APPROPRIATE AND IMMEDIATE
ACTION. THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN NORRIS SAID
ABOUT PARITY. THE BILL LACKEY
LEAD ACTUALLY DISCRIMINATES
AGAINST CHARTER STUDENTS BY
SLASHING NON CLASSROOM BASED
FUNDING BY 30% BUT NOT FOR
DISTRICTS WITH INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAMS. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN ALSO FALLS FAR SHORT OF
HOLDING AUTHORIZERS ACCOUNTABLE
AS YOU JUST HEARD MISTER FIND
YOU SPEAK TO THAT. IN FACT IT
ACTUALLY DOUBLES DOWN ON THE
FIRST PERSON SENTENCED OF
INCREASED OVERSIGHT FEES WHICH
WE KNOW THAT MOTIVATED
UNSCRUPULOUS AUTHORIZERS IN THE
PAST. MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL ELIMINATES STUDENT
CENTERED FLEXIBLE SCHEDULES IN
THE DISCRETION NECESSARY FOR
TEACHERS IMPAIR PROFESSIONALS
TO MEET STUDENT NEEDS. FURTHER
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN UNRAVELS
THAT HISTORIC COMPROMISE
SHEPHERDED BY GOVERNOR NEWSOM
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. I
RELIVE THE GETTING SETTLED
ISSUES RELATED TO SITE BASED
SCHOOLS DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE REGULATIONS FOR
IMPLEMENTING THESE NEW LAWS.
HAVE NOT EVEN YET BEEN
INITIATED. HOW CAN WE FULLY
ENGAGE A WIN RECENT LEGISLATIVE
AGREEMENTS ARE BEING DISMISSED
AND PUNITIVE APPROACHES AGAINST
AN ENTIRE SECTOR ARE BEING
INVEST IN THIS BILL. THIS BILL
TARGETS FAMILIES WHO'VE BEEN
FAILED BY SITE BASED SETTINGS
THESE CHARTERS DO SERVE A
HIGHLY MOBILE STUDENT
POPULATION UP TO SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. WE'RE STILL TALKING
ABOUT A FRACTION OF THE WHOLE
STUDENT BODY OF CALIFORNIA LESS
THAN THREE PERCENT. THE FOR THE
PREGNANT OR THE WORKING TEAM OR
THE MIGRANT STUDENT WHO FOLLOWS
THE CROPS WITH THE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES WHO HAVE
FLOCKED TO PERSONALIZE LEARNING
PROGRAMS IN THE PANDEMIC. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN WILL STRAIN
AND EVEN FOR CLOTHES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE STUDENTS
TO RECEIVE THE EDUCATION THEY
DESERVE. THESE ARE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS THIS IS NOT
EQUITY AND THIS IS NOT
CALIFORNIA WE RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR YOU KNOW VOTE AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU A TWO HOUR WAIT NEXT
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE I'M KATE FORD
AND I'M CURRENTLY THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SANTA BARBARA UNIFIED
SCHOOL BOARD AFTER FORTY THREE
YEARS IN EDUCATION I BELIEVE
THAT IS THE PRINCIPLE OF PUBLIC
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OVERSEEING
ELEVEN CHARGE BOTH AND NOW OF
THE AUTHORIZER IN MY ROLE ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD. MY
PERSPECTIVE MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO
YOU WITH RESPECT TO THE OVER
REACH EXHIBITED IN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN MY EXPERIENCE BOTH IN
LOS ANGELES AND HERE IN SANTA
BARBARA IS THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEMS IN PLACE NO NOT PERFECT
OUR COMPREHENSIVE TIME
INTENSIVE AND HELPFUL TO BOTH
THE CHARGERS OF THE AUTHORIZER.
I SUPPORT REGULATIONS ARE
PROCESSES THAT PREVENT
SITUATIONS LIKE THE
REPREHENSIBLE EIGHT THREE FRAUD
IN SAN DIEGO BUT MY EXPERIENCE
WITH AND SEE BE CHARGED WITH
THAT THEY FELL OF SPECIFIC
NEEDS HAVE VERY STRONG PARENTS
AND TEACHERS SUPPORT ARE WELL
MANAGED AND HAVE GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR AUDITORS
AND AUTHORIZE THE DISTRICT.
EVEN BIGGER PICTURE IS THAT AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN MAKES IT
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO OPERATE
CHARTERS PUBLIC SCHOOL AND THIS
KIND OF BROAD STROKE IS SIMPLY
DESTRUCTIVE IT'S NOTABLE THAT
THE SMALL GROUP OF SUPPORTERS
OF THIS BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. DOESN'T INCLUDE
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS NOT DOES
IT INCLUDE THE THOUSANDS OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE STATE SEND
THEIR CHILDREN TO CHARTERS I
THINK THAT'S QUITE TELLING. BY
LAW NO CHILD SHOULD BE FORCED.
TO ATTEND A CHARTER SCHOOL. AB
THIRD SIX. IS THE BEST KEPT
SECRET CHARTERS. WITH
ADDITIONAL COSTS REDUCE. AND
NEWER. THAT WOULD MAKE THE VERY
FABRIC OF. I NEED THE VISION
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE R. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NOT MIRED
IN FRAUD AND SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED AS SUCH. INSTEAD WHY
NOT WORK TOGETHER TO STRENGTHEN
THE SUPPORT AND OVERSIGHT FOR
AUTHORIZES IN CHARTERS ALIKE.
OF ETHNIC PONDERED THE FIFTY
THOUSAND CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ARE WELL
SERVED THAT MUST BE THE CALL AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN DOES NOT DO
THAT. AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU VOTE NO ON AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- WE WILL NOW
GO TO- COMMITTEE MEMBER
QUESTIONS. I HAVE I HAVE FROM.
I HOPE THAT YOU OWN THOSE THREE
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF TIME AS I
HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS I DO
WANT TO STATE FOR THE RECORD
THAT I HAVE- SPENT QUITE A BIT
OF TIME IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
AND SING THIS BILL TALKING TO
BOTH SIDES I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMENTS TRYING TO
CLARIFY SOME OF THE STATEMENTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD. I DO HAVE
THIS IS A MAJOR BILL WITH MANY
MANY COMPONENTS AS WE'VE ALL
SEEN I WOULD SAY THAT TO US
JUST FROM SEEING LEGISLATION
NOW THIS GOING INTO MY SEVENTH
YEAR I WOULD OF LIKE TO SEE
THIS PUT IT INTO SEVERAL BILLS
AS IT'S REALLY ADDRESSING MANY
MANY ISSUES THAT BEING SAID IF
SOMEONE BILL- BUT I WILL START
WITH I'VE HEARD THAT THERE WAS
VERY LITTLE. ON INTER ACTION
BETWEEN THE OPPOSITION AND THE
AUTHOR AND I HAVE SEEN A RECORD
OF MANY MANY MEETINGS THAT HAVE
TAKEN PLACE SINCE JANUARY SO
AGAIN I'M TRYING TO STATE FOR
THE RECORD A SOME OF THE MAJOR
THINGS I'VE HEARD AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S TWO SIDES TO AN ISSUE
AND SOMETIMES WE GET A ONE
PERSPECTIVE AND YET THERE IS
ANOTHER AND SOMETIMES THE TRUTH
LIES IN THE MIDDLE- SO I HAVE
HEARD THAT THERE WERE SEVERAL
MEETINGS THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE
SINCE JANUARY RELATED TO THIS.
SOME OF MY MAJOR QUESTION THREE
WILL REVOLVE AROUND THE 30% AND
SO I'M GOING TO ADDRESS THIS TO
EITHER- EITHER AUTHOR OR EVEN
ONE OF OUR WITNESSES HERE THAT
THIS 30% WILL IN FACT A PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS OUT OF BUSINESS
AND AGAIN RELATED THE ADA SO I
WOULD JUST PUT THAT OUT THERE
IF SOMEBODY CAN EXPLAIN.
EXACTLY WHAT IS IMPLIED BY.
THAT SO ON ADA THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION AND THE 30% REDUCTION
I'D SO I'LL BE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS- FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND I WILL BE ASKING SOME OF
OUR WITNESSES TO DO BACK UP ON
ON SOME OF **** AND OUR OTHER
AUTHORS CHINA- SO WE HAVE AT
LEAST FIVE OTHER STATES THAT
ARE REDUCE FUNDING FOR VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS AND THEY HAVE TO SHUT
DOWN ANY OF THE SCHOOLS. IN
THOSE STATES AS WELL AS WE
HEARD FROM OUR LEAD AUTHOR OR
YOU'RE- THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
SAME CLASS OF BRICK AND MORTAR
OR WITH ADDITIONAL STAFF LIKE
CUSTODIANS AND SO FORTH. AND SO.
NOT NOT CARE THAT THEY NEED
THAT ADDITIONAL- THAT THAT
EXTRA 30% THERE. SO THEY
TYPICALLY A SCHOOL WOULD BE
FUNDED ON EIGHTY EIGHT PER
STUDENT AND THAT PER STUDENT IN
A PUBLIC SCHOOL WOULD BE A 100%
AS THEY ATTENDED IN CLASSROOM
SCHOOL. THAT NOT ONLY PAYS FOR
OF COURSE YOUR CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS YOUR ADMINISTRATION
YOUR CUSTODIAN SHORE UP ALL
PARA PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE ON
THE STAFF. IF THE STUDENT IS
NOW ATTENDING A NON. IN PERSON
CLASSROOM WITH OUT A PHYSICAL
SPACE. THEN THE POINT OF THIS-
ALTER THE ALTERATION IN THIS
BILL WOULD TO SAY THEN THEY
SHOULD NOT BE GETTING A 100% OF
ADD A. D. A. AS THERE IS NOT A
BRICK AND MORTAR. LOCATION THAT
THEY NEED TO USE THAT
ADDITIONAL 30% FOR IS THAT
PRETTY MUCH THAT THAT SUMMER
ACT. ALL RIGHT SO THEN THE NEXT
QUESTION I AM VOTERS IF I COULD
ADD ONE MORE THING SEVENTY
SCHOOLS ARE SPENDING THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT
THEY'RE GIVING TO PARENTS AT
THAT THE THREATENS TO SPEND
HOWEVER THEY WANT- A YEAR SEEN
THINGS LIKE- FOR PAYING FOR.
EQUESTRIAN CLASSES THEY'RE
PLAYING FOR TRIPS TO THE LEVEL
AND WE HAD A FAMILY GO TO
CHICAGO I THINK IT SPEAKS TO
THE FACT THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE SAME OVERHEAD AND DID NOT
HAVE THE SAME MONEY SO THEY
COULD AFFORD TO DO SOMETHING-
THAT WE CAN DO IN TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS ARE BRICK AND MORTAR
SCHOOLS. I THINK MY FRIENDS IN
MY DISTRICT WOULD GLADLY TAKE
THE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO PAY FOR BASIC THINGS THAT
THEIR STUDENTS. NEEDS BUT
THAT'S NOT OFFERED TO THEM.
MMHM THANK YOU THEN THE NEXT
AREA GARCIA. IT JUST. TWO
POINTS OF THE UP RIGHT NOW THAT
FOR ME IS ACTUALLY BUILT IN THE
CURRENT LAW JUST AS A CURRENT
PRACTICE FOR THE MOST PART. THE
70% THRESHOLD. AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE INSIDE THE ANALYSIS HERE
IT LAYS OUT. THE AG BASICALLY A
PROGRESSIVE FUNDING MODEL OFFER
HOW SCHOOLS GET MONEY LET ME
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE ALL STAR AT
THE BOTTOM- PUPILS ENGAGING
CLASSROOM BASED INSTRUCTION
BETWEEN ZERO AND 19% OF THEIR-
ATTENDANCE GENERATES SEVENTY
PERCENT. FOR STATE
APPORTIONMENT K. AND NOW GOES
ALL THE WAY UP. TO BILLS AGAIN
I'M GONNA JUMP AHEAD BUT HE WAS
ENGAGING CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTION FOR AT LEAST 80% OF
THEIR TENANTS GENERATE ONE
HUNDRED. PERCENT OF ATTENDANCE
FOR STATE APPORTIONMENT SO
THERE'S A SCHEDULE FOR OFTEN
THE STUDENTS IN A CLASSROOM AND
THAT ALIGNS WITH- WITH WITH
WHETHER OR NOT THEIR- BRICK AND
MORTAR WHETHER NOT THE SCHOOL
THE STUDENTS EVEN IN THE
CLASSROOMS OF STUDENTS NEVER
GOES TO SCHOOL- THERE'S- THAT
CANNOT THE NEED FOR THE
FACILITY AND THAT'S IF YOU LOOK
AT THE- ANALYSIS THAT'S- THAT'S
HOW THE- THAT'S WHAT GUIDES.
THE FUNDING MODEL. AND THERE
ARE SOME STUDENTS WHO ARE
DOING. OFFICE WORKING WITH THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AND THEY DO HAVE
AN HYBRID WHERE THEY DO SO TO A
BRICK AND MORTAR THAT
ACCOMMODATED IN THE SCHEDULE
THAT I SOMETIMES YES. ALL RIGHT
SO THEN THE NEXT QUESTION THAT
I'VE HEARD QUITE A BIT ABOUT
AND I AM. VERY INTERESTED TO
UNDERSTAND IS. THE ACTUAL CALL
A MULTI YEAR CALL CALENDAR-
AND- AGAIN I AM A COMPLETE
BELIEVER THAT PARENTS. AND EVEN
ADULTS WELL YOUNG ADULTS WHO
ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL HAVE. MANY
MANY NEEDS AND AS. WAS
MENTIONED HI ONE OF THIS. COULD
MY GROW WORKER COULD BE. A TEAM.
COULD BE I JUST THEIR CHOICE TO
NOT BE IN A TRADITIONAL SCHOOL
BUT WHAT ABOUT THIS ISSUE
RELATED TO THE MULTI CALENDAR.
FUNDING AND THE ADA THAT
FOLLOWS WITH THAT STUDENT- IT'S
NOT VERY CLEAR ON EXACTLY WHAT
THAT MEANS SO A STUDENT DEBT
CAN STILL ENROLL WHENEVER THEY
WANT YEAR ROUND- AND- LEFT THE
CHURCH SAID- THEY'RE STILL
FLEXIBILITY AND HOW THE
SCHEDULES ARE SETUP- HERE
ALONGTHE WAY AND HE'S TAKING
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
THAT. CLEAR FOR INDIVIDUALS.
SCHOOL FOR THE CONTROL THEIR
OWN SCHEDULE AND SO I WHAT I
SEE AS- MISTER MIKE FLYING TO
ELABORATE ON THAT. I THINK. A
COUPLE THOUGHTS ON MULTI TRACK
NUMBER ONE THE ISSUE THAT'S
TRYING TO BE ADDRESSED AS WERE
STUDENTS ARE. ARE ALLOWED TO
JUMP FROM TRACK TO TRACK TO
ULTIMATELY- GENERATE MORE THAN
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PER YEAR. AT
THE STATE'S EXPENSE- AS- THE CO
AUTHORS OF SPOKEN TO- CALENDAR
SET BY THE LOCAL SCHOOL- SCHOOL
DISTRICT- OR CHARTER SCHOOL IN
THIS CASE- AND IN THIS
PROVISION IS APPLICABLE TO
BOTH- THEY CAN- THE STATE LAW.
SETS A MINIMUM NUMBER DAY'S
INSTRUCTION NOT A MAXIMUM. AND
SO IF A STUDENT WERE TO ENROLL
QUOTE UNQUOTE LATE IN THE YEAR.
THE CHARTER SCHOOL CAN CONTINUE
TO SERVE THEM WE SERVE KIDS
DURING THE SUMMER IN OTHER-
ENVIRONMENTS- WHETHER WE CALL
THAT SUMMER SCHOOL OR EXTENDED
YEAR WHAT HAVE YOU- BUT THERE
IS A- A MAXIMUM NUMBER OF DAYS
IN CURRENT LAW THAT THE STATE.
PAYS FOR THE S. MODEL LIMIT
LIMITING FACTOR ON- THE NUMBER
OF DAYS THOUGH THAT A STUDENT
CAN BE SERVED- SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE SOME CONSIDERATIONS
OF AN EXAMPLE OF. WE ARE AT
WORST PRACTICE WHERE THERE IS
THIS- SCENARIO WHERE ADA COULD
BE COLLECTED. MORE THAN ONCE A
YEAR FOR STUDENT HOW HOW HAS
THAT BEEN OCCURRING SO IN A
MULTI TRACK YEAR ROUND JUST
ASSUME THERE'S FOUR TRACKS EACH
OF THEM STARTED DIFFERENT
POINTS. OF CURRENT LAW DOES
REQUIRE THAT- THEY MUST ALL
HAVE STARTED BY A CERTAIN DATE
OR ALL OF REACH SO MANY DAYS BY
A CERTAIN DATE IN THE YEAR SO
YOU WOULDN'T TYPICALLY BE
STARTING A TRACK IN JANUARY AS
AN EXAMPLE- SO MULTIPLE TRACKS
YOU COULD START JULY ONE. IN
THE CASE OF A THREE TO GIVE YOU
A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE- OF THE
ENROLLED STUDENTS ON TRACK ONE
ON JULY ONE WHERE THEY WERE
ATTENDING. A LITTLE LEAGUE.
GAMES AND PRACTICES S. EIGHTY
EIGHT BASICALLY- AND THEN THE
STUDENT MOVED LATER IN THE YEAR
TO ANOTHER TRACK. TO MAXIMIZE
OR THEY WENT BACK TO THEIR HOME
SCHOOL. A DISTRICT AND THEY
WERE SERVED FOR THE REGULAR
SCHOOL YEAR BY THAT HOME SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALTERNATELY THE STATE
PAID MORE THAN ONE ABA FOR THAT
STUDENT. CAN I ALSO ASK THE DA
TO ELABORATE ON ON THE SIX
SAMPLES. I'M SORRY CAN WE ALSO
AT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO
ELABORATE THANK YOU. RIGHT
ENGINE FOR MISTER THEM ALMOST
FINDS UP THERE CAN YOU JUST
ALSO SPEAK TO HELP THE
INTRODUCTION CAL PADS WE
ADDRESS SOME OF THIS ISSUE SURE
THE PROVISIONS IN THE BILL ARE
THAT AS THE STATE LOOKS TO FOR
LACK OF BETTER TERM- CAL PADS
TWO POINT OH. A CAB AS THE
STATE'S LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM HERE WHERE AFFECT MATT
IS THE STATE'S CONTRACTOR
AWKWARD RELATIONSHIP SINCE WERE
ALO STATE. A COMPONENT OF THE
STATE BUT- WE'RE THE STATE'S
CONTRACTOR TO THE CD EITHER
OPERATES THAT SYSTEM AND SO WE
KNOW IT VERY VERY WELL- THE
BILL PROVIDES IT AS THEY LOOK
TO- FUTURE- CAL PATCHWORK THAT
THEY WOULD ALIGN EIGHTY A WITH
CAL PADS. SO THE ACTUALLY SEE
AT THE STATE LEVEL AT A PER
STUDENT SO CAP HAD SAYS REPORT
ON AN INDIVIDUAL STUDENT BASIS
BUT NOT ADA FOR APPORTIONMENT
PURPOSES. THAT'S DONE ON AN
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT BASES OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT CHARTER SCHOOL
LEVEL BUT DOES NOT FLOAT UP TO
THE STATE WHEN IT FLOATS UP TO
THE STATE IS IT'S JUST A TOTAL
YOU LOSE VISIBILITY. OF THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT AND SO TO
SEE ONE OF STUDENTS ENROLLED
AND NOT YOU CAN SEE THAT IN CAL
PADS BUT NOT KNOW THEIR
ATTENDANCE ACCEPTED A VERY HIGH
LEVEL INCLUDING. FOR REPORTING
ON CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. SO IN
ESSENCE I WHAT YOU'RE IS THAT
BE IF A DISTRICT AND THAT. FOR
SAY ABOUT SCORING THAT'S FOR
ADA WOULD BE CAUGHT YES HE'S AT
THE UP THE PROVISION OF THE
BILL WOULD CATCH THAT. THE CAL
PASSED FOR YOU WOULD YOU WOULD
HAVE VISIBILITY AT THE STATE
LEVEL OF THAT ACTIVITY YES SIR.
AND I BELIEVE HE ONE OF THE SAN
DIEGO DA YES TWO EIGHT. AND
AGAIN I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THEY ARE HERE. TO REALLY
SPEAK TO. THEIR EXPERIENCED AND
WHAT THEY CAN SURE IS LIMITED.
WITH A THREE AND SOME OTHER
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT GONNA GO.
TOO FAR INTO SOME OF THE TECH
TO ALLMAN CIVILE BECAUSE
THAT'S- NOT WHAT THEY CAME UP
FOR TODAY. CORRECT SO TO MAKE
SURE THEM ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS ASKED THOUGH. THE
QUESTION THE BIGGEST EXAMPLES.
OF HOW OLD THE DOUBLE DIPPING
WITH ADA HAS OCCURRED. OKAY AND
SO NOT ADDRESSING THE POLICY OF
WHETHER MULTI TRACK IS GOOD OR
BAD BUT WHAT WE FOUND IN THE
CASE WAS SPECIFICALLY. LIKE MR
FIND EXPLAINED YOU WOULD HAVE A
STUDENT FOR INSTANCE. YOU KNOW
STEVE A. THAT. IS ENROLLED IN A
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL FOR THE
SCHOOL YEAR THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
ONE EIGHTY A IN A TRADITIONAL
BRICK AND MORTAR SCHOOL OR A
CHARTER SCHOOL. IF THEY WANT TO
GO FULL TIME FOR THE ENTIRE
YEAR FOR INSTANCE TAKE SUMMER
SCHOOL. YOUR ONE EIGHTY A WOULD
HAVE TO BE STRETCH FOR THE
ENTIRE YEAR. IF YOU SWITCHED
FROM ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
ANOTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT. OR IF
YOU SWITCH FROM ONE CHARTER
SCHOOL TO ANOTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND THE STATE
CURRENTLY HAS NO ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY FOLLOW YOUR SWITCH.
YOU CAN END UP RECEIVING YOUR
ONE EIGHTY A PLUS AN ADDITIONAL
PERCENTAGE OF ADA FOR THE
SUMMER SCHOOL OR WHATEVER PART
OF THE SCHOOL THAT YOU WENT TO.
SO WHAT WE FOUND IN OUR CASE.
IS THAT IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE
MAXIMIZE PROFITS. YOU WOULD
SWITCH. FROM ONE SCHOOL OR
SHE'S ME ONE TRACK TO ANOTHER
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT ALL.
CHARTER SCHOOLS BY ANY STRETCH
OR DOING THAT OR THAT ANY MULTI
TRACK FOLKS ARE DOING IT.
THAT'S WHAT WE FOUND IN THAT
CASE. THAT MAKES SENSE. YOUR
CASE BEING ABOUT THE THREE.
CORRECT SO YEAH. CAN YOU
ELABORATE ON HOW MANY OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS YOU HAVE ONGOING
RIGHT NOW BESIDES A THREE NO.
YOU CAN'T LIBRARY ARE THERE ARE
OTHER INVESTIGATION I CAN'T
ELABORATE. SO I'LL JUST FINISH
UP MY QUESTION AS- SO AS
PARENTS CHOOSE THEIR EDUCATION
FOR THEIR OWN CHILDREN WHETHER
IT'S PUBLIC OR PRIVATE OR
CHARTER ONLINE OR IN PERSON OR-
THEY THEY ARE OLDER KIDS JUST
AS YOU WOULD WITH ANY TYPE OF
APPLICATION BUT THE WHOLE ADA
PART IS NOT REALLY IN THEIR
PURVIEW THEY'RE NOT THE ONES
THAT. ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TRACKING ATTENDANCE FOR EVEN
LETTING A DISTRICT KNOW IF
THEY'RE GOING TO MOVE SOMEWHERE
ELSE THAT'S UP TO THE DISTRICT
TO FOLLOW THAT. EIGHTY EIGHT IF
YOU WANT TO SAY IT THAT WAY SO
I'M JUST MAKING A STATEMENT
THAT IN NO WAY DO I BELIEVE
THAT PARENTS ARE KNOWINGLY. AT
TRYING TO DOUBLE DIP IF YOU
WANT TO SAY AND ALSO MAKE THE
COMMENT THAT YES THERE'S BAD
APPLES AND IN- WHETHER IF WE
WANT TO SAY A THREE IF WE WANT
TO SAY PUBLIC EDUCATION UNDER
ALL OUR INSTITUTIONS AND THAT
THIS BILL- AS I'M UNDERSTANDING
THAT MORE IS TO TRY TO CREATE
THE PARITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
SO THAT ALL OF OUR SCHOOL
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS AGAIN
WHETHER IT'S ONLINE CHARTER
WHETHER IT'S IN AND TRADITIONAL
IN CLASS HAS PARITY AND EQUITY-
SO I GUESS I REALLY DIDN'T ASK
YOU A QUESTION I JUST MADE A
PERFECT AND MEDICAL STOP THERE
THANK YOU THAT I WILL POINT OUT
WHEN THEY PASSED THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY EARLIER HE DID SAY
THAT THERE WERE OTHER CASES-
CORRECT NOT THAT HE WAS DOING
THE INVESTIGATION BUT HE HE
BELIEVED THAT THERE WAS OTHER
INSTANCES AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
AT WE HAVE- THE AP CARE COOLEY
FAT INSPIRE- NAME THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF COVERAGE AND THAT IN
THE NEWSPAPER SKAVA TRI VALLEY
BACCHANALIA. INSULARITY ARE ARE
SOME. OF THE ADDITIONAL- A
SCHOOL FOR THAT. THAT WERE HIM
FOR A- YES IS AB THERE'S MANY
MORE THAN THAT ADMIT DURING MY
TENURE IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
WE PAY ATTENTION TO THESE
SITUATIONS WE PAY ATTENTION TO
THE ARTICLES AND COMPARE
THERE'S BEEN MANY MORE THAN
THAT- THAT ARE FURTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MR MCCARTY.
YEAH THANK YOU I JUST I'M JUST
BLOWN AWAY BY THIS EXAMPLE IN
SAN DIEGO AND GRANTED THE
OPPONENTS THIS WILL SAY WELL
THAT'S JUST ONE BAD APPLE NOT
ALL OF US AND I'LL GET TO IN A
SECOND BUT HOW DID THAT HOW DID
THEY GET THE INFORMATION BOOTH
THIS THIS WHOLE WHERE WHERE
THE- WHERE THE- REPRESENTATIVE.
AREA SO THEY USED SOME TYPE OF
LITTLE LEAGUE REGISTRATION
INFORMATION SO WHAT CAN YOU
WALK ME THROUGH HOW IT ALL
TRANSPIRED OF SOME OF IT I CAN
SO THE INITIAL CONTACT THAT WE
RECEIVED WAS FROM A LITTLE
LEAGUE THAT WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS GRANT
FUNDING THAT WAS GOING TO COME
TO THEM A THREE ORGANIZATION IT
HIRED INDIVIDUALS TO RECRUIT
STUDENTS TO COME IN FOR THE
SUMMER TIME SO WHAT THESE
RECRUITERS DID AND WE'RE PAID
TO DO SO WAS WENT AND SIGNED
UP- LITTLE LEAGUE SPORTS
PROGRAMS ALL SORTS OF- SUMMER
PROGRAMS. AND ENROLL THEM
OFENTIMES WITHOUT THE
INDIVIDUAL'S KNOWLEDGE INTO A
CHARTER SCHOOL THE RECRUITER
WOULD SEAT RECEIVE AN AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOR DOING SO AND THEN THE
LITTLE LEAGUE FOR INSTANCE
MIGHT RECEIVE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER STUDENT OR THE
RECRUITER MIGHT GET TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER STUDENT AND THEN
THE BAD ACTOR CHARTER SCHOOL
WOULD RECEIVE ANYWHERE BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT SO.
OBVIOUSLY HAD WE HAD TWO
THOUSAND FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
GOING INTO IT A LITTLE LEAGUE
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES I DON'T
THINK ANYONE WOULD BEEN AS OF
SEPT BY BUT INSTEAD IT WAS
GOING TO THE PROVIDERS. YEAH
THAT JUST BLOWS MY MIND AND
THANK YOU FOR ARTICULATING THAT
AND- YES JUST LIKE THE OLD
EXAMPLES OF PEOPLE GO ON THE
PHONE BOOK AND- REGISTERING
VOTERS AND EARNED GETTING YOUR
DOWNEY THAT'S JUST FLAT OUT.
OUT FRONT IDEA BUT BUT REAL
QUICK JUST UNIQUE COMIC I WANT
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DA'S
OFFICE TO SAVE THIS IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT SPECIFIC
CASE THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
UNIVERSALISM LONG BEACH MY
TOWN. AND THEY FOUND A SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT ON THE EASTERN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY I BELIEVE IN A
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHTY A AND THEN
GREW UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND.
RIGHT AND THIS GUY AT THE
BLEEDING ONE CAME FROM
AUSTRALIA. AND CAME OVER HERE
AND SET UP THIS OPERATION
INSTALLED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
PLUS INSIDE TWO YEARS SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. SO THE- A- BIG
OPERATE IN A BIG BIG DEAL AND
NO ONE CAUGHT IT. BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT RIGHT
A SMALL DISTRICT WITH HUNDRED.
FIFTY STUDENTS GIVE OR TAKE.
DIDN'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT THE ODDEST
DIDN'T CATCH IT THE ACCOUNT AND
CATCHING. THE CAL PAD SYSTEM
DIDN'T CATCH IT SO THAT'S WHAT
WE SEEK TO RECTIFY HERE TODAY.
MR MCCARTY. YEAH I THINK THAT
LEADS ME TO THE BIGGER POINT.
YOU KNOW I I'M FRUSTRATED HERE
THE OPPOSITION. SAYING WE DON'T
LIKE THESE BAD ACTORS THEY MAKE
IT BAD ON US. AND THEN WE'LL
TURN THEM INTO BUT THEN WE COME
WITH REASONABLE OVERSIGHT-
THAT'S GOING TO SET US OUT OF
BUSINESS AND JUST LIKE. I WEEK
WE HEAR THIS OVER AND OVER AND
THEN WE KEEP HEARING EXAMPLES
OVER AND OVER ITSELF. THAT'S
WHAT YOU GET FROM NOT HAVING
PROPER OVERSIGHT ITSELF. HI I
THINK YOUR ARGUMENT IS A VERY
VERY- HOLLOW. AND I DID WANT TO
ALLOW THE CHAIR. OR THE CHAIR
THE AUTHOR AND GET THREE
AUTHORS HERE. TO TO TALK ABOUT
ONE AT THAT YEAH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS. AND I RECEIVED SOME
I RECEIVED SOME EMAILS FROM
PUBLIC PEOPLE HERE I KNOW
LOCALLY A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
AS YOU KNOW THEY- STATE THEY
EMAIL YOU AND TELL YOU ABOUT
THE BILL AND THEN YOUR YOU MAY
SUPPORTER AUTHOR AND YOU I
ALWAYS THINK WELL. THAT MY BILL
DID THAT I WOULDN'T SUPPORT IT
RIGHT. BECAUSE OF THE IN ALL
THESE PIECES IN THERE JUST
AREN'T FACTUAL- BUT DON'T LET
THE TRUTH GET IN THE WAY OF A
GOOD STORY THAT'S WHAT WE HEAR
TOO OFTEN IN THIS BUSINESS. SO
IF YOU- MISTER O'DONNELL CAN
TALK ABOUT THAT THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT FIRST FOR SMALLER
DISTRICTS- AND THE
GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE- AND HOW
THAT WE THIS WON'T BE A SHUT
DOWN FOR SOME FROM THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE. WHO ARE TALKING TO US
TODAY I'M SORRY COULD YOU
CLARIFY YOUR QUESTION A LITTLE
YES HE WAS IN THERE IT IS
AMENDMENTS THAT THE IS NOT PART
OF A SCHOOLS ARE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED BIRTH A SMALL
DISTRICTS- A GRANDFATHERING
PIECE AS FAR AS OUR EIGHTY
EIGHT CORRECT- YES. YES THEY
DID MAKE. YES NINE ACRE WE HAVE
THE- THE COMMITTEE OUT. WHAT
THAT PIECE IS TO HAVE. I CAN
SPEAK TO IT IS IF YOU CAN SHOW
ME WHERE ANALYSIS SECOND
SPEAKERS. FROM THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ON PAID. I JUST THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT THAT I'M I KNOW WE
DON'T KNOW ALL THESE MINIMUM
LIMIT AND ONE OF THEM YEAH AS
CHAIR I'M LIMITED ON WHAT I CAN
I KNOW WEIGH IN ON SO I CAN
SPEAK TO THEM NOW I THINK IT
WOULD HELP US OF THE B. IT'S ON
PAGE TWENTY SEVEN A SMART PICK
TWENTY TWO AND ITS AMENDMENT
NUMBER SEVEN THE TOP OF THE
PAGE YEP ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
SELFIE TO OUTLINE. THE DEBT HOW
WE BEFORE WE WERE ABLE TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THE MAIN
CONCERNS WE HEAR ABOUT THIS AND.
THAT THE GRANDFATHERING ISSUES.
CAN. BUT MAKING THE PAGE TWENTY
TWO MM NUMBER. SEVEN TWENTY TWO
BUT I AND I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
QUITE FRANKLY- IF IT'S ALRIGHT
IT BECAUSE THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
WHAT IT DOES IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
GET GRANDFATHERS AND NON
CLUSTER BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED BY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OUTSIDE THE ADA
REQUIREMENTS EMBEDDED IN THIS
BILL- SO WHAT WE HAVE IN THIS
BILL IS- IF YOU WANT AUTHORIZES
CHARTER. YOU'VE GOT TO BE THIS
BIG FOR THIS MANY STUDENTS YOU
CAN AUTHORIZE THAT BIG FOR THAT
MANY STUDENTS TO AUTHORIZE AND
WHY THAT WAS PUT IN HERE WAS
AAIN WAS THE C. E. SAN DIEGO
COUNTY SITUATION AND OTHERS
WHERE YOU HAVE A VERY VERY
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT- THAT
MAYBE HAVE A HUNDRED HUNDRED
FIFTY STUDENTS- GO AHEAD
AUTHORIZING TO A CHARTER SCHOOL
TO HAVE TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS. AND
AGAIN THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS JONES DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT- THE GOOD
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES THE
AUDITOR SAID WHERE THEY NEED TO
TAKE PLACE SO WHAT WE DID ABOUT
IT IN THIS BILL WAS CREATED A
THRESHOLD. OF PROGRESSIVE- IT'S
AND FORGOT NUMBER OF STUDENTS.
A STUDENT A DISTRICT MUST HAVE.
TO APPROVE A CERTAIN SIZE
CHARTER. SO IF YOU'RE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU COULD
PROBABLY. AUTHOR IS A SMALL
NUMBER OF CHARTER SCHOOL
STUDENTS EVEN IF YOU'RE LARGER
SCHOOL DISTRICT YOU COULD
AUTHORIZE A LARGER NUMBER. OF
CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENTS- BUT
AGAIN THAT THAT THAT THAT
THRESHOLD THAT PROGRESSIVE
NUMBER. IS BUILT IN THERE TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE DISTRICTS
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT THAT THUS FAR HAS
REALLY NOT BEEN PROVIDED OR
LEAD TO SITUATIONS LIKE A THREE
IN SAN DIEGO. OKAY RANT OVER
THERE IN MEANS LORD IF YOU'RE
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE. YOU'RE
OKAY YOU'RE YOU'RE FINE IF
YOU'RE GONNA STATE YOU'RE-
YOU'RE NOT SUBJECT TO THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS. THAT'S A
GRANDFATHERING MEANS PERFECT.
THANK YOU. ANYMORE QUESTIONS
MCCARTY. YEAH STALI. SO SECTION
THIRTY EIGHT I HAVE- MULTIPLE
CHARTERS IN MY SCHOOL AND IN MY
DISTRICT AND THERE IS I'M A
HUGE PROPONENT OF PARENTAL
CHOICE AND SCHOOL CHOICE BUT
TURNER FOR US ARE A NECESSITY
THIS ISN'T IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
GO TO THE SCHOOL DOWN THE
STREET WE HAVE KIDS THAT RIDE
ON THE SCHOOL BUS FOR FORTY
FIVE MINUTES ONE WAY. SO SOME
OF THESE RESTRICTIONS JUST
REALLY WON'T WORK FOR THEM AT
ALL AND BUT I HAVE A VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTION FOR THE
SECTION OF THIRTY EIGHT MY
NIECES LIVE IN MODOC COUNTY AND
THEY ATTEND A CHARTER SCHOOL IN
SHASTA COUNTY SO UNDER AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN ON JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO THE
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS LIKE MY
NIECES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
ENROLLED IN NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTERS WHO RESIDE IN ADJACENT
COUNTY- LET ME TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS IN THE BEGINNING A GIVE ME
ONE SECOND. LET ME ALSO SAY
THAT YOU MISTER C. DO YOU WANNA
YEAH SO RESPOND A MASON. SO
THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT SPECIFIC
TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY BECAUSE
UNDER CURRENT LAW EXISTING
CURRENT LAW. NOT CONSUMMATE
CHARTER SCHOOLS CANNOT HAVE
DISABILITIES AND ADJACENT
COUNTIES. ARE AND SO THIS BILL.
IS THAT ISSUE THERE IS NOT A
RESULT OF THIS BILL BUT AT THE
RISK OF RESULTS OF EXISTING-
CURRENT LAW OUT THERE. ARE THEY
MAY ONLY HAVE FACILITIES IN THE
DIFFICULT'S. THEY ARE
AUTHORIZED. SO IN GENERAL
THAT'S A- THOUGHT IN THE VALLEY
I LIVE IN THERE'S THREE
COUNTIES. WITHIN ONE. AREA SO
COUNTY LINES THE THAT'S VERY
BURDENSOME FOR CHILDREN WHO
LIVE IN VERY ROLE FRONTIER
AREAS BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT THE ANALYSIS OF YOUR
SITUATION THE SITUATION YOU
CITED THEY'VE AND ROLLED IN THE
SCHOOL IS EVER COUNTY. YES BILL
DOESN'T PRECLUDE THEM FROM
DOING THAT AND ROLLING IN A
DIFFERENT COUNTY SO THAT THEY
WOULD BE FINE. IT DOES IT DOES
WORK OKAY DOES APOLOGIZE I'M
AYE BUT IT'S CURRENT LAW I
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS BILL BUT
EXISTING CURRENT LAW ALREADY.
THAT I WHILE HOW WOULD THEY BE
GOING TO SCHOOL RIGHT OFF ITS
CURRENT LAW. COULD BE THAT
THERE THAT THE CURRENT LAWS I
BEAT HIM BLACK OF OVERSIGHT. OF
NOW. THAT THAT. I'M YEAH THAT'S
THAT'S COULD I COULD I DIRECTLY
ADDRESSES BECAUSE I. I HAVE THE
SAME CONCERN DO YOU MIND HAVING.
GREAT I. SO CHELSEA CAN CAN USE
THIS CHELSEA'S THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTING WROTE THE ANALYSIS-
AND SHE'S GOING TO SPEAK TO THE
MATTER. THE CURRENT LAW
SPECIFIES THAT NONHAZARDOUS
CHARTER SCHOOLS CANNOT HAVE
FACILITIES OR SATELLITE
FACILITIES IN ADJACENT COUNTIES
UNLESS THEY WERE APPROVED BY
THEIR LOCAL DISTRICT OKAY THAT
WAS TWO YEARS AGO WE PASSED
THAT LAW. THIS BILL WITH
SPECIFIED THAT THE ATTENDANCE
BOUNDARIES FOR NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS WOULD BE
THE COUNTY IN WHICH THEY ARE.
AUTHORIZED BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO HAVE
FACILITIES. SO IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT I
DISCOVERED THIS ALSO THIS THIS
ISSUE OF THE- OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL THAT HAS FACILITIES IN
TWO COUNTIES SO ACTUAL ONLINE
FACILITIES. AND YET YOU KNOW
THAT'S NOT OF THE NOT NORMALLY
LEGAL BUT IF THE COUNTY IF THEY
IF THEY SOUGHT APPROVAL. IT HAS
IT THEN DOES BECOME LEGAL SO
THAT'S HOW. THAT'S HOW THE SAID
THAT'S HOW THIS EXIST AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. AND SO- HI I'M
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. I'VE
I'VE TALKED TO THE OFFICER
ABOUT IT IT IS- LOOKING AT THIS
AS THIS MOVES FORWARD IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE MOST
CURRENT SCHOOLS IN THAT
SITUATION BUT- YEAH MISTER
BENNETT DID BRING ME AN ISSUE
THAT HE HAS FOUND IN SANTA
BARBARA. THAT HE SAID WE WOULD
DISCUSS AND SEEK TO FIND A
SOLUTION UPON AND THIS MAY BE
VERY ISSUE THAT YOU'RE CITING
RIGHT NOW I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE- FIGHT COMPLETELY
ALIGNED. BUT I KNEW YOU KNOW
THAT WE DO HAVE A TOPIC THAT WE
NEED TO DISCUSS AND WORK ON
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH WITH.
FACILITIES AND WHAT WHAT COUNTY
THEY'RE LOCATED THE NEXT DOOR
COUNTY X. ADDRESS SO THAT IS A
TOPIC WE NEED TO DISCUSS MORE
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
BILL. AND BRING UP ISSUES THAT
PEOPLE AREN'T AWARE OF OR MIGHT
NOT HAVE CONTEMPLATED BEFORE
TODAY AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY. ARE WE GOING TO BE ABLE
SOLVE THAT RIGHT NOW NO BUT IT
IS SOMETHING WE NEED TO DISCUSS
THIS IS OUR FIRST COMMITTEE FOR
THIS BILL- AND WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THAT. THE AUTHOR IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
DISCUSS THIS ISSUE LOOKING FOR
THE SAME OVERLAP BETWEEN MISTER
BENNETT AND- AN ENDLESS STALI
S. ASSEMBLY PORCELAIN I WOULD
BE A THIRD ON THAT TO LOOK AT
AMENDMENT TO THAT COULD WORK.
THE SPECIFIC. SCENARIO OUT. SO
I HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION ON.
THE IS MIKE A CLARIFYING I
GUESS THE VISITATION IN PERSON
VISITATION WITH YOUR TEACHERS
WHAT IS A REQUIREMENT UNDER THE
SPELL. LET ME GIVE YOU ONLY
GIVE YOU THE SPECIFIC NUMBER
BECAUSE I ALREADY. STATED IN MY
PRESENTATION. BUT RIGHT NOW NO
REQUIREMENTS- IT'S EVERY THIRTY
MINUTES EVERY THREE DAYS NO TWO
THREE EVERY THREE DAYS CONTACT
EVERY THREE DAYS IT'S CONTACT
EVERY THREE NINE THAT BE
VIRTUAL YEAH OKAY SO I DON'T
HAVE INTERNET MINE AND MY
DISTRICT SO CAN. THE PHONE. IN
THE PHONE CAN IT BE FOR ME THIS
IS OUR THIS IS LEGITIMATE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE BROADBAND AND IN
A GOOD PORTION OF MY DISTRICT
SO. IF IT'S A REQUIREMENT TO
VIRTUALLY TOUCH BASE EVERY
THREE DAYS THAT ISN'T GOING TO
WORK FOR MY DISTRICT THINK IT
INCLUDE PHONES. AS WELL THE
PHONECALL HOW ARE THEY
CONNECTING NOW I GUESS I WAS ON
BROADWAY WE ARE TAKE THEIR
PARENTS WERE QUESTIONED AND
GOOD BUT THE QUESTION. SO
THAT'S A CONCERN FOR ME OKAY
THAT'S NOT EVERY THAT'S NOT IT
THAT'S NOT A GUIDELINE OR
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD BE ACT
WOULD PHYSICALLY BE WORKABLE
FOR SOME OF MY- STUDENTS. SO
AND ALSO A LOT OF THEM WILL
TRIP THEY TAKE MY SISTER IN
PARTICULAR. TAKES HER KIDS
PHYSICALLY DRIVES THEM TO THEIR
TEACHER BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WORKS FOR THEM THAT'S THE MODEL
THAT WORKS FOR THEM. BUT IT
ISN'T EVERY WEEK AND SO. BUT
THAT DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE REGULATION AND
OVERSIGHT. ISN'T HAPPENING
BECAUSE- SO I THERE'S A THERE'S
A QUITE A FEW THINGS IN THIS
BILL THAT JUST DON'T WORK FOR
ROLE. CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW IT
CAN BE MY ONLY MY DISTRICT
THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE THAT HAVE
ROLE. PARTS OF THEIR DISTRICT
AS WELL. MR KILEY MISTER
BIGELOW WHAT GOES ON AND ON. SO
ANYWAY I DEFINITELY THINK
THERE'S SOME WORK TO BE DONE
HERE AND I WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE
IN THAT PROCESS MCALLISTER. AND
FOR PHONE CALLS DID NOT WORK
EITHER BECAUSE THAT'S AWFUL.
THAT'S ONE OF THE WAY THE
CONTRACT OFFER TO THE PHONE.
DEPENDS ON SELF SERVICE OR NOT
AND I'M TO AND BEYOND CAN DRIVE
OUT THROUGH MY DISTRICT WITH ME
SOMETIME AND- CHECK IT OUT BUT
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE. THOSE ARE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS. THAT I. OR
LAND LINE IS ANOTHER OPTION TO
RIGHT WE DON'T KNOW HAVE
CELLPHONES I'M GONNA HAVE BEEN
OUT THERE AND SO I KNOW THAT-
CELL PHONE DOESN'T WORK- IN
LOTS OF PLACES- BUT I. THANK
YOU HAVE A HOME IN THE
MOUNTAINS AND I HAVE A LAND
LINE IT HAS VERY LIMITED
INTERNET BUT I'M ABLE TO MAKE
THIS CALL SAYS FINE- I THOUGHT.
NOTHING UP OFF THE FOR TRACTION.
I THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I WE WANT TO GET FLEXIBILITY
HAVE. QUALITY INCIDENTS NEEDS
ARE BEING MET I WAS ACTUALLY
JUST TUTORING. WHATEVER
COLLEAGUES- KITS AT YESTERDAY.
AND THE FRUSTRATION THEY WERE
HAVING BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T
HAVE ANY INTERACTION WITH THE
TEACHERS ANSWER SOME BASIC
QUESTIONS. FOR THEM AND SO WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT. WE
ARE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE GETTING
INTERACTION THAT'S QUALITIES
CONCERT QUESTIONS THAT ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE- PROGRESSING- AND
GETTING OUT OF FAIR. EDUCATION
I THANK YOU OTHERS ARE MISTER
KILEY. THAT WAS PROBABLY GOING.
THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS THE AUTHORS ACTUALLY
I OWN OF COURSE YOU'RE FREE TO
CHIME IN IF YOU'D LIKE- I JUST
HAVE QUESTIONS FOR A FEW
QUESTIONS FOR TO THE WITNESSES-
FIRST FOR THE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION- AND THEN FOR THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
READ YOUR LETTER OF SUPPORT
AND- AND YOUR MEMO WHICH IS A
VERY IMPRESSIVE DOCUMENT THIRTY
THREE PAGE MEMO. GOING THROUGH.
EACH OF THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL OR AT LEAST MANY OF THEM-
AND EXPLAINING. HOW THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN HELPFUL IN PREVENTING
THE SCHEME THAT YOUR OFFICE ON
COVERED. IN THEM MCMANUS CASE
AND- YOU CLEARLY DID
EXCEPTIONAL WORK IN THAT CASE
AND SO- YOU KNOW I'VE GIVEN-
THE OPINION OF YOUR OFFICE A
LOT OF WEIGHT AND CONSIDERING
THIS LEGISLATION AND SO I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I HAVE. A CLEAR
SENSE OF WHAT WHAT YOUR
POSITION IS I MEAN DESERVE
SUMMARIZE THOSE DOCUMENTS IN
YOUR- TESTIMONY TODAY YOU
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL. WOULD
HELP PREVENT PROTECT. THE
PUBLIC AGAINST THE SORT OF
FRAUD THAT PLAYED OUT IN THE
LEAD TO THE MCMANUS CASES ALL
RIGHT. WELL LET ME EXPLAIN
THANK YOU FOR GIVING THE
OPPORTUNITY AND FOR READING
THROUGH THE DOCUMENTS. WE
SUBMITTED TO YOU FOLKS
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE RELATED TO
OUR AREAS OF- WHAT WE SOCCER.
AND ARE AREAS WHEN WE READ
THROUGH THE BILL THAT WERE
RELATED TO. THE CASE THAT WE
SOCCER. WERE NOT IN THE
POSITION TO PUT FORWARD PUBLIC
POLICY HAS TO ALL AREAS- THERE
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE BILL. THAT
WE WEREN'T INVOLVED WITH- BUT
THE AREAS THAT WE WERE INVOLVED
WITH WE WANT TO GIVE
INFORMATION. AS TO WHAT WE SAW
AND HOPEFULLY AREAS THAT YOU AS
THE LEGISLATURE ASSEMBLY YOU.
CAN YOU KNOW CAN SOLVE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES. I SEE AN- SO YOUR
LETTER SAYS YOU'VE SUPPORT THE
BILL YOU IN FACT THINGS AS YOU
EMPHATICALLY SUPPORT THE BALLOT
OR YOUR OFFICE DOES- IF THERE'S
OF COURSE YOU KNOW BEEN
HUNDREDS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE WEIGHED IN. IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IT IS
THE MIDDLE LETTERS IN
OPPOSITION- SAYING THAT THIS IS
GOING THAT THIS LEGISLATION
WOULD- INHIBIT THEIR ABILITY TO
OPERATE IN THIS SITE MANY OF
THE PROVISIONS THAT YOU ALSO
CITE- IN YOUR LETTER AND SO.
AND THIS IS GONNA HARM THEIR
ABILITY TO SERVE THEIR FAMILIES
WELL WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
YOU HAVE ANY REASON TO SORT OF
DOUBT THAT. AT ALL I AM- I WILL
SEVEN I WILL- THIS I TALK TO
THE DA. FROM SAN DIEGO COUNTY
YESTERDAY- AND WE HAD A LENGTHY
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE BILL AND
ABOUT WHAT SHE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE HERE TODAY IN WHICH. SHE
SOUGHT TO DO IS BRING SOME. I
GUESS PROSECUTE. PROSECUTORIAL
EXPERTISE NOT EDUCATIONAL.
POLICY EXPERTISE TO US TODAY.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO ASK HIM TO
ASK THAT QUESTION RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE- AGAIN YOU'RE YOU'RE
GOING INTO A LANE THAT SHE-
DOESN'T SEE HERSELF AND- SHE'S
NOT GOING TO BLEED INTO-
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL POLICY.
AS A WHOLE. WHAT WHAT SHE
BROUGHT TODAY. WAS A GENTLEMAN
WHO IS VERY EXPERIENCED IN A
CASE. DOWN IN SAN DIEGO AND THE
CASE IS. IT IS IMPORTANT TODAY
BECAUSE IT SPEAKS TO WHAT'S
GOING ON ACROSS OUR STATE. AND
HOW WE TODAY MIGHT ADDRESS PART
OF THAT BUT AGAIN I'M- I DON'T
WANT HIM GETTING INTO.
EDUCATIONAL POLICY AND THAT'S
WHAT I BELIEVE YOU'RE
ATTEMPTING TO ASK HIM TO DO NOW
HE'S- SO NOW I'M NOT I'M ASKING
HIM. WHETHER YOU HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS PARTICULAR
POLICY TOOL I COULD HAVE THE
EFFECT. ONE OF ORDER AND MISTER
KILEY IS NOT IN THE COURT ROOM
HERE. THAT YOU KNOW DO NOT ASK
QUESTIONS AND NOW THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO PUT A HYPOTHETICAL IN
IN THE IN THE WITNESSES. HAD
HE'S TALKING ABOUT WHAT HE
FEELS ABOUT BRING
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT YOU'RE
ASKING HIM ABOUT THAT WHAT THE
OPPOSITION THINGS THAT'S NOT
WHAT HE'S HERE FOR AND THIS IS.
THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE%
QUESTIONING SO I THINK YOU KNOW
IN THE FUTURE IF YOU CAN IT'S
NOT A PROGRAM AYE AYE SCOTT
LISTEN I'M GONNA I'M GONNA PASS
THE GENTLEMAN NOT TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION BECAUSE I BELIEVE YOUR
QUESTIONS RELATIVE TO
EDUCATIONAL POLICY AS A WHOLE.
AND THAT'S AS HE HAS CLEARLY
STATED NOT HIS EXPERTISE AND
NOT WHY HEIS HERE TODAY I
DON'T KNOW WHY YOU'RE AFRAID OF
THE ANSWER LET THEM WHAT THE
LETTER WHEN TO SPEAK FOR
HIMSELF USING. TO ME. THAT THE-
UNSETTLED. I THINK YOU HAD
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR ANOTHER
INDIVIDUAL- NO I HAD A COUPLE
QUESTIONS OF THIS WITNESS. I
MEAN THEY'RE WEIGHING IN ON AN
EDUCATION BILL I'M NOT ASKING
TO A PINE EDUCATION POLICY YEAH
BUT YOU'RE ASK MISTER CHAIR
HE'S ASKING HIM TO GIVE HIS
OPINION. ON WHAT THE OPPOSITION
FIX NO I'M NOT YEAH YOU DID YOU
SAID WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THE
OPPOSITION SAYS THIS IS GONNA
SHUT PEOPLE DOWN. WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY SAID TO
SACRIFICE. ARGUMENT WAS GIVEN
ON ITS USE ME EXCUSE. ALONG
WITH REYES MORTAR HERE AFFECT
OKAY IF YOU HAVE AN- OTHER
QUESTION. FOR THIS INDIVIDUAL.
THAT IS. WITHIN HIS LANE A FEW
HORROR- I'LL ASK HIM TO ANSWER
IT BUT I'M GETTING. I THINK
YOU'RE BLEEDING INTEGRATOR
EDUCATIONAL POLICY AND THAT'SNOT HIS ROLE HERE TODAY OKAY
MAYBE OUT OF WHAT YOU SEE IS
THE SCOPE OF YOUR TESTIMONY. SO
THAT I KNOW WHAT I SHOULD GET
MY QUESTION TO. I BELIEVE HE
ALREADY STATED WHAT HIS SCOPE
WAS HERE TODAY WHAT IS THAT
WHEN IT'S JUST YOU KNOW IT IS
GIVING. YOU THE OPPORTUNITY.
HUSING HEY. HE STATED THE WHEN
HE CAME UP HERE. WHAT WHAT WHAT
HIS WHAT HIS ROLE WAS HERE
TODAY AND I WANT TO RESPECT
THAT WELL BECAUSE LOOK HE CAME
UP FROM SAN DIEGO. OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT I JUST LIKE
REMINDERS THAT I CAN KNOW WHAT
QUESTIONS OR ARE WITHIN BOUNDS.
OF KIND OF WHAT YOU HAVE YES
GOT IT AND I BELIEVE HE STATED
THE SCOPES OF ASKING THE
QUESTION IS CAN I PLEASE JUST
GET A REMINDER OF WHAT THE
SCRIPTURES ESTONIANS. THERE
WERE HERE TO INFORM OF WHAT WE
SAW IN OUR CASE WHERE WE CAN
BECAUSE I'VE ON FORCE AFTER
MINE EITHER STILL SOME ONGOING
ASPECTS OF THE CASE THAT ARE
THE LEGAL CHALLENGES AND THE
LACK OF OVERSIGHT THAT OCCURS
AT THE STATE LEVEL SO- I'M NOT
HERE TO TALK ABOUT ALL THE
POLICIES OF THIS BILL AND
WHETHER OR NOT ALL THOSE
POLICIES WOULD BE GOOD OR BAD
BUT JUST THE FACTS OF THE CASE
AND THE ISSUES THAT WE SAW. AND
THAT YOU AND THE REASON YOU
IDENTIFY YOU BELIEVE WOULD BE
AFFECTED RELEASE WOULD HELP
INTO MAKING SURE THINGS LIKE
THAT HAPPEN AGAIN. CORRECT AND
I TAKE IT SINCE THIS WOULD
PROBABLY BE A KIND OF OUTSIDE
OF. YOUR LANE THAT YOU DIDN'T
CONSIDER WHETHER THERE ARE
OTHER ALTERNATIVES THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN JUST AS EFFECTIVE AS
THAT WAS YOU JUST KIND OF.
ANALYZE WHAT WAS IN FRONT OF
THE RIGHT. WITH IT WE POINT OUT
WHAT WE SAW IN OUR CASE AND-
ORDER THEM MAJOR ASPECTS OF IT
WAS THE LACK OF OVERSIGHT AT
THE STATE LEVEL OF THE- LACK OF%
FOLLOWING OF THE STATE FUNDS.
AND THEN AS A BROKE DOWN TO THE
INDIVIDUAL LEVELS. THE FACT
THAT THE OVERSIGHT WASN'T THERE
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE. AND THAT
BECAUSE OF THAT UNFORTUNATELY.
MONEY THAT SHOULD HAVE GONE TO
STUDENT EDUCATION WENT TO THE
FOLKS THAT WERE. RUNNING THESE
BAD ACTORS SCHOOLS AND TAKING
THE MONEY. THANK YOU I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THE CASE
SURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR I
HAD A QUESTION FOR ANOTHER
WITNESS. YEAH THIS IS. A FROM
THE REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. I
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AS
WELL I WANT TO ASK ABOUT A
PORTION OF YOUR LETTER- OF
SUPPORT WERE YOU SAID. A
PACKAGE OF BILLS PASSED IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. WE
COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
FOR ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS
PROVISIONS OF AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN OF THIS BILL WOULD
BLATANTLY VIOLATE THE AGREEMENT
REACHED TO THE NEGOTIATIONS ON
ALL THESE BILLS TO LIMIT
FURTHER CHARTER RESTRICTIONS
SO. CAN YOU JUST I THINK YOU
ALLUDED TO THE SENATE TESTIMONY
IS WHAT WHAT WHAT EXACTLY WAS
THAT AGREEMENT. WHAT WAS THE
NATURE OF IT. WELL L. AS YOU
MAY RECALL- IN A TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. THREE MASSIVE PIECES
OF LEGISLATION THAT WERE
INTENDED TO ADDRESS ESPECIALLY
SOME SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT OUT OF.
OUT OF AREA AUTHORIZING- THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ISSUES
ISSUES THAT HAD NOT BEEN
RESOLVED FOR TEN YEARS AND WE
HAD BEEN MEETING IN THESE
ROOMS. I TRIED TO COME TO
REASONABLE COMPROMISES- IT. SB
ONE TWENTY SIX ADDRESSED ALL
THOSE ISSUES WITH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY IN OPERATIONS IN.
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
PROVISIONS IMPROVING PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY. AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE AUTHORED BY CHAIRMAN
DONALD. INCREASED AUTHORIZED TO
DISCRETION AND CHARTERING
DECISIONS AND PROVIDING CLEAR.
AND SPECIFIC CRITERIA FOR
CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS
INCLUDING A BROAD. ARRAY OF
ADDITIONAL MEASURES
SPECIFICALLY RELATE RELATED TO
CREDENTIALING AND- SECURITY
CHECKS AND MANY OF THOSE
ISSUES. THEN FIFTY NO SEVEN
EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH SEVEN. ALSO
A- CO AUTHORED BY CHAIR DONALD
AND MISTER MCCARTY- AUTHORED BY
MISS SMITH ADDRESSED A LOT OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE IT
PRECISELY IN. FULL EVIDENCE
HERE IN IN YOUR DISCUSSION.
THAT RELATED TO OUT OF ARE
AUTHORIZING- OF THE LOCATION OF
RESOURCE CENTER. RESOURCE
CENTER SPELL WHERE DOES NOT
CLASSROOM BASED SCHOOLS COULD
BE OPERATED. AND A LOT OF
AUTHORIZER. TRANSPARENCY END UP
IN OVERSIGHT. THE FULL. BRUNT
OF THOSE MEASURES JUST APPROVED
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN TO THE
REGULATORY. PROCESS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION YET. SO BUT HOW
DOES BILL BY ANY. AND WHAT IS I
MEAN. WHEN V. THIS PACKAGE OF
BILLS- WAS APPROVED- WE AGREED
THAT THERE WOULD BE A TWO YEAR
MORATORIUM WHILE ADDITIONAL.
MEASURES PRECISELY AROUND NON
CLASSROOM BASED OPERATIONS
POSITION A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEING ADDRESSED HERE
THAT WE WOULD PICK THIS UP IN A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER. AT AT THE
AT A LATER DATE CERTAINLY THE
PANDEMIC HAS MADE CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT AND AT AND DEEP
STUDY- YOU ERY CHALLENGING IN
THIS YEAR WHEN EVERY SINGLE
SCHOOL ACROSS. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A NON CLASSROOM BASED
SCHOOL LET'S REMIND OURSELVES
OF THAT IN OUR- NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN LEADING THE WAY
IN PROVIDINGVERY HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION AND MODELING FOR
AND PARTNERING WITH DISTRICTS.
ON HOW TO DO IT WELL. HOWEVER
BY RE LITIGATING THE ISSUES OF
TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ALL OF
THOSE ISSUES THAT WE ALREADY
PUT BEHIND US AND DUMPING THEM
ONTO THIS VEHICLE. THAT IS
OUTSIDE OF THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE
SAID WE WOULD AGREE TO AND
REALLY UNDERMINES GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S COMPROMISED. THAT IS
OUR VIEW WELL I MEAN I DON'T
KNOW A FAIR CRITICISM I MEAN
WHO ARE THE PARTIES TO THIS
AGREEMENT THE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. ALL THE THINGS I'VE ALL
THE PARTIES TO THE AGREEMENT
WERE ALL OF US THAT TOGETHER
SIGNED OF THAT LEGISLATION WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOM INCLUDING ALL
OF THE LABOR THE MANAGEMENT
GROUPS. MANY OF THE FOLKS IN
THIS ROOM. WELL I MEAN I WHAT
DIDN'T- SUPPORT THAT L. OUTSIDE
THREE OF THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE THE TIME SO HOW CAN
WE- YOU KNOW SAY THAT THIS BILL
REALLY VIOLATES ANY AGREEMENT
THAT WE WOULD BE. I IS THAT
REALLY A FAIR CRITICISM YOU CAN
SOMEHOW BINDS THE LEGISLATURE
SPEECH OR ACTIONS. WELL IT
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW THE PROCESS
OF DEMOCRATIC ENGAGEMENT IT
WOULD BE A PUTS ALL OF THESE
ISSUES. UP OF FOR COLLABORATION
AND DEBATE AND CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT BUT I DO BELIEVE
THAT WHEN WE WANT TO ACTUALLY
TARGET THE ISSUES THAT- THAT
THAT WE WOULD. ADDRESS IN A
LATER SESSION THAT WE WERE AT
THE AT INTENDING TO ADDRESS
THOSE IN A SCOPED AND SURGICAL
MATTER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT WERE STILL LEFT
OUTSTANDING. AND YET WE'RE
REALLY RELATE TO GETTING NEW IT
GOT OLD ISSUES. OKAY I MEAN I.
I MEAN MY VIEW AT THE TIME WAS
THAT. THIS AGREEMENT OF COURSE
WASN'T GONNA BE HONORED IF IT
WAS IT WOULD BE THE ONLY TIME
IN WORLD HISTORY THAT A
APPEASEMENT HAS WORKED SO DO
YOU THINK THAT MAYBE THE TIME
HAS COME TO CALL A SPADE A
SPADE AND TO RECOGNIZE. THAT
THIS BILL IS PART OF AN EFFORT
OF THIS CAPITAL TO AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA. I
CERTAINLY THAT'S THE INTENT OF
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. IS THERE ANY
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT UNDER THE GUISE OF PARITY
AND EQUITY WE ARE LOSING THE
VERY SOUL OF WHAT MAKES GOOD
CHARTER SCHOOL SUCCESSFUL
DEALING ESPECIALLY WITH THE
MOST MARGINALIZED AND MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS WE WERE THE
ONES LIKE I SAID WITH WE WERE
THE FIRST TO RAISE THE ISSUE
NUMBERS PLEASE SUMMER. WE WERE
THE FIRST TO ISSUE WHAT WILL
ALERTS THAT THERE WERE PROBLEMS
WITH A THREE IT IS CERTAINLY
NOT YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING THIS
QUESTION A LONGER SAID YOU HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR THAT I
DON'T THAT WAS MY LAST QUESTION
I HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU I IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'RE IN AGREEMENT- AND I
THINK THAT THAT FACT JUST NEEDS
TO BE ACKNOWLEDGED IT'S EITHER
IT'S TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY IT'S FRAUD.
WHATEVER THE PURPORTED
JUSTIFICATION MIGHT BE FOR THIS
BILL OR THE NEXT BILL THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE THERE'S AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S WHAT
NEEDS TO BE FOUGHT AGAINST ON
THIS BILL- AND THAT MANY OTHERS
LIKE IT THAT WE'RE SURE TO SEE
IN THE FUTURE IF WE DON'T TAKE
A STAND NOW WELL I APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTIONS AND CERTAINLY
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THEY'RE READY THERE IS A LINK
HERE I THANK YOU THAT WE ARE
NOT. THANK YOU THANK YOU. CAN I
JUST WANNA BE CLEAR THAT AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE AUTHORED ON GAY
ESTABLISH A TO A MORATORIUM ON
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS IN THE ANALYSIS HERE WHY DID
IT DO THAT AS SHE HAS STATED SO
WE COULD WORK ON OTHER ISSUES.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
IT'S. THAT SIMPLE MISS GARCIA-
GATH. I FIND IT INSULT. THAT
TRY TO ENSURE WE HAVE PARITY
AND GOOD GOVERNMENT AND WE STOP
ABUSE- IS SEEN AS- AN ATTACK
ON. HER SCHOOL THESE BILLS
APPLY TO BOTH DISTRICT AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS. OUT THERE. I
WILL SAY THAT THOSE BILLS THAT
WERE REFERENCE I. DID NOT COVER
ANY OF THE ABUSE THAT WE
THOUGHT BY EIGHT THIRTY OUT
THERE. INTO THE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS AT YOU KNOW
THE SITUATION. IS OUT THERE. I
THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
THAT. THE LAST PERSON TALK
ABOUT THAT THEY WANT TO IT'S
WHEN THEY WANT. TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND IT SHOULD BE
WHEN THEY WANT TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE THAT SHOULD BE THAT WE
ADDRESS THEM NOT BECAUSE THE
NEED IS NOW IN THE BASE IS
GOING ON NOW. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY. YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
NOTE I THINK IS TO KILEY.
HONESTLY HELP TO DO WITH THE
ISSUE THAT- THAT THERE WAS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT WHEN THOSE
BILLS WERE SIGNED AND GOVERNORS
THE GOVERNOR'S STATEMENT AND
WE'RE IN THE ROOM IS THAT
HOPEFULLY WE CAN PUT THESE
ISSUES TO REST ME WASN'T THE
HOSPITAL CORDON WRITTEN IN
SANDSTONE OR WHAT HAVE YOU. AND
THAT WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE GOOD
STEWARDS OF TAXPAYER MONEY AND
THE- DA OF SAN DIEGO FOUND
FRAUD AND THERE WERE SOME
ISSUES THAT WEREN'T COVERED AND
SO IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY
LOOK. AT WEAKNESSES THAT STATE
LAW AND RESPONSE. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE SAYING THIS IS KILL OF
ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS- WE'RE
SAYING IT DOES NOT- BRINGS
ABOUT FAIR ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT'S IS WHY WE HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE HAVE A
HEARING TODAY. WILL CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD BUT IN OUR VIEW
DATA ALLOWS GOOD OPERATORS TO
STAY IN EXISTENCE- WE KNOW THAT
DURING THE PANDEMIC FATAH
FAMILIES TO REALIZE THIS WORKS
FOR THEM AND THAT'LL CONTINUE
IN. CHARTER SCHOOLS OR YOU KNOW
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS- BUT
THIS IS NOT ABOUT ENDING
CHARTER SCHOOLS AS WE KNOW IT
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW IT'S JUST
RIDICULOUS AND- I WITH THAT
TYPE YOU KNOW I THINK WE SHOULD
CALL THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT YOU WANTED
CA. THANK THANK YOU MUCH- AND I
APPRECIATE THE INTEREST IN.
TRYING TO CALL VOTE- BUT I DO
HAVE. SIMPSON COMMENTED I GOT
QUITE PROJECT YOUR- FORBEARANCE
WHILE I GET THROUGH THIS- THIS
IS A AND IMPORTANCIA
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE I'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS- WITH THE PEOPLE
WHILE I'M TRYING TO DO MY
RESEARCH IN PREPARATION FOR
TODAY'S HEARING- AND FIRST I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE I
APPRECIATE TO CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTATIVES
THAT I MET WITH- WHO GAVE ME
SPECIFIC ASPECTS OF THE BILL-
THAT THEY HAD CONCERNS ABOUT.
AND THEY DID THAT FAR ENOUGH IN
ADVANCE- THAT I HAD TIME TO
EXAMINE THOSE ISSUES. I ALSO
APPREIATE MY MEETING- WITH
OVER A HUNDRED CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENTS- ON ASSUME WHO- I THINK
DID A OF. A STRONG JOB OF
REINFORCING FOR ME HOW
IMPORTANT THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION IS TO THEM. AND HOW
MUCH THEY VALUE THEIR CURRENT
CHARTER SCHOOL EXPERIENCE.
ADDITIONALLY I APPRECIATE THE
STAFF OF PARTICULAR CHELSEA'S.
OF STEADY AND NEARLY ROUND THE
CLOCK EFFORT- TO BE AVAILABLE-
AND TO PATIENTLY RESPOND TO MY
QUESTIONS- ABOUT CLARIFICATION
SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT. FINALLY
I APPRECIATE TODAY I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY OF YOU KNOW THIS BUT
IT WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SANTA BARBARA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT'S THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICT- SPEAKING- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- SANTA
BARBARA BEING- THE- MAJOR
SCHOOL DISTRICT- YEAH. IN MY
DISTRICT. BUT CLEARLY- KATE
FORD'S- TESTIMONY- IDENTIFIES
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A SERIOUS-
THAT THAT THE SERIES OF
COMPROMISES OVER THE YEARS. HAS
LED TO. MUCH LESS ANIMOSITY AND
A STRONGER BOND BETWEEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS-
PUBLIC SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
HAVE. NOT TALKED TO ME ABOUT
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE- ABOUT
THIS BILL. AND THAT IMPROVED
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS AS
BENEFICIAL FOR EVERYBODY AND.
HELPFUL TO MAINTAIN AND- SO I
PER HER. AND HELPING TO. MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT THAT'S OUT THERE
AND WHY THEY- HAVE SOME ISSUES
SO AS I EVALUATE THIS BILL MY
GOAL I JUST HAVE ONE GOAL AND
THAT'S JUST GOOD GOVERNMENT
JUST TRY TO CONVINCE ME THAT
IT'S GOOD GOVERNMENT OUT OF A
SUPPORT THE BILL- AND SOME
PEOPLE AS- WE'VE HEARD HER TO
CHECK YOUR BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL BRING AN END TO NEARLY ALL
ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOLS- AND-
THAT THAT IS I BELIEVE THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONCERN BEING
EXPRESSED BY THE PARENTS THAT
ARE COMMUNICATING TO ME HEY
THIS IS GOING TO BRING THIS TO
AN END- THAT THE PARENT EVEN.
IS SITTING ON THIS COMMITTEE-
THE ISSUES THAT MOST GENERATE
THIS CONCERN ABOUT CLOSURE ARE
THESE AS FAR AS I SEE IT. THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE FOR ONLINE
LEARNING THE INCREASE OF THE
FEE FROM 1% TO THREE PERCENT.
THE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA MOVING IT TO A FORMULA
THAT'S BASED ON HOW MUCH ONLINE
I MEAN HOW MUCH IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION YOU HAVE- AND- THEN
THERE. AND THEN THEY ALSO THE
RESTRICTION OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHICH WAS AT BEING
BEING RESTRICTED TO JUST ONE
COUNTY- THERE ARE ALSO SOME
ISSUES- REGARDING PROCESS
FOLLOWED IN THE ADVANCEMENT OF
THE BILL. AND I THINK THE
DISCUSSION THAT WE'VE HAD HERE-
BUT LET ME IDENTIFIED THAT THE
PROCESS QUESTIONS AS THE
WEAKEST ARGUMENT THAT I'VE
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION- IN
TERMS OF DOING THAT. I
CERTAINLY COMING HERE DON'T
FEEL LIKE I'M BOUND BY
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR SAID TWO
YEARS AGO SAYING I HOPE
THERE'S- PEACE FOR AWHILE- IN
THE IN TERMS OF MOVING FORWARD-
MOST OF THE CHANGES ADVANCED BY
THIS BILL. I BELIEVE ARE
INTENDED AS WAYS TO INCENTIVIZE
OF MOVEMENT TO A HEALTHY
COMBINATION. OF ONLINE. AND IN
PERSON LEARNING. THAT I WANT TO
ANSWER THAT EVERY THAT I'VE-
IN THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE OR REGULATE RIGHT
SOME HEALTHY COMBINATION OF
ONLINE AND IN PERSON LEARNING-
AND THERE ARE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT EXCEPTIONS TO THIS
PRINCIPLE FOR. FOR SUCH A- BUT
THE UP TO THIS PRINCIPLE OF A
COMBINATION OF ONLINE AND IN
PERSON BUT CERTAINLY THE
EVIDENCE IS STRONG. THAT THAT
IS SUPERIOR TO JUST SIMPLY
ONLINE INSTRUCTION ONLY AS- AS
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED. SO FOR ME
THE QUESTION IN FRONT OF US
RELEASED. FOR SCHOOLS TO THE
DESIRE TO USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
IS IT APPROPRIATE TO USE A
COMBINATION OF INCENTIVES AND
REGULATIONS TO TRY TO PUSH.
THOSE SCHOOLS TO HAVE A HEALTHY
COMBINATION OF ONLINE AND IN
PERSON. OR TO LEAVE THE STATUS
QUO WHERE THEY COULD DO VERY
LITTLE IN PERSON- IF ANY. AND
THEN THE SECOND QUESTION I
THINK IS TO THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL. DO THAT DO THEY
APPROPRIATELY PUSH FOR ONLINE
AND IN PERSON WITHOUT HAVING
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES THAT ARE
GREATER THAN THE BENEFITS LIKE
THAT THAT COULD COME FROM THAT.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE ISSUES
OF REQUIREMENT FOR PHYSICAL
LOCATION THE REGION CREATING
THE FEE FROM ONE TO THREE
PERCENT. AND THE MODIFYING OF
THE FUNDING FORMULA WILL FOR
MOST SCHOOLS BECAUSE SOME SOME
REAL ADJUSTMENTS THAT THERE
WILL JUST WOULD HAVE TO BE
RIGHT. BUT I BELIEVE FROM WHAT
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SEE THAT
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS CAN BE MADE
BY THE SCHOOLS IF THERE ARE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE MAKING A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THEIR STUDENTS. AND ALSO
FOLLOW THE SPIRIT OF COMPROMISE
THAT HAS EVOLVED OVER THE YEARS
SHOULD YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
BATTLING OF DEBTS IN BETTER
THAN THE LAW REGARDING CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH WITH PUBLIC SCHOOLS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE FEE INCREASED FROM
1% TO THREE PERCENT. THAT CAN
ONLY THAT MONEY CAN ONLY BE
USED FOR MORE OVERSIGHT. AND IF
IT'S NOT USED FOR OVERSIGHT FEE
CAN BE CHARGED CORRECT THAT THE
FEE WILL BE LESS SO IT'S ONLY
IF IT IF YOU NEED IT FOR THE
OVERSIGHT. AND CERTAINLY TODAY
I THINK A GOOD CASE HAS BEEN
MADE OF THAT MORE OVERSIGHT IS
NEEDED THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS IF THIS IS COMPLICATED.
TO DO THIS KIND OF OVERSIGHT
IT'S COMPLICATED IN NORMAL
SCHOOLS IF YOU GO TO ONLINE
SCHOOLS WITH THE LACK OF
PHYSICAL PRESENCE AND THE
ABILITY TO TAKE LITTLE LEAGUE
YOU KNOW AND DO REGISTRATION
ONLINE. SO WE NEED MORE ROBUST
ON OVERSIGHT SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING WE'RE
GOING TO ONLINE ONLINE SCHOOLS.
SO I THINK ALMOST EVERYBODY
AGREES WE NEED WE DON'T NEED.
MORE OVERSIGHT SO A FEE IAN
CREASED HEALTH FOR THAT-
OVERSIGHT DOES NOT. ME AS
INAPPROPRIATE PARTICULAR IF
IT'S ONLY ALLOWED TO BE USED
FOR THE OVERSIGHT. THE
REQUIREMENT OF A OF A PHYSICAL
LOCATION- IS- IS A CHALLENGE
FOR SOME OF THESE ONLINE
SCHOOLS BUT- I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT. THE CHARTER ONLINE
SCHOOLS HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
FLEXIBILITYTHAN TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ONLINE- COMMITTEE PHYSICAL
THEY WOULD HAVE TO DEVELOP. SO
TODAY I STILL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE IMPACT OF
THE COUNTY REACHED RESTRICTIONS
I APPRECIATE THAT THE- CHAIR.
IS WILLING TO- WORK WITH AND
EXPLORE THOSE- AS SHE'S
EXPRESSED AND THEN FINALLY I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT AS A
RESULT OF COVERT. ONLINE
INSTRUCTION HAS ARRIVED FOR
MAINSTREAM AMERICA. LIKE IT OR
NOT WE GOT EXPOSED TO IT IT IS
OUT THERE- AND WE IT AS FAR AS
I CAN TELL HAVE NOT REALLY HAD
IN THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATIVE
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THIS EVOLVING
FIELD OF EDUCATION. SO THE
QUESTION IS AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE OVERALL PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL PROVIDE A COMMONSENSE
EFFORT TO TRY TO PROVIDE
REGULATIONS NEEDED TO SUPPORT.
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE ONLINE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE MAKING
A GOOD FAITH EFFORT. YOU'VE
ALREADY SEEN. ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS GET TARNISHED BY THE A.
THREE SCHEDULE ALL OF. SO I
WOULD I WOULD HOPETHAT PEOPLE
WOULD LOOK AT THIS IS SAYING IN
THE SPIRIT OF THE COMPROMISE OF
US OUT THERE IF WE GET THE
APPROPRIATE REGULATIONS AND WE
DO IT AN APPROPRIATE WAY. OUT
WE ACTUALLY CAN INCREASE THE
CREDIBILITY OF- THOSE GOOD
FAITH THOSE PEOPLE ARE MAKING A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO PROVIDE
QUALITY EDUCATION AND FOLLOW
THE SPIRIT OF COMPROMISE IT'S
**** BEEN DEVELOPED WITH PROPER
SAFEGUARDS. FINAL THING THAT I
WOULD THE POINT THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE IT SAID YES
ULTIMATELY. IF YOU WANT TO USE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS. FOR A FOR
PROFIT VENTURE. THE BURDEN OF
PROOF IS ON YOU. AT IS ARE
REPEAT IF YOU WANT TO USE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS FOR A FOR
PROFIT VENTURE WE DON'T MAKE
SCHOOLS USE TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
TAXPAYERS THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
CHOICE WHETHER THEY'RE GONNA
PAY THEIR TAXES FOR THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOL. SO BUT WHEN THEY DO
THAT THEY EXPECT A LOT OF
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S A AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE A
FOR PROFIT COMPANIES COME
AGAIN. THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS
IT IS ON THEM AND RIGHT NOW I
BELIEVE THAT THE- LEGISLATIVE
AND EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP AND
IN IN SACRAMENTO IS SAYING.
WELL WE BELIEVE IN A
COMBINATION OF ONLINE AND IN
PERSON. BUT WE'RE NOT SO
CONVINCED THAT WERE JUST READY
TO JUST SAY IT'S OKAY TO GO
COMPLETE ONLINE. WITHOUT ANY
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT SO IF YOU
DON'T WANT THE RESTRICTIONS IF
YOU WANT MORE FLEXIBILITY. THEN
GIVE YOU CAN ASK FOR THE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AT THIS POINT
IN TIME IT IN THE CONVERSATION
SELF FOR THE THIS IS THE
BEGINNING. OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO REGULATE ONLINE
SCHOOLS HOW DO YOU DO IT RIGHT-
I RESPECT A GOOD FAITH EFFORT
THAT'S BEEN MADE TO TRY TOGET
THIS YEAR. AND I RESPECT THE
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS MADE BY THE
CHARTER SCHOOL ADVOCATES
PARTICULARLY THE PARENTS WHO
ARE CONCERNED THAT JUST MIGHT
BE SOMEHOW THE DEATH KNELL OF
THAT. I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
CASE I WANT TO DO GOOD
GOVERNMENT I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
PART OF AN EFFORT TO CLOSE ALL
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
BENNETT- SING UP MR LEE. I JUST
WANTED TO THE CONSTANT
LEADERSHIP OF OUR- AND WELL AS-
THE- CRISTINA GARCIA. ON MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE HOLDING OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR EDUCATING OUR STUDENTS I
DON'T WANT TO. RETREAD THE
GREAT GROUND THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY MADE. BUT I JUST WHAT
IS TO SAY THAT WHEN THE- WHAT
IT IS PROGRAM THE PROCESS THE I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST TO BE
ADDED THE COLLECTOR THE BILLS
WELL. YES OKAY WITH THAT ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE NOW LET'S GET TO THE
PUBLIC BECAUSE I KNOW THEY WANT
TO BE HEARD ON THIS. OKAY SO
WE'RE GOING TO IS IF YOU'RE IN
THE ROOM. WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES
AND THE ROOM. WILL TAKE UP TO
TEN MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT
AND THE MOON IN THE ROOM WHAT
YOU DO IS YOU COME UP YOU STATE
YOUR NAME. IF YOUR ASSOCIATE
WITH A GROUP OR YOUR PARENT
THAT'S FINE SAY THAT AND THEN
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
SO DON'T GET DON'T SAY ANYTHING
MORE THAN THAT OR YOU'LL BE CUT
OFF. OKAY AND THERE AND BE
RESPECTFUL TO BECAUSE WE HAVE%
OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
BE. MAYBE OUTSIDE OR MAYBE ON
THE PHONES THAT WE HAVE TO HEAR
FROM TO AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE OUT HERE PRETTY SOON. IS
ANOTHER COMMITTEES COMING IN
AND THEY HAVE TO CLEAN THE-
CLEAN THE ROOM SO WITH THAT-
SUPPORT- THE GUIDE THE-
OPPOSITION. OR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ALRIGHT I HURDLES
MARQUEZ ON BEHALF OF VISIONS
AND EDUCATION AND INSPIRE.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. HI I'M IN THE ABSENT
PARENT LEADER AND THE PARENT
PARTICIPATION PARTICLE
COMMUNITY AND WE OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS SERRA
GRECO I'M REPRESENTING NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS. PARENTS AND STAFF OF
THE- OF THE SCHOOLS AND I
OPPOSE THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. MY
NAME IS BREANNA HUMES AND I'M A
MOM OF TWO CHARTER SCHOOL KIDS
WHO ARE SPECIAL NEEDS AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HORUMAR DONAHOE I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF HOME IN
HIGHER EDUCATION AND I'M HOME
SCHOOL PARENTS AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS SKYLER SMITH I'M A I'M A
STUDENT WITH A CHARTER SCHOOL
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HI I'M ANNA SMITH I
AM A CHARTER SCHOOL PARENT AND
AN EDUCATOR AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS LOW TCO GAMBLE
I AM A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER FOR
BOTH THE CHARTER SCHOOL AND- A
PUBLIC SCHOOL AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SEEN OVER THEIR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE. AND GET ON THE PHONE I
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE ON THE PHONE
LINE AND AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
WILL TAKE TEN MINUTES. IF YOU
ARE AND SUPPORT OUR OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE SEVEN ZERO
NOW. ONE MOMENT AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE AND SEVEN SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AT SEVEN SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KEEP UP.
OKAY. WILL MOVE ON. ALAINA
SEVEN TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS JOHN BOARD FROM
COSTA MESA THAT I'M A PROUD
GRANDMOTHER OF THREE HOME
SCHOOLERS AND I OPPOSE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR CHILDREN
THEY CAN THANK YOU THANK YOU
AGAIN TO AGAIN JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE JUST. TAKING OTHER
PEOPLE'S TIME. OKAY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. BUT NONE Q. UPPER
MOMENT ONE MOMENT. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE AT SEVEN OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SEVEN OH SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M SPEAKING MY
NAME IS. AN EDUCATOR FROM HOPE
BILL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. AND WE
WILL GO TO ALAINA THREE OH FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THEY MET THE
PATEA APPARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO GO TO LINE
OF SEVEN EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SEVEN EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
DILUTES HERE WITH THAT VOICE
SUPPOSED TO BE ACCEPTED
RESTRICTIONS IN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
VOTE TO LINE UP WITH SEVEN
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK MY NAME IS AMBER ROGER
AND I AM THE LEADER AT THE I.
LEAD CHARTER SCHOOLS
REPRESENTING SIX THOUSAND K.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT GO TO A LINE OF
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIRTY ONE HAS DROPPED TO ABOUT
THE LINE OF EIGHT TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DON'T KNOW
EMILY ROSENBERGER WITH ADDED
VALUE AND NOT FROM SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF EIGHT FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER WITH I. LEAD
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR DANNER AND I
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED BILL A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU.
MEXICO CAROLINA OF. THE MOMENT.
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SORRY THAT IT DROPS
OVER TO LINE OF EIGHT. THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT A
GREAT THING WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND FROM
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT SO LINE
OF SEVEN AND NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CAITLYN TALKED MORE AN APPARENT
AND ALSO A SPECIAL EDUCATION
EDUCATOR AT HIGHLY CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND I OPPOSE AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. THANK YOU IN
MEXICO TOWLINE AT SEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY
MATURE THEY DROP AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF NINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN
NINE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY RACHEL
AND I PROVIDE TALK. OPPOSITION.
THANK MEXICO TO TEN NINETY THE
ALLIED OF THE- YOUR- THREE NINE
TEN NINETY SIX FELINE IS OPEN.
BUT WE WILL MOVE ON TO AWAY OH
SAID YOUR LINE IS THE. FOR ONE.
YOUR OKAY YOU. OKAY. ALL RIGHT
WELL TO LINE OF SIX ONE LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MEGAN AND I'M
SCHOOLED IN CHARTER. NIGHTCAP
CLASS BASED HEARD SCHOOL MOM OF.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OKAY TO ALLOW
OF ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CHASE WITH MY
FATHER- COMMITTEE- STRONG
OPPOSE. THANK YOU MEXICO
TIMELINE OF ONE FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS MMHM I'M SORRY
THEY- I'M NOT QUITE A LINE OF
ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THEY DID TO ME. I
WOULD TALK. HELLO. ONE MOMENT.
NOT AT ALL AND I KNOW BUT I
THINK HALF OF. LAX THE- I WAS
TALKING ABOUT ALREADY MY HOPES
I HAD I GOT. BY MOMENT WHERE WE
THAT LINE. OKAY BOB. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU FOR THE. I'M
NOT OUCH WE TIME. WELL RIGHT.
ONE MOMENT IN THE FUTURE PLEASE.
YEAH BUT. NO ONE ELSE CARE LIKE
NO ONE REALLY AND WORK AT. WHAT
YOU KNOW MODERATOR OF IF THERE
AREN'T SPEAKING TO THE BILL YOU
MIGHT WANT TO PROCEED TO THE
NEXT CALLER SO WE GET AS MANY
COLORS IN AS POSSIBLE. I DON'T
HEAR ANYTHING FIRST. IN THE
MORNING AND I. THANK. RIGHT AND
THAT'S WHAT THE TO DO. ALL
RIGHT NUMBER. THE. NOT
FOLLOWING ROAD PROTOCOL.
CURRENTLY WE WILL GO BACK TO
THE LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
DON'T KNOW MUCH FOUR NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS COURTNEY
MENDEZ I AM A HOME SCHOOL MOM
OF FOUR THRIVING STUDENTS I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WERE GOING TO LINE UP OF ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT'S CHEAPEST- THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. VERY
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SET BROWN BOTH SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. FIRST
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TELL
AYE AND EIGHT FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH PENNY
HARRINGTON FROM BEST TO
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THANK YOU. IT YEAH. THEY'VE
BEEN. MEXICO CAROLINA OF BY
TWELVE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINES
ARE OPEN. HI AND CATHLEEN
WALKER AND I REPAIR IT AND ALSO
IT MIGHT LEAD SPEECH LANGUAGE-PATHOLOGIST AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. THIRTEEN THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF A
THIRD AT THUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M SORRY GREG HAYES ON BEHALF
OF OKAY PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
OPPOSITION. I DID FIVE. FOR
ITSELF BUT NEXT DOOR GO TO LINE
OF ONE OF FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AM JENNIFER CORNER
OF CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS AND
AYE OPPOSED AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
THANK YOU MODERATOR TIME IS UP
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BRING IT
BACK THANK YOU MODERATOR. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO- THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN CAPITOL
PARK WILL GO TO THE REMOTE
PARK IF YOU'RE GOING TO TESTIFY
REMOTELY WHAT YOU ARE TO DO IS
WALK UP THE MICROPHONE YOU
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
A POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY WE
HAVE TEN MINUTES SO BE QUICK SO
OTHERS CAN GET AND WE WANT TO
HEAR YOU. GO AHEAD. JUST NOT
GOING. I'M RETAIN AT MAMA FIVE
IN SACRAMENTO INCLUDING A
SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD AND I
OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU- MY NAME IS BECKY
MORALIS I'M A CALIFORNIA
CREDENTIALED TEACHER AND MOM OF
TWO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. MY NAME IS
CHAIRED HINES AND I AM A HOME
SCHOOL STUDENT AND I OPPOSE AB.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. LOUIS
SANTIAGO I'M A CREDENTIALED
TEACHER AND THE PARENT OF FOUR
CHILDREN ATTENDING AN ONSIDE
BASED CHARTER SCHOOL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. BUT MY NAME
IS NAOMI HINES AND FIFTH GRADE
HOME SCHOOLER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS SUSAN TO
PENSKE I AM A PARENT FROM
FULLERTON AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN. AND I AM.
I'M A PULL. TWELVE YES MY NAME
IS NICOLE YOUNG I'M FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA I AM THE
PARENT OF A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER- OUR SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS SCHOOLED BY A HOME
ONLINE CHARTER AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
JACOB BEATEN BENDER I'M A
GRADUATING STUDENT WHO HAS BEEN
WITH SOUTH SUTTER CHARTER
SCHOOL FOR MY ENTIRE LIFE AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHICH WOULD CLOSE MY SCHOOL. HI
MY NAME IS MERRY YOUR I AM A
RESIDENT OF A SIMPLE MIND. UGH
TIM GRAYSON IS DISTRICT. I AM
AN EMPLOYEE OF TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS. FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
MORE. I AM AM A BEATEN BENDER
SOUTH SUTTER CHARGER STUDENT-
STUFF THAT OUR CHARTER PARENT
FOR THIRTEEN YEARS I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. JEFF RICE
WITH THE A PLUS PERSONALIZED
LEARNING NETWORK ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY SEVEN
PERSONALIZED LEARNING PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS ALL OF WILL WHO
WILL BE HER HARM BY THIS BILL.
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND K.
TWELVE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU CARMAKERS BUILD
REGION WAS A. B. MY NAME IS
CASEY BEATING VENDOR. I AM A
SOUTH SIDER STARTED. SELF
SUTTER CHARTER SCHOOL STUDENT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IS THAT APPEARS TO BE. AFTER.
I'M JANET BEEN MENTOR I WAS
CELLS ARE CHARTER SCHOOL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RIGHT DO I GO. SO IT CAN YOU
SEE ME IN THE COMMITTEE. YEAH-
I LOOK HERE. WHAT EASIER TO
OPEN THE BUILDING PLEASE
PROCEED YOU HAVE IT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MOVE ON IF YOU DON'T
WANT TO IF YOU DON'T SHARE YOUR
OPINION WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MOVE ON. ALL RIGHT VERY MUCH IS
THIS THE START OF EDUCATION
VOWED TO GO DONALD. I'M VERY
AGAINST PLEASE MOVE ON. THIS IS
GOING TO GO INTO ANOTHER
WITNESS. PLEASE TO ANOTHER
WITNESS YEAH I'M AGAINST. HI
ROBERT MCGUIRE I AM GUARDIAN
AND HOMEMADE TO CATER TO MY
GRANDSON. AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. HARD TO HEAR BUT HE
OPPOSES THE BILL. HI I'M FAIR
SATTERFIELD MET CHARTER SCHOOL
PARENT AND EDUCATOR AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
GOOD IT'S
OUR TIME GOOD. I THINK. WELL
DONE. THAT'S UP FROM THERE YEAH
RIGHT. THAT'S OKAY THAT IS IT
FROM A- ZERO TESTIMONY STATION-
SO NOW WILL ASK THE AUTHOR
CLOSE ALL JUST QUICKLY PASS IT
ON TO MISS GARCIA BUT ALL I ONE
THING I AM- MOST NOTABLE THE
CONVERSATION TODAY IS THAT
PEOPLE THINK THIS BILL IS ABOUT
CLOSING ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOLS
YOU'RE BEING TOLD THAT. THAT'S
NOT FACTUAL THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
NOT TRUE. WILL IT GIVE THEM
DIFFERENT RULES TO FOLLOW
ACCOUNTABILITY- GOOD AUDITING
PRACTICES PRACTICES GOOD
GOVERNMENT PRACTICES YES BUT
THAT DOES NOT CLOSE. ANY ONLINE
CHARTER SCHOOL THIS IS ALL PART
OF A- AN AGREEMENT MADE TWO
YEARS AGO. TO PUT THE SEVERED
OFF- FOR TWO YEARS THUS THE
MORATORIUM WAS PLACED ON NEW
ONLINE CHARTER SCHOOL SO NOW IS
THE TIME THAT THAT
CONVERSATION. THAT IS WHAT WAS
CONTEMPLATED TWO YEARS AGO THAT
IS WHAT WE ARE DOING THIS
HEARING TODAY MISS GARCIA-
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
MISTER BENNETT FOR HIS COMMENTS
I THINK HE DID A GOOD JOB OF
SUMMARIZING. A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WE HAVE A LOT OF
PASSIONATE INDIVIDUALS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT GOOD
QUALITY. EDUCATION TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ARE
IMPORTANT SO I HOPE MOVING
FORWARD WE CAN FOCUS ON THAT TO
TRY TO ENSURE THAT TAX DOLLARS
ARE. PROTECTED WHILE STILL
ENSURING THAT PARENTS INSURING
THAT PARENTS HAVE CHOICE
INSURING THAT OUR- SPECIAL AT
THE DEATH OF THE QUALITY THAT
THEY NEED AND ALL OVER STUDNTS
INCLUDING OUR MOST.
MARGINALIZED STUDENTS I HAVE A
QUALITY EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL GAP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTED ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS TO COME. OUT WITH A
PRODUCTIVE AMENDMENTS OF THE
EXISTENCE OF HOW WE. CAN REACH
OUR COMMON GOALS THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU- WITH THAT WILL
GO TO THE SECRETARY I DON'T
HAVE THE MOTION BEFORE ME SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
IT
MEMBERS- FREESHEET THAT LET'S
LET US MOVE ON ADAMIS CORK
SOURCE AB EIGHT SIX FIVE AB
EIGHT SIX FIVE THAT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. RAPPERS AND. YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK SILVA THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
VERY COLD IN THIS ROOM STUFF
AND- AT ANY HOW I'M HERE TO
PRESENT THE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SIX FIVE WHICH REQUIRES VARIOUS
CHANGES TO THE CHILD CARE AND
DEVELOPMENT GENERAL. SERVICES
ACT RELATED TO ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO AND VIABILITY
OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. AS WE
KNOW THIS YEAR PARTICULARLY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
SOME OF OUR MOST VALUED FRONT
LINE WORKERS IN ORDER TO GET
SOME OF OUR PARENTS BACK TO
WORK SPECIFICALLY THE BILL WILL
ASSIST IN ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS WITHIN OUR STATE CHILD
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION SYSTEM
BY ALLOWING FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO BE REIMBURSED FOR
THE FULL AMOUNT TO THE
CERTIFIED HOURS. NOTED ON A
SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE
CERTIFICATE AND NOT ON
ATTENDANCE AGAIN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW THAT OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS NEED TO
COUNT ON MANY TIMES THEY ARE
BUYING SUPPLIES THEY ARE BUYING
MEALS THEY ARE BUYING UP
CURRICULUM MATERIALS FOR THE
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS THAT THEY
HAVE PLANNED ON. ALLOWING CHILD
CARE CONTRACTORS FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND SUBSIDIZE
FAMILIES THE USE OF ELECTRONIC
MEANS IN ORDER TO BEST MEET THE
NEEDS OF HE FAMILIES. THIS IS
PROBABLY SURPRISING TO US MANY
OF US WHO DO ONLINE BANKING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE ELECTRONICALLY
THAT- THIS GROUP HAS BEEN LEFT
OUT OF THAT. REQUIRE DIRECT
DEPOSIT FROM THE STATE TO THE
PROVIDERS. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
URGENT NEED TO PROTECT THANK
YOU IMPROVE AND ENSURE THE
VIABILITY OF CHILD CARE AND
EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS PRIMARILY WOMEN OF
COLOR SHOW UP EVERY DAY TO CARE
FOR OUR CHILDREN. RISKING
EXPOSURE TO THE VIRUS WILL
NEEDING TO FIND OTHER AND MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS FOR EVEN THEIR OWN
CHILDREN HELLO HOWEVER NEARLY
60% OF THESE CARE GIVERS
QUALIFY FOR PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE MOST OF THEM MAKE. NEAR
POVERTY WAGES IT'S UNACCEPTABLE
THAT WE DON'T PAY THE PEOPLE TO
WHOM WE ENTRUST. OUR YOUNGEST
CHILDREN SAFETY AND EDUCATION A
LIVING WAGE WELL AT THE SAME
TIME HAVE POLICIES THAT HINDER
THEIR VIABILITY THE SUBSIDIZED
CHILD CARE SYSTEM FURTHER HARMS
THE FISCAL HEALTH OF THE FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. BY ONLY
ALLOWING FOR REIMBURSEMENT WHEN
I FAMILY ACTUALLY SHOWS UP. AND
THIS IS DEVASTATING WHEN YOU
LOOK AT A MONTHLY PAYCHECK SO
AS WE HAVE BEEN HERE VERY LONG
TIME I WILL I WILL. ASK MY-
PEOPLE HERE THAT ARE GOING
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TO WEIGH IN
CRISTINA FOUR FROMMER WHO IS
THAT CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR THE CHILDREN'S COUNCIL OF
SAN FRANCISCO. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- GINA AND
FORTUNATELY IT'S UNABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY MY NAME IS MIKE I'M
A CHARLES LINE FOR PUBLIC
POLICY DIRECTOR I WILL BE
FILLING IN FOR HER TODAY- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- AGAIN MY NAME IS I IF
I WORK AT CHILDREN COUNTLESS
DAMPENED BISCO. AND INSEPARABLE
GO BY ADVOCATING FOR QUALITY
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
EMPOWERING FAMILIES. WITH
INFORMATION AND FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND BUILDING THE
CAPABILITIES EDUCATORS WE
ENSURE THAT EVERY CHILD IN SAN
FRANCISCO AT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL. I'M
HAPPY TO SHARE WHY WITH THE
COURT EIGHTY EIGHT SIX FIVE THE
MAIN FOCUS OF AB EIGHT SIX FIVE
THE FOUNDER FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. AT A STABLE AMOUNT
FOR KEEPING THE POTTERS FIELD
FALL FOR ONE OF CALIFORNIA
SPENT THE NIGHT FAMILIES. PRIOR
TO CO THAT UNITY AGENCIES ARE
YET UNIFIED THE SHORT COMING AT
THE CORE REASON MY FAMILY WITH
VARIABLE ARE UNSTABLE WORK
HOURS COULD NOT FIND CHILD
CARE. WHEN COATED HEAD ALBEIT
CENTRAL WORKERS SUCH AS THOSE
IN HEALTHCARE DEEPER MARKET
FIREFIGHTERS AND MORE WE'RE
STRUGGLING TO FIND A PROVIDER.
GOVERNOR NATHAN ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER REQUIRING THAT
CAN WITHOUT CARE PROVIDERS BE
REIMBURSED FOR THE CHILD CARE
SPOT AND NOT ON THE ATTENDANCE
OF THE FAMILY. WITH THE SAME
POLICY THAT EXISTS IN THE
PRIVATE MARKET BUT ALLOW
PROVIDERS MAINTAIN. A SOMEWHAT
STABLE BUDGET. I AREAS THAT
WERE BROKEN BEFORE HE CAME BACK.
DURING THAT. ONE SUCH. IS A
PROCESS IN WHICH- A BE WORKING
THERE FUNDING REMEMBER HER. AND
DISTRICT PROVIDERS THAN THE
MULTI DOLLAR ALLOCATION ARE
RECEIVED BY AGENCIES VIA MAIL
MAIL THIS IS EXTREMELY
OUTDATED. AB EIGHT SIX FIVE
ADDRESS KEEP WITH THEM UPDATE
IN ADDITION TO BASING
REIMBURSEMENT OFF OF THE ROLE
THAT. IT TAKES THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE NEARLY A
MONTH THE PRODUCT THAT THE
ALLOCATION AND THEN PRODUCE
HARD COPY CAT. THAT ARE THEN
PUT INTO FEMALE MALE FOR
EXAMPLE THE STATEMENT ENACTED
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD OF
THIS YEAR ARE STILL BEING
PROCESS PROCESS IN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE. AND NOT
EXPECTED TO BE RECEIVING. AND
DISTRIBUTED. OUT TO THE
PROVIDERS UNTIL MAY AT THE
EARLIEST. PROVIDERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY OPEN AND
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY THE COSTS
AND THEN BE REIMBURSED. THIS IS
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO PROVIDERS CLOSING
PERMANENTLY ALLOWING FOR THE
ELECTRONIC FUND PROCESS OR
DIRECT DEPOSIT OF OUR
ALLOCATION WILL HELP US GET
MONIES OUT QUICKER TO
PROVIDERS. FURTHERMORE EIGHTY
EIGHT SIX FIVE ELIMINATE THE
LIMITATIONS SURROUNDING CLOSURE
DAYS WHICH WILL INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES AROUND IN PROVIDER
PAYMENTS. EIGHTY EIGHT SIX FIVE
WILL ALSO ALLOW CONTRACTORS
LIKE EIGHT PIECE TO START
SMALLER THEY'RE FUND WHICH WILL
HELP STABILIZE THE FIELD PLEASE
NUMBER IS FIVE A LOT THE BETTER
AND MORE EFFICIENTLY THIRD
FAMILY THANK YOU THANK YOU. ARE
YOUR NEXT A WITNESS IN SUPPORT-
FROM- PSYCH THE NAME COBURN.
AND DINNER. I DON'T KNOW DAHLE
ON THEM- MY NAME DANNY COLDER
CEO OF THE CAL ALTERNATIVE
PROGRAM WITH THE AND FONG EIGHT
SIX FIVE CHAPTER EIGHT BUSINESS
CAL STEP CHILD PROGRAM SERVICE
HUNDRED THOUSAND BOTH CALIBER
IN DOWN YEARS NINE NINE AND
MEMBERS FILLED HAVE A BIG ISSUE
HI VERY SUCCINCT THOROUGHLY I'M
NOT GOING GO OVER. WHAT THEY
SAID SHE THINKS I WANNA HOW. I
DON'T THAT WERE. ABOUT A-
COMPRISED THAT AND BROWN WOMEN.
ARE CURRENTLY. THIRTY DOLLARS
THAT'S CENTS TO NINE FIFTY HOUR
THESE THE PROVIDE. TALKING
ABOUT. ADDITIONALLY LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU ADDITIONAL. WE'VE HAD
CHEN BOX IN THE MAIL OF VIRTUAL
SEVEN. MILLION DOLLARS. AND THE
TAKES ROUGHLY SIX WE TO GET
ROUGHLY. THOSE ARE THE REAL
LIFE ISSUES WE'RE DEALING WITH.
WITH THAT I JUST WANNA THANK
THE NUMBER COURT OFFICER CARRY
THE MUCH NEEDED LEAD TO. AND
I'M TO READ TO ANY. THANK YOU I
ANY ARE ONLY UP WILL I DON'T
SEE ANY OF. WITNESSES AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER QUEST. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY MISTER ALI. SECOND BY- BY
MISTER BENNETT SECOND AYE MR
BENNETT- YOU KNOW COMMITTEE
MEMBER QUESTIONS WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE UP
TO TEN MINUTES- ANYONE IN THE
ROOM OR STOP PINE IN THIS BILL
SEE NO ONE IN THE ROOM ON THE
PHONE LINE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES FOR UP TO TEN MINUTES.
THANK YOUR APPEARANCE A PORTER
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT SIX FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AT A. B. AB EIGHT. FIVE AND WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DONNA
HOFFMAN CALLING AND
REPRESENTING COUNCIL FOR A
STRONG AMERICA READY NATION
FIGHT CRIME INVESTING KIDS AND
MISSION READINESS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR
IN SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF. NINETEEN OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS SOME FUNNY THAT MONITORS ON
THE PARENT OF THREE WHO HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY. ONE CHARTER
SCHOOL IN THE DISTRICT HAVE
FAILED US AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AT THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF NINETEEN FIFTY
FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EVERYONE ON BEHALF OF CHILD
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE'LL
TRY LINE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU GO TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY IN THIS IN THE-
STATION IN THE CAPITAL PARK.
SENIOR PERSONS AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IN CALABAR.
WILL MOVE BACK TO THE AUTHOR
THE BILL'S MOVED SECONDED YOU
MAY CLOSE. JUST ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS COMMONSENSE
BILL. THANK YOU- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
O'DONNELL HI BUT ALL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE BENNETT BENNETT HI
DOLLY DOLLY I LEAK LEAK FIVE
MCCARTY. QUICK SILVA HI QUICK
SILVA FIVE THE BILL HAS. SIX
FOOT THROW SIX HOST IS OUT FOR
NOW MOVED TO. WE HAVE OTHER
BUSINESS STILL- WITHOUT
OBJECTION IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME WE ARE PUTTING A BILL
WHICH WAS PREVIOUSLY ON
CONSENT. BACK ON THE CONSENT
FILE THAT BILL IS AB EIGHT
EIGHT THREE AB EIGHT THREE
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT WILL BE
THE ORDER. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE SIX
SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS. TO
APPROPRIATIONS FILE ITEM THREE
AB TWELVE NINETY FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHT SIX THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB EIGHT EIGHT
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FOR DONALD FIVE
ALL AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
BENNETT BENNETT HI DOLLY. DALLI
I LEAVE. THE AYE MCCARTY QUICK
SILVA HI QUICK SILVA HI. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS SIX VOTES
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SIX VOTES
IT IS OUT. OF IT WE DO HAVE
BILLS WE HAVE NO BILLS ON CALL-
WE'LL WE'LL NOW DURING THE
HEARING AND LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADD ONS FOR ADAMS. THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED. OKAY WE
WILL START AND FILE ORDER FOR
CATALANS FIRST IS FILE ITEM TO
NUMBER AB. THREE ZERO NINE FIVE
DALLI DALLI HI. NEXT IS. FILE
ITEM FOR A. B. NINETY TWO DALLI
DALLI I. NEXT IS FILE ITEM FIVE
AB FIVE SIX EIGHT DALLI DALLI I
MCCARTY QUICK SILVA HI QUICK
SILVA HI. NEXT IS A. B. I'M
SORRY FILE ITEM. NINETY
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. LEET LEE
HI. NEXT IS FILE ITEM TWELVE A.
B. EIGHT SIX FIVE MCCARTY. IS
NOT PRESENT. THAT IS ALL HAVE
AT THIS TIME MR MCCARTY IS
MISSING FROM A FEW BILLS. ARE
YOU GOING TO HEAR. RIGHT NOW WE
ARE DONE WITH SOME BILLS. YES.
OKAY THE NINETEENTH JUST
MCCARTY. ALL. NO. FIFTY S. B.
YES. WE SHOULD PACK UP THOUGH
AND BE READY TO LEAVE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU. OF MONEY. FOLLOWING
A LONG. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE POLICY IT SAID NO
THAT'S- NOT. ABOUT. I'M HERE.
THAT IS RIGHT YOU MIGHT CAN YOU
HEAR ME. OUR FIRST IS FILE ITEM
TO AB THREE OH NINE MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY FIVE. NEXT IS FILE ITEM
FIVE AB FIVE SIX EIGHT MCCARTY
BY MCCARTY I. NEXT IS E. FILE
ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT SIX FIVE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I. AND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY HI THANK YOU. OKAY.